Heat. Heat.
Hey,
heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Your path to glory starts at your local
Nexus night at your local store all over
country, all over the country, and all
over the world. Battle at your local
game store in a casual, relaxed
environment where you can kind of learn
the ropes and get yourself all set up
for possibly being the next regional
champion. Check it out at
locator.ribbound.uvsgames.com/events
uvsgames.com/events
or scan the QR code.
All right, folks. It is all built up to
this here in the regional qualifier in
Las Vegas. I'm Jim Davis. That's
Kasanova. This is the round of eight.
Our players, we are down to eight
players still in the tournament vying
for the championship. The halls starting
to get packed up. So, if you're not in
top eight right now, if you're not in
the round of eight, uh you got to get
out of here. But for these players, they
have a lot more work to do. In top
eight, our number one at the top, Pris,
look, I got to say, look, you said you
got to get out. Don't get out of here.
Get over to the the section where you
can watch the match. Build the crowd up.
You can't let Bolognia outdo us with
that Polish crowd cheering and chanting.
We got to get hype up for this top
eight. Prismaticism, the first seed on
Draven. A lot of Draven for this one
overall.
>> Yeah, a lot of Draven for sure. We got
TT in second. We have the the five
players or I'm sorry, there are five
players who four players who drew in.
Then we have the one player who won in.
Uh and then we have our three X2s. These
are the players. There are a lot more
players than this at 11 and two. So our
three tiebreaker winners. Column you saw
play wonderfully on camera. Allen of
course our champion from last weekend
and Shisel. And uh we got an Ezreal. We
got Aurelia. And we got a Jax.
>> Where did Wait, where Jax?
>> Wait, hold on. Wait. Check the script. I
I don't where did this Jax I mean we did
see him winning in on camera and that's
not that surprising but it is a surprise
that Jax is here and at the top of the
tables cuz this is not a legend that has
shown very much success. One top eight
in China over the four different events
that happened there and Bolognia not
nearly there to be seen. There was one
at 10 three that won the best of that
did pretty well but Jax not anticipated
to be a top eight threat.
>> Yeah, we hear the finance report here is
the counter strikes are sold out in the
hall. Uh so uh really really cool stuff.
Very very exciting. Top eight for all of
our players. 13 rounds have come down to
this a championship and a little bit
more. Here's our bracket. So look at
these matchups here. We have a lot of
Draven. So break down the match up. What
do we What do we have going on here?
>> Yeah. So we got a Draven mirror up top.
Prismaticism versus Shisel. We've seen
them both on camera. Prismaticism on
that miracle Draven. Shisel uh I believe
was on mid-range earlier when we did see
him play. So, it is going to be kind of
that pseudo mirror match up between the
two. Then, Sami Sherman versus the very
best gamer. We saw the very best gamer
take down Colin Kaiser to stop his kind
of uh earlier run that he was having.
You know, he's undefeated, ended up
10-1, ended up going into that uh
winning in against the very best gamer
and losing to the Jack. So, Draven, a
matchup that he's quite familiar with.
And then it is Aurelia v Draven and
Draven v Ezreal to round it out. Of
course, a lot of Draven across the
board, but these few extra survivors,
none of them are going to have to take
each other down. They're all against
Draven.
>> So, the big question here is, of course,
who do you got in each side of the
bracket? Now, some of these players are
hard to root against. Of course, our
defending champion Allen Pris as well.
Who do you have in each bracket?
>> So, I think for me, Pris has been
playing outstanding all day. Took the
one loss earlier on to Colin Colin
Kaiser. Uh, but other than that, has
been impeccable. I think Pris, it's his
time to finally get a win. Uh, you know,
he he topped in Houston on Teemo, tops
in Bolognia on the Miracle Draven, comes
back again, immediately makes it back to
the top eight. His only loss in Bolognia
was to Allen's EQ, making it then, and
then eventually losing to Ghostaster uh
to get knocked out of top eight. So,
from there, Pris is just he's he's been
looking for it for a long time. I think
he's going to get there. When I look at
the bottom side, I mean, I look at a
rematch between Allen ZQ and Colin
Kaiser happening potentially in that
semifinals, and those are the two
players I really have my eyes on uh
fighting their way towards that grand.
But untimed rounds, Allen's EQ, Ezreal,
Gem, I don't think there is anything
more powerful in Riftbound right now.
And odds on for me, I would predict
Allen a winner.
>> So yeah, that Colin Allen match was
unbelievable. uh probably match of the
weekend so far for me. But what about
the very best gamer? So, kind of our
wild card here. So, you know, Draven, of
course, we had Ezra win last weekend.
Aurelia doing quite well also. The wild
card is Jax. Very best gamer. And uh
kind of the odd one out. Does very best
gamer have a chance here with Jax. Well,
I would say, you know, he made it all
the way to the top eight with Jax. His
name is the very best gamer. I mean,
imagine if he had a real weapon. He
would be unstoppable at this point. But
I will say he took down Colin Kaiser's
Draven earlier who looked infallible
throughout Swiss was at 100. Finally
falters in the last two rounds. One of
those players to take him down is the
very best gamer. If he can take down
Collins Draven, who are these other
Dravens for him to to take on? Bring
them on. I think he's ready for it.
There's one more Draven lined up. And
that's kind of a kind of the the heart
uh just awesome match. We've got Sam
first major Riftbound event. So, kind of
like the Cinderella stories were what I
was looking for. There we go. Uh, very
best gamer playing Jax. Sam, first major
Riftbound tournament making top eight.
You know, it's cool to see both sides of
the coin. You know, Pris and Allen
coming off last weekend of Bolognia and
just, you know, showing a level of
domination. Uh, it's still a fairly new
game ribbound, but just we haven't
really seen, you don't see often in card
games, you know. So, we have the
domination of the players who've been
really doing well, and we have some uh
some new faces as well. Yeah, there's a
side thing happening here as well when
we look at this top eight. Very best
gamer. That's the best of Jacks right
there, right? There's no other jacks in
the top eight.
>> Deluxe Phil Cheese. That's the best of
Aelia right there. Congrats as well. And
Allan did say he was going to win four
out of four Ezreals.
There's Ezreal number two.
>> It's It's so funny cuz you say that and
I just laugh cuz it sounds like an
absurd thing to say, but if someone can
do it, it's probably him.
>> He's halfway there,
>> right? Like already. So, um, the job's
not done.
>> Unbelievable. A fantastic top eight. And
of course, like I said, we we are on
time. This is going to be an awesome
awesome view of some really, really high
level Riftbound, which I'm absolutely
super excited for. So, um, we're getting
ready, getting things all set up. We
also got a little bit of a little a look
in at our best of as well. So, kind of
lost in this bracket is there are a
whole bunch of other winners in this
tournament. There were prizes, you know,
top 16, top 32 players qualifying for
the regional. It's in the name regional
qualifier of course. Uh but there's also
all the best of for all of the legends
and we see you know there are a few of
them here. We're going to see our our
our Draven best of might end up winning
the tournament or uh falling in the uh
in the in the grand semi-finals. Uh but
all these other legends uh these
players, you know, maybe they were out
in there not in day one, maybe they were
deep into day two. We saw some really
cool day two runs. Lux,
>> Victor, you know, Rexai, these players
fell a little short. You know, we had
some exciting matches early in the day
of of Rexi and Lux, but they still were
in the running for the best of Let's
take a look and see how they did.
There's a Voli Bear. There's the Yasawo.
Look at all of these smiling faces. I
see no veggies in there. Won the civer.
It's one of our top eight players from
Houston.
Amazing work from all these. That was
Nightingale. We saw him on stream for
the Arya. It looks like he ended up
picking it up long term.
>> So cool. Uh this billionaire ended up
picking up his Ye. He's been trying to
get that for a while.
>> Or fantastic.
Annie, that's just so cool. I'm sorry.
Got LS in there also.
>> Did get the Teemo.
>> Got the Teemo. Fantastic. So really,
really cool to see. And there you go. So
Night Andale won the AI at 9 and four.
Kenu the Annie at 93 and one. Rock low
is here 11 and two bubbled. That's a
virtual top eight. You know, that's the
record that made top eight, but of
course a lot of folks didn't make with
tiebreers. We got Darius uh Carry Boy
Denny at 9 and four. Really, really cool
to see. And uh I wonder how many level
twos we'll see in this players who had
that kind of virtual top eight. Le blind
monk played by Silverman at 5 and three.
Just missed day two. And speaking of
just missing day two, uh Lafenite,
Leona, Radiant Dawn at 52 and one. Can't
get much closer to day two than that. Oh
yeah,
>> we got Damon XGGG, our Lucian winner at
10 and3. Vexter Lux Lady Luminosity.
That was not the Lux player we saw on We
had
>> No, we had Grappler on. Grappler not
quite able to beat out there. It might
have been even in tiebreakers. I know at
one point Grapp was 9 and two.
>> Then we got Villionaire Master Ye Wu
Bladesman 10 and three. A bit of a near
miss. Sly, Misfortune, Bounty Hunter,
eight and five. Reasonable enough. Luna
Sky or 10 and3 or that seems crazy. I
did not realize there was an or making
that deep of a run. That is amazing. And
I I want to call it V. If I'm
remembering properly, this this is not
the one that we on stream. Of course, V
I heard was running yellow Rex eye champ
Zone and I was very interested in the
brew. I I am looking out for when that
gets published because Vu was cooking up
something spicy that we never got a
chance to check out that I I really
wanted to. And it just goes to show if
the stories kind of go beyond what you
even see on coverage, you know, and when
you're able to walk the hall and peek
around. Uh and I actually saw that
probably that or player cuz it was an or
player in your top tables in one of the
last rounds. Uh so I can only assume it
was that or player. Uh but you know, the
story is behind the story. There's so
much more going on in the tournament
itself. So many players, but the players
we're focusing on now, there are eight
of them. We are in the round of eight
and we have our very first match.
Speaking of Jacks, speaking of Sam
Sherman and uh and Charie Low, ready to
rock and roll. Let's look at this Jack's
list. The very best gamer Jack Scram at
Arms. Well, so one of the big things
that we had coming into this week is
there was that announcement of some rule
clarifications. And one of the big
winners of that rule clarification was
Jacks. Uh being able to use the Jack's
ability to attach an equipment that is
already equipped to a unit back to that
unit. Essentially unattach it and
reattach it with the uh the the second
part of Grandmaster at arms. And you
think, well, that doesn't feel like
that's good at all or make any sense.
Why would I want to do that? Well, there
are two big reasons. Aphilios has an
when I am attached trigger that is able
to give a buff to a unit is able to
ready two runes or channel a rune and
then the other side of it is brutalizer.
When it is attached it gives a plus two.
So by doing this you're actually able to
kind of reinitialize that brutalizer and
gain a lot of value. And I think this is
one of those things that can really help
Jax find an even better place in the
meta. On top of that, you do have Jacks
Unmatched in the champion zone that is
turning all of these gear into combat
tricks which can provide just an insane
amount of value throughout the game. And
the final thing I want to call out and
one of the biggest reasons that I felt
that Jax maybe could one day find a
place and I wasn't sure that it would be
so soon making his way into the top
eight is Counterstrike. such an
incredible signature spell in its
ability to help you either win combats
where you get very favorable trades or
guarantee a hold or even in a pinch stop
spell decks from dealing with your
units. Awesome stuff here. The
brutalizer one too, you often see
players kind of get stuck with
brutalizer. What am I going to do with
it? So that ruling very very good. And
we have up against Sam D. Sherman our
Draven player.
>> Yeah. And I mean this is just very
standard mid-range. We talked about the
Ferris 4runner being very good into
spell decks. What I would say is Jax is
very much not a spell deck. However,
this is still a lot of might that Jax
may have some issues dealing with over
time. One of the big things where they
have to look out for are going to be the
rebukes. Now they're running into green
here. Not so fast becomes a very big
tool at dealing with what is normally a
massive threat against unisbased
strategies. All right, so we got a big
match here. We've seen Sam on camera.
We've also seen uh very best on camera
as well. Now we see them battling each
other in this best of eight round of
eight.
>> Best of eight. Let's go. No, of course
the round of eight
>> and Sam D. Sherman on the right. Now we
see some deck list here. Is this an open
deck list top eight?
>> Uh yeah, it looks like it. Yeah, open
deck list top eight. It looks like that
was both of them going through it. Uh, I
think Sam was asking, "What does this
card do?" Uh, when reading it off of the
piece of paper and, uh, you know, when
you're playing the side, the rogue deck
that your opponent says, "What does this
card do?" You have to feel a little bit
good about that. Ready to be like,
"Okay, my opponent does not have much
experience in a matchup that I probably
have a ton of reps in because this is
Jax playing against the most popular
deck in the tournament, Draven. I would
venture the very best is played against
Draven probably one or two times this.
>> Yeah, maybe maybe a few times.
>> Yeah, maybe maybe once twice.
>> Yeah, maybe once on camera against Colin
Kaiser and actually picking up a win
there.
>> So, we got Sam on the right side. We got
very best gamer on the left. Top eight
action. Sam the fourth seed. Very best
the fifth seed. Treasure Hunter is a
start for Sam going right over to Lucian
on very best gamer side. And we got big
game. These players, you know, it's it's
a big challenge to make top eight, but
there's still a lot of work to be done.
These players want to hoist that trophy.
Hunter in. Here's a gold.
>> And on the board, first blood goes to
Sam. We see a Draven. We see a different
roll out. Yeah. Treasure hunter reavers
row. Very great start to infinitely
generate that gold. It makes it really
easy cuz when you defend, you just run
away. As Draven, uh, your opponent
doesn't get to draw when you lose a
combat. So, you're happy to just run
away with the tail between your legs,
pick up some additional gold, and make
sure you have no rune issues going
forward throughout the game. As we do
have a bone shiver get slammed down, and
it is going to be Jax just going to
activate that to equip it for cheap. You
don't have to pay the power cost, just
the one rune to equip the bone shiver.
And that is going to be a rune, a
conquer, a ready for Lucian. He gets to
come home and evade combat. Lucian very
good for any deck in orange when playing
against Draven to try and evade combat
as much as possible.
>> Yeah, and makes a lot of sense, you
know, with Lucian being so good against
Draven and Draven being so popular.
Avoid that combat. We've seen we've seen
the avoid combat thing across multiple
decks playing against Draven in various
ways. How can I avoid the combat step?
And uh Lucian does that quite well. So
going back Sam's way, two more runes.
Draven ready to rock and roll. Get a
whole point on the hunter. Sam to two.
Very best at one. Gonna read that bone
shiver.
>> He's rocking the uh participation promo
bone shiver that maybe he got yesterday
morning or or Friday morning whenever he
came in and registered.
>> Pretty cool feeling. Register your deck
was down one card. I'll get that one.
Don't you worry.
>> So Sam surveying and you're totally
right in that you know Sam super ready
to play against Draven. Has played a
bunch of mirrors. You heard the
interview. You know played against Raven
a ton preparing against all the various
versions. uh you can't really prepare
against every legend, you know, so you
pick up the top ones, you prep your
matchups, you prep your plans. How many
games do you think Sam has played
against Jax just overall?
>> Uh it's very possible zero.
>> Uh I'm not going to say it's zero. It's
it's also possible he's played a few,
but Jax is one of those legends where I
think a lot of players coming in with
their prep may have actually zero reps
into. And I think that's part of the
edge that Very Best Gamer is finding as
well, right? When you get to play one of
these rogue decks that's still quite
strong, it's less likely that your
opponent is going to know what you are
up to. And so far, it has led to a top
eight for very best gamer in this
tournament.
>> See if he can take it any further than
that.
>> The rogue deck edge is awesome. So, we
see Dra come in taking over the
monastery and following up with a Ferris
4Runner. And that is a lot of might.
Yes. So, you know, in green and orange,
no rebukes, no fight or flights. Still
hard to get this thing off the board in
a clean manner.
>> Come back. Very best gamers way.
Lucian's ready up. A lot of runes to
work with.
Treasure hunter also went home and made
a gold. So, a solid stand happening here
on the monastery.
>> Admiring the I got one of those, too.
Hey, this is really
>> That's pretty cool.
>> Hey, that was a really great
participation promo we got, guys.
>> Cool card.
>> We'll add the Blade of the Rune King to
the deck next.
>> Yeah, that
>> top a promo.
>> That's uh that's a nice one.
>> Really showing off
our top eight players all getting that
promo. The winner getting the uh the
special promo.
>> One of the more unique cards you can own
in this game. So, here is Lucian coming
in to Reverse Row.
>> That's a point.
>> Two points. very best gamer.
We're going to see a ready.
Saw the rune come in as also thanks to
bone shiver.
And now is this a hit and run or is this
a stay on reaver's row? Got to imagine
it's a hit and run.
>> Yeah, it's very likely run. I mean, you
definitely don't want to give up the
Lucian and especially with developing
Jax Unmatched. Yes, there are a few
runes available to maybe play around and
defend the Lucian holding at the
Reavers, but three runes only is a
little scary.
Very best gamer is going to go for it.
He always has the out of if Sam is
presenting more than he is comfortable
with, he can take the Reaver's Row and
and dip. But this at least just does not
allow the treasure hunter to just walk
in by her lonesome and take this down.
The the fear for me would potentially be
switcheroo and the question is is that
in the main deck and reading through
here it's not. There is a switcheroo in
the sideboard for Sam and with uh the
open deck list they had at the start
there. Uh very best game knows he does
not have to worry about switcheroo in
game one for treasure hunter walking.
>> Different uh different vibes once you
have open deck list. You know now we're
in the top eight and now you can take a
second. you have you're untimed so you
have more time to kind of just take a
second take it all in and you have that
info of the open deck list you can't
look at it during the game before the
game you get a good look at it and know
what you got to play around so
>> we see stack deck was a hold point also
>> on the monastery putting Sam to four and
very best to two so this you know
defending the reaver's row stops the
fifth point which is one of the most
awkward points anyway
so Sam working it through. We are
untimed. Players do need to play at a uh
a good pace. Hunter will just move over
to the monastery making another gold.
Yeah, I mean Sam is very ahead on points
currently 4-2.
So there is the luxury of just
developing if Sam decides could even
retreat and that looks like what he was
considering. But I don't mind holding
still as long as uh some amount of runes
are being kept up. Uh, however, if Sam
just wants to go for a full deploy, not
too bad an idea to just bring everything
back, look to conquer to six on the next
turn.
>> All right, so yes, we see Darius ready,
but just get a Darius play hopeful and
say go. So Hunter hangs out saying that
gold is very important. Not going to be
too good at defending. Uh, but wanted
the gold looks like. So powerful
backline for Sam. We get a hold for our
very best gamer. Up to three. Lucian
ready. Jax ready. And with this Jackson
play, it changes the texture of a game a
lot.
>> Yeah, it turns every single one of those
equipment in hand into a reaction speed
spell. And what I mean by that is they
gain quick draw with this Jax Unmatched
on the board. Stellicorn going to be
placed into the Reaver's row potentially
just to get a trigger so that she can
retreat. Jax going to swap the bone
shiver over so Jax can go in and get an
additional rune. That is now already 12
runes uh that Jax has available at this
point. And I was wondering if we got a
little bit of info about the texture of
the hand because very best gamer did not
respond to the uh trigger of the
treasure hunter moving by playing any
gear at reaction speed. So I was curious
if there were none in hand, but I think
various gamer was still just trying to
play safe around that potential Darius
running into the Lucian. So held off and
it is going to be a challenge taking
down the Darius as well. So yeah, great
great here. Challenge of course plays
fantastic with equipment. You go big.
You set up a little fight and Darius
going down
>> now. Jack's hanging out. Going back
Sam's way. So it is 424.
Stellor very nice on reverse row but has
to back out. Get a draw also. Both
players will draw. One for the combat
win, one for the move. Lot of lot of
might in the back line for Sam.
A lot of runes available also. So both
these players have a ton of resources.
Sam going to work it through.
Might in play. Cards in hand.
Sam is uh first major riffbound
tournament. Finding himself here if it's
OP eight. And you got to wonder, you
know, what's the what's the mental
state, you know, like are you just happy
to be here? Are you nervous? Are you uh
just you know playing relaxed you know
with no real pressure you know different
uh different folks react different ways
>> same for very best gamer it's like have
you reached your goals already you are
the best of jacks right
>> you've made top eight this is certainly
exceeded your expectations coming into
the event and the interview I had with
him it was very clear that top eight was
not something on the table for him but
he said he did want to prove this
username that he is in fact the very Oh,
>> it says it right there. It's just
written out. So, stack deck.
>> Definitely not.
>> Sam is a lot to work with here.
>> This has got to be the feelood match of
the uh of the top eight.
>> Oh, for sure.
>> Almost certainly. But for Sam, a lot of
the job not done being a Draven player,
the best of You're going to have to keep
fighting for that. Now, you can feel
good about a top eight, about a
qualification to regionals, but there is
so much more
>> on the line.
opponent get down to their last card
ability for
>> they seem very friendly with each other.
>> Yeah, they're having fun.
>> Yeah, back and forth.
>> They're having a good time. They are
very very happy to be here and of course
must have played extremely well all
weekend, you know. Um you could say, you
know, first tournament Sam is playing
other games has is experienced gamer.
Very best gamer has to be good because
of the tag. And then also if you're will
if you're
>> if you're willing to take, you know,
kind of a rogue deck in, you know, go
best of hunting, um you better make sure
your list is tuned up and you're ready
to battle. and uh battled all the way
here into fifth place. So here's Darius.
>> Yeah, big thing I'm looking at now is
how can very best gamer potentially keep
a hold because preventing Sam from going
to six here is the name of the game.
That is what opens up the door for very
best gamer to find a win in this game
one. He's behind on point tempo. He just
went to four. Sam went to four last
turn. Gets to go to six this time around
and push to end on the following turn.
Counter Strike would be a house to try
and defend against the push onto the top
battlefield. Seven might on that Jax for
now.
>> Seven can be contested by Draven, but if
you need to push over, Sam will have to
commit more and that's when
Counterstrike can find a potential
blowout. So Draven moves in, takes the
win against the Herder, which will
retreat and draw a card. So Reaver's
Row, you know, working both ways here.
obviously works in DR Draven's favor
most of the time, but the herder are
getting a little value as well with so
many runes in play. The very best game
are happy to see more cards. And now,
like you're saying, Sam needs to try to
figure out how to navigate this combat
up top at the monastery with the jacks.
Counter-strike a possibility. And of
course, any equipment as well, also with
quick draw.
Both players thinking it through. Look
at it. Four runes up for Jacks. Is it
four or five? There's a little bit
stacked. I think it's four. I see four,
too.
And we see stack deck. You see another
Nox hopeful. Look, looks like an axe as
well. So, a lot of options both, you
know, as far as you can just cast stack
deck and start there. Or if you want all
these runes for other things, you know,
most things in Draven do come in twos.
So,
Sam really thinking it through.
>> Yep. spinning axe very important piece
of this puzzle plus three going to allow
to bump over a lot of the potential
responses from very best gamer.
So
>> moving in. Here's forerunner. Here's
Noxious. 10 coming into the jacks.
>> 10 into seven.
>> First action going to be tapping two.
Is that going to be the counter strike.
>> Thinking it too. Thinking it through.
>> Counter strike.
>> All right, there's the counter strike.
So choose a unit. The next time that
unit will be dealt damage this turn,
prevent it and draw a card.
>> Tom, uh, all damage happens at the same
time in combat.
>> So, the 10 damage being presented here
by Sam just will not happen
>> to the JS back to you.
>> Instead, Jax will be able to kill the
4Runner off.
>> And now the remaining unit will get
pushed back, right?
>> Yes. Decides instead to leave the
4Runner says you'll get the mechs. I
don't want you to have the mechs. just
going to take out the hopeful to
actually make Sam have less might.
>> Yes, less might overall. You know, if
you can block the the the mechs inside
the 4Runner, 4Runner still, you know,
still hanging around, but less total.
And now we see another move in. So, here
comes Darius. Seven to seven.
Counter-strike is the next damage. So,
this one is a valid one unless there is
a a guardian angel at quick draw.
reaction speed.
>> That puts Jax to eight, but the spinning
axe will come through. That will allow
Sam to win the combat and get rid of the
guardian angel. But very best gamer able
to retain Jax Unmatched. Very important
to keep Junk Jax Unmatched around
because it is this chosen champion that
allows you to play these equipment at
reaction speed with the quick draw. It
is not your legend letting you do that,
right? This is the chosen champion. So
it completely shifts the texture of the
deck when you lose unmatched.
>> Yeah, one of the issues these equipment
decks do tend to have is they play at
slow speed where you know you have an
equipment in play, your opponent can
kind of look at the equipment, add up
the numbers and see if they can beat it.
But quick draw making it tricky giving a
lot more flexibility.
So Sam with a good turn up to six points
and on a pretty strong presence on both
battlefields
>> and last piece is going to be knock to
the back So four more might says go.
We're going very best gamers way.
Jacks Lucian Stellicorn
two runes
and
>> I'm missing.
>> Okay. Oh, hold on a second here. So 3 6
7 8 9 10 11. So we have uh 11 runes here
in play. There actually was a judge
call. So apparently uh the 12th rune was
stuck in very best gamers deck box. So
kind of a silly dexterity error. Very
little to be gained from that. So judges
issued a warning uh and just simply took
the rune and shuffle it into the the one
card rune deck. Uh and we play on. So
warning little bit of a miscue. Very
little, you know, possibility for uh for
any kind of abuse. So how about this?
That spinning axe looks cool. Hey, can I
have that? Yeah, Ashan, steal the
spinning axe. You can still move this
around
uh with the Jax Legend ability. Usually,
it's really tough to actually move it,
but Jack's legend does kind of let you
use Axan in this way where you can start
to move the weapon around. And now we
have a Jax with a spinning axe.
>> That is awesome.
>> Well, he said, "Imagine if you had a
real weapon and then that's a real
weapon." So, Jax with a spinning axe.
That is very threatening.
>> My equipment's cool. Your equipment's
cool.
>> You know what? Sounds great.
>> It's so cool. Why don't you come in and
take a look at it? So, Charm, Draven
over. Draven's got no shot there. So,
Draven's down also. And a monumental
swing of a turn. Uh, Axshan stealing
stuff. Charm pulling in. Stellicorn
moving to Reverse Row. Draw a card and
uh, of course, Stellor fantastic on
Reverse Row. Even if it gets pushed back
and not very best gamer up to that all
important six. Now, Sam is also on six.
The question now becomes, can Sam break
for those last two points?
Yeah, that extra draw is going to be
very important. There's a lot of runes
available. I mean, this is the great
thing about this Jax stack is it it
often is very power like it's able to
keep a lot of runes around and
especially when we saw that early bone
shiver, you know, because Jax doesn't
have to pay the upfront cost of power.
Bone Shiver is a lot more effective in
this deck because it doesn't go minus
one before you can ever go plus one. And
because you can move it with the jacks,
you can conquer with one unit, move it
to another, conquer again, get a bunch
of runes, and it actually ramps very
effectively in this deck where it
struggles in a lot of other ones. So,
we're going to see a reinforce
on the top on the monastery, but here's
a thunders song. So, if you got things
to play, you got to play them now. All
those equipments are a quick draw. It is
reaction speed, so they can come down
and it doesn't really nullify the
effectiveness that much. Yeah, and most
things are reaction speed in this deck.
Uh because the equipment are when you
have unmatched. Also, a lot of your
other tricks in combat are things like
discipline, that's at reaction speed.
Counter strike, that's at reaction
speed. A lot of the things in this deck
are just going to be at reaction speed.
>> We're going to see that draw. So, he
does said that's it though, just the
discipline.
>> Oo. Okay. So, plus on Lucian. So, now we
have a total count. We've got Jax is at
what? Five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10
on the jacks
>> and five on the Lucian.
>> So 15.
>> Sam does math like me. He said, "This is
five. This is a million." That's how I
do it as well, right?
>> But uh a million, 10, 15. All falls to
rebuke. And that's a huge one. So
Shiver falls off, the spinning axe falls
off also. Uh and now Lucian on his
lonesome. This is looking a bit scary
for very best gamer who's currently
unable to cast any spells. Here's the
4Runner. Lucian's down.
>> Draw a card for the combat and noxious
hopeful coming in. There it is. Game
number one goes to Sam. Uh, stealing the
axe was really, really cool, but just
not enough. And the thundersong says,
>> "This turn is all mine."
>> Yeah, it's not the first green deck I've
seen struggle with Brin here into
Rebuke. I think uh there's a certain uh
fire below the mountain that uh has a
little bit of trouble with that exact
combination as well. And that is another
deck very built around single large unit
with a bunch of gear. Uh that is been
the main issue for a lot of these types
of builds because you can't have the not
so fast as an out. And it's the same
problem for Jax, but Jax's a lot faster
in the early game than that
affforementioned or deck. And so there
is still a lot more room to not get
completely juiced by it when that does
come around. All right, so we're going
to game two here. And uh my turn.
>> We got Obelisk of Power for Sam and
Sunken Temple for very best gamer. Very
best gamer now down a game. Has to win
two in a row or his tournament is over.
A great tournament it has been if that
is the case. But very best gamer is not
done yet.
>> Yeah, it's very best gamer. Not h I'm
happy with the top eight gamer.
>> Yeah, it's the most chill top eight
demeanor I think I have seen in my
entire life by the way.
So here's Lucian, weapon master, pop it
up. Knox hopeful on the side of Sam.
Jack's hanging out champ zone.
We'll see the the purple spells are
really good against equipment. You know,
the ability to to fight or flight or
rebuke against uh you know, when you're
kind of going Voltron on one big unit.
Uh very very potent. And that's where
being in green helps Jax a lot, right?
Because you you have the answers to
those spells. You've got the defy for
the fight orflight. got the not so fast
for the rebuke. Now that's where of
course Brin here became a big problem in
that last game preventing even if there
was a not so fast in hand no way to
answer it as the Brin here had stopped
that from coming down. So being in green
doesn't solve everything but it does
mean that you actually have a little bit
more game into those tricks than a lot
of other decks actually do. Uh and it's
why green is kind of snuck around as
finding some good purchase in the metag
game especially with Aurelia. But
Aurelia kind of cheats cuz she's got
purple as well.
have the purple cards and the cards good
against purple cards. That's a good
recipe. It's a It's a good combination.
Playing the good stuff with the stuff
that's good against the good stuff. So,
Rebuke goes to hand. Sam agrees. It's a
good card in the matchup. Knox hopeful
hanging out. Dven in the champ zone.
Also,
now the problem is can the hopeful
really afford to get in here or is there
too much risk of reprisal?
>> Yeah, I mean there there's a lot of risk
of moving it in, right? Uh you I think
at this point for Sam uh just developing
on the back line and looking to maybe go
to four on the next turn is a little bit
more attractive. Uh the other option is
to fully attempt to hold like full send
hopeful put Draven there say you're not
beating 10. Uh but I think it's a little
bit soft. This is into orange. Punch
first is a card that can exist but I
believe this was a zero punch one punch
first deck in the main one in the side.
Punch is an interesting card because in
the Draven match up, it is good. Uh,
however, against purple, punch can have
some issues. There's there's push,
there's rebuke. Um, so sometimes it's a
little bit tough to decide whether or
not you'd want to actually play around
those punches. And I'm curious if the
various best gamer sites them in or out
or just keeps one in this matchup. I
think all three have merit uh to to be
decisions to be made.
>> There's some gamesmanship there, too,
because you're right. They are going to
be against Flash. Uh, I'm sorry, I'll
flash a fighter fight, things like that.
Uh, but because they're weak, Sam might
assume they're not there. And if you
assume punch first is not there, punch
first can be a devastating blowout.
>> Yeah, but Sam did end up just going for
that. I will just chill. We'll play
back. We'll start to build the base.
Very best gamer is going to get to go
collect a buff from that Warmogs running
in, running away with the Lucian, and
start to develop Jax Unmatched.
>> All right, so Jax is in. As long as Jax
is in play, we get to see a lot of
tricky kind of flexibility from very
best gamer with these equipments. If Jax
is not in play, if Sam can deal with it,
that you know, kind of limits the
option. So, cards in hand checked for
Sam.
Noxful Draven in the back row. A lot of
runes to work with. A lot of cards in
hand.
Sunken Temple possible card draw avenue
for both players.
And Sam to think it through.
Sam up a game. Big match a player of it
is uh playing again in his first major
riftbound tournament all the way in top
eight. Here's a Ferris forerunner and
again the patience just saying you know
what I don't think things will go great
if I pass turn tapped out. So for
develop the back row se back very best
gamers way and uh Lucian uh this is a
perfect time for Lucian's hit and run.
You know if you're going to start
developing your back row I can say I'm
in I'm out. Keep scoring those points.
So up to two. Lucian's in, Lucian's out.
And the next step is
still a core.
>> Well, even more card draw. Lucian gets
to draw off of the Sunken Temple, right?
Because the buff after the Warmogs, now
Lucian is a five. So now each time he
runs into Sunken Temple, you can pay
one, draw a card, run home.
>> Yeah, pretty good deal.
>> And that is a that is a situation that
Sam can't abide by forever. No, you
know, you can't can't just sit back. So
for getting going to get in on the
action here and we see one of these
battlefields that can draw cards that
both players can uh can utilize. We end
up in a very resourceheavy game. Who's
that favor? Resourceheavy I think is
just going to be in the Draven direction
cuz generally as Jax you're actually
going to outresource people a lot of the
time cuz you don't spend that much
power. Sometimes you're even generating
a bunch of runes with Bone Shiver. So
you kind of end up in these spots where
you've got like two units on board, one
of them being Jacks unmatched and you
just like pass with eight runes up and a
bunch of action. And because of that, I
think Jax can find a lot of uh perches
in those spots. But if Draven is also
having that much action, and it's the
purple spells that can be really
difficult to be dealt with without the
very specific counter spell answers, I
tend to think that the Draven is going
to do better on high econ.
All right, so Sam has drawn the card,
has a handful of cards, a bunch of runes
available, and looking pretty well set
up here.
We're going to see Draven going to
reinforce. Nope. Pump fake.
Rebuke in hand. Is it going to ride the
wind?
A switcheroo. Also kind of a nice one
here. And D to move in. So moving in
another recycle. Darius
readied. Nope, not ready.
No second card just yet. Or is Darius
the third? The third card. might have
been the third card or just the pass was
all Sam wanted to do anyway and just
kind skipped the trigger. Short carded
passed.
>> So going back very best gamers way and
now there's a formidable force on the
sunken temple. This also stops the
Lucian kind of come in draw come out
also. So the draw engine for very best
gamer has been stymied at the moment.
Jack's hanging out a bunch of runes.
Free shot for Stellacicorn to come into
the obelisk and draw a card.
a lot of options, lot to work through.
>> Yeah, it's this weird spot where it's
like, okay, you do want to move the
Stella, you want this card, and the
obelisk is a free move, but also like
Lucian is free to go in and out of
obelisk if there is not a swing going
towards Temple on this turn. But I think
for very best gamer, get this kind of
draw first from the Stella. See if
there's a world that you can actually
attack into this sunken temple.
Definitely some concern about the two
runes up, but if you can find a not so
fast, then you don't have to worry about
something like rebuke and you can just
with reckless abandon buff up the unit
and be like, "All right, go ahead.
Rebuke me. What do you want to do about
it?"
>> Yeah. And with Jax in play, these
equipments are surprised. They are
combat tricks, so it's hard for Sam to
know exactly how much might be in this
combat.
So, very best gamer with a friend, a
brand new card. Got to put the hand down
and looks like wants to go uh in for a
showdown. Oh, just the jacks. I was I
was kind of thinking it would be both.
Wow,
>> there's a lot of action that I'm
expecting behind this. Maybe a counter
strike actually is what this is reading
to me. Kill like half of them with the
counter strike and then push the Lucian
in to finish things off.
>> That is a That's a brave Jax.
So now it's on Sam.
Well, I guess focus.
I mean, if if very best gamer just
passed here. Yeah. So, no, no pass.
>> Yeah, this was waiting on the Draven
trigger, right?
>> Uh, it looks like declined. I did not
see a red go under.
>> Yep. So, we see that a guardian angel.
>> Looks to be slipping it in there. So,
guardian angel bringing Jax up to six
might
and more to come.
cannon barrage just to deal some damage.
>> Oh, okay. It's a cannon barrage that is
two to each of the units uh at the
battlefield, enemy units.
>> This is tech for overzealous fan. But in
this case, very best gamer just doing
some math and seeing, okay, well, if I
deal two to each of these, suddenly six
damage is enough.
>> Yeah, this is cool.
>> So, this already works to to trade this
down. Doesn't give a combat win to Sam
and says, "Okay, you go ahead and do
something. I'll give up my guardian
angel to wipe your board up and then can
go in and conquer with Lucian draw, run
home, you know, have Lucian and Jax back
at home afterwards.
>> Yeah, reopening Lucian's card draw
emporium there at the sunken temple. So
Sam, what do you got here? Sam does have
some tools. We see Fighter Flight Rup
ride through actually has almost all the
tools and switcheroo.
So here's Fighter Flight. Is there a
counter?
>> Yeah, that would just be covered by
Defy. There are two copies in the main
>> and the fighter flight is in the bin
with the Jax is still at the at the
battlefield. So we'll see uh you know
one one player shortcutting here
and the followup is a big spot
>> challenge.
>> Okay. So
>> this has to wait for the fighter flight
to resolve though before the challenge
goes.
>> Correct. So the challenge is at action
speed. So,
oh, sorry. Fighterflight was cast on the
Draven. I I I completely I completely
missed that cuz I was like assuming that
the point was at the Jax, but then I saw
the Draven is at base. So, it had
resolved. That's why it went to the bin
waiting for very best gamer. Uh just
trying to save the Draven, not let it go
down. There was Sam keeping all of his
might on the board because as Ferros
dies, you get six more might back on the
back row. So, Sam just valuing keeping
all the might together. felt like you
know what I don't think the push is
worthwhile in this spot
and from there it is just going to be
very best gamer running in picking up
another card and then moving the buff
the warmogs over to the Stellicorn so it
doesn't get traded for free all right so
not a bad turn uh reestablishing sunken
temple keeping Jax alive keeping Lucian
in the back row and now we're going
Sam's way Sam did maintain a bunch of
bite ferris foreigner just a really
really hard card to deal with at parody.
So he's maxer hanging out. Draven
noxious hopeful.
What's step one?
Draven heading over to the obelisk and
going to pay going to float one energy.
Pay the power pushing Draven up to six.
Oh boy.
>> Quick draw. We got the brutalizer coming
in which going to give a base of one and
plus two more thanks to it being
equipped this turn. And that is enough
to uh to take the day if there's not
more things coming from Sam. But there
is
>> there is spinning axe is going to
answer. That is a new plus three. The
brutalizer sometimes you forget about
too when you're trying to play around
ranges cuz you think about green. You
think two runes up and you think well
plus two. Yep. That's what you're
expecting plus two. But this is plus
three when it comes down. Spinning ax of
course easy to cover it but is forced
out with the Draven on to the obelisk.
Though we do know there is a ride the
wind if Sam did want to ride the wind
over to sunken temple, go home and just
keep everything back at base. But that
play line feels a lot better when you
have the point lead. When you're behind,
it feels a lot worse. It doesn't really
accomplish what you need. You need to be
able to hold at some point in order to
win the game when you're behind. You
can't just keep trading points back and
forth. There's also some weight on Sam
to try and kind of dee this sunken
tunnel sunken temple and not allow
Lucian to keep kind of coming in, coming
out, drawing cards. So, we're going to
see that right now. Noxious. Mech mech
coming into a temple. Another point for
Sam.
And now the followup. Still a lot of
cards in hand. And wow, really going to
stack up. So, here's the hopeful.
That being said, the brutalizer is still
in play. So, that is uh you know, three
might ready to rock and roll. But Sam is
not done. Here's a hidden guard. And
we're really seeing the power of the
Draven deck. The ability to put in a
bunch of numbers. while also having this
great interaction
cuz nides a card.
This is a total
14 might on the sunken temple with the
hidden card.
>> Yeah. And then also five runes available
too. So it could be a lot more.
>> Incredibly difficult to break this.
>> Yep. So we're going to see a pass. So
Draven's bush buff wears off. We're
going back very best gamers way. Lucian,
Warmmog, Brutalizer, Jax. A lot of runes
to work with, but a whole lot to get
over. A big group of cards for this deck
as well. He's been able to draw so much
off that sunken temple. The Stella
finding something. You know, often times
green orange can run into card trouble
and that has just not been an issue for
very best gamer so far in this set as
we've been seeing.
>> Yeah, very very cool. kind of showing
off the weaknesses, you know, where
typically orange green doesn't get to
interact as much and then also has card
draw problems, but quick draw being
great with the equipment. Battlefields
helping out with the card draw and now
very best gamer has a job to do and it
is to try and clear that temple. Very
best gamer is up four to three, but both
battlefields have a significant amount
of might on them and there's always the
fear of what Sam's got behind with five
runes available and a lot of cards in
hand.
players thinking it through here. This
is kind of the beauty of untime rounds.
You know, we are almost approaching what
would be the end of round clock in a
regular round, but in top eight, these
players get to really take their time,
think through, and play some highlevel
riftbound. And here we go. Stealing the
axe once again.
That is a big power shift. Minus three
to your board, plus three to mine.
>> Can still look to move it. Yep. So,
>> move it over to unmatched once more.
Going on my jacks.
Ain't done yet. Here's the brutalizer.
So that is a lot. Brutalizer is three.
Axe is three. Jax is five. It looks like
11 to me.
11v4.
Draven trigger currently. Not a lot of
these fury runes, these angry runes
ready to buff this up. However, there's
a hand of of super high quality tricks
here from Sam. Uh I think I see a rebuke
a ride the wind. I think I saw a
switcheroo also. Uh so many many
options. Of course, green has the
ability to counter and has the ability
to fight back. So Sam needs to decide uh
how much to go in and how to go in.
There's also just the note that Jackson
match does have deflect. So you don't
really want to go rebuke into this. Oh,
get not so fast. Well, I guess I
switcheroo. Oh, wait. Where did my runes
go?
>> So Sam says, you know what? You can have
it. So the hidden guard was a tide
turner going to swap in with the Draven.
Tide Turner is like, "Wait a second. I
got to go over here." Yeah, you do.
Sorry about that one. So Tide Turner
hops in the obelisk. Gets smooshed by
Jax, but now Draven is over at the
sunken temple joining the uh the 10
might that was already there. Sorry, 14
might that was already there and uh
making it even harder to break. And now
the brutalizer is also already on the
jack. So I was about to say this just
opens up an opportunity for very best
gamers to just develop and pass. And
Aphelios is a really great opportunity
there. He's going to equip the Warmog's
armor ready two runes to have
defensively one of the modes of
Aphelios. Those ready two runes channel
a rune exhausted or buff a unit
whenever you equip
two Aelios specifically. Love readying
two. So, and readying two here the the
other two are much more proactive
immediate gains. Readying to speaks to
hey, I'm going to interact next turn.
And of course, Sam sees that, sees a
choice made, and that gets to go into a
turn with a hold. So, a mega hold there
on sunken temple. Still only worth one
point despite there being so much might
there.
And now Jax hanging out on the obelisk.
So, a bit of a split board scenario.
And Sam, oh, Sam's got a lot of options
here. We see the thundersong in the
window.
That can be the killing stroke if need
be.
Sam thinking it through. Thunders song.
Look like ride the wind, switcheroo,
rebuke,
and I'm not sure what the card on the
far left is.
>> Yeah, but the big thing that you've
called out, the Briner, thundersong,
rebuke combination. We saw it in game
one to close it out. We've seen it time
and time again to deal with the heavy
stacked uh unit decks like we see it
against Aurelia, we see it against Jax,
we see it against or this combination of
cards is a big win condition for the
Draven deck. For now, it is just going
to go for a hidden Switcheroo next to
the treasure hunter. This is pretty face
up on average. Uh it's not often you
leave the treasure hunter there unless
it has a switcheroo to back it up. and
we'll see a very best gamer wants to
walk into that.
>> It's pretty funny here the visual of the
entire army leaves the temple and the
hunter has to go by himself. It's like
all right you you guard that now.
>> Yeah, they're stuck picking up the
treasure I left behind.
>> So, uh hunter's in going back very best
gamers way. And yes, this looks very
Switcherooesque. Uh of course the one
might on treasure hunter the preferred
target for a switcher route. Jack
doesn't get the hold. So very best gamer
is at six. Can't win the game this turn.
Can go to seven possibly.
So could even maybe see a retreat and
try and go for the full win next turn.
Yeah, I think that's actually quite
reasonable. The problem being hidden
cards start to become more of a problem
the more time you give. And it also
allows Sam to to retake, set up these
kind of perfect holds, hide cards, and
then have as many runes as possible
available for that interaction. And in
the previous game, very best gamer got
blown out by the Brin here. And I wonder
if very best gamer is concerned about
maybe similar happening and doesn't want
to hold. So we do end up seeing that
exact kind of idea of backing off and
just playing for the attack instead.
Holding becomes a really scary prospect
for the Jacks even though normally
that's what you like to do when the Brin
here gets involved. Now holding suddenly
becomes something very difficult. So
this point lead definitely not something
you want to throw away. And I think very
best gamer though does want to walk into
the switcher. He says, "Hey, you know
what? I I can deal with it." All right,
solutions coming in. Wants to go
shopping at the sunken tunnel sunken
temple emporium one more time. And I
mean Soeru is there. So I guess Sam is
deciding we, you know, could see
say ride the we see ride the wind. Okay.
>> All right.
>> So going for a different method. Is it
possible this is not the switcheroon?
Um,
technically yes. Uh, I think there there
may have been another hidden card there,
but I feel like the worlds where it's
not Switcheroo are more confusing to me
and I don't like them.
>> So, hidden cards are scary. I like the
known. They are scary. I love sabotage.
I can see my opponent's hand. Nothing to
worry about.
>> Yeah. Also, a lot of uh room for skill
expression, you know, because you you
can play a hidden card and you assume
it's something and it actually isn't. So
we see Draven going to get the buff.
Going to go up to six. So Draven's at
six. Hunter's at one. Hidden card still
down. And Lucian
just going to take out the Hunter. So
now leaving Draven at the battlefield at
six. Can go up again if a new combat
starts. And that hidden card still
hanging. If if the hidden card is
switcher now, it's lost a lot of its
value.
>> Yeah, it's not very good. Uh with Draven
at six already. Uh there's also
grandmaster arm still available. So,
spinning axe can be moved over. Uh,
brutalizer can be moved over. There are
options. Brutalizer going to get moved
to Aphilios. Looks like ready two runes
is not going to be the option. So, is it
Channel is it buff? Uh, or just going to
float two runes in response and then
allow them to get reried. So, two
floating for very best gamer.
So, a lot of energy available.
And
here we go.
Hello, Draven. It's time to rumble
now. Again, Sam has the trigger. Can
recycle another fury rune to give
another plus two. Draven always happy to
get into another combat.
Total count on very best side is four,
five, six, seven, eight. So that looking
at a possible trade,
>> but it is a switcher room. Okay. So,
bit of a bit of a a juke there to start,
but switch the eight and the six at this
point. Uh, I suppose the raven trigger
could not have passed yet. And we're
going to see a counter strike.
>> That feels like a steep cost to pay to
try and deal with this switcheroo.
really just looking for something like a
a second brutalizer, a couple of buffs
to try and push over the top,
but being sent home after the fact,
Counter-Strike not actually getting much
value here. And in fact, all all it did
was kind of interrupt a Switcheroo. Not
feeling like a good place to be for very
best gamer.
>> Yeah. All right. So, very best gamer on
six. Uh the Jax is is hanging out
Obelisk. Still some energy to go, so not
done quite just yet. And we're going to
see clockwork or keeper. So pay the
power draw a card.
And what is the next step really after
all this? We might be where you said we
were going to be at the very start
whereas unmatched moves back. And then
it's just six to four and let Sam move
it and look for the retake. And all this
was uh all this was for a bit of fun.
>> I'm having fun. You're having fun.
They're having fun.
>> Sam's drawing cards. I'm sure he's
having fun.
>> Yeah, for sure.
So, very best gamer. What is the next
step? A lot of runes spent this turn.
>> And just going to see Jax back it up.
All right. So, back it up.
You see a Stellicorn. All right. So, I
mean, very very energy efficient. Uh,
using all the runes possible and then
the kind of classic at six. Everything's
in the back row. I'll get you next turn.
So, over Sam's way. Sam holds to five.
can get the six here as well, but more
importantly needs to fortify
and try and stop the onslaught from next
turn. Our very best game will be trying
to take down the game and force a game
three here in our round of eight.
It looked like a pair of rebukes in
Sam's hand. So, those are very good for
the matchup. Better on offense because
they can be paired with Briner, but on
defense they're still powerful. It just
means that there is room for very best
gamer to find the not so fast to find
some other answer to dealing with them.
Yeah, definitely a bit of a minefield
next turn for very best gamer of uh
things to you know needs to make sure
that the combat goes in a way where you
can kind of tiptoe your way around each
possible pitfall and find the way to
eight points if it is possible.
So Sam's at five. I have to imagine the
six points coming in here as well as a
bunch of other uh units stacking up. So
we're going to see not one but two
knocks so taking the obelisk. That's
six. Two mechs over to the temple.
Kai'Sa going to pop in just played over
to the obelisk and there's a pass. Four
runes up, two rebukes. Probably just two
things in general is what very best
gamer has to think about. What those two
things are. Dream counts by twos.
>> That's the puzzle.
>> So going back very best gamers way. This
is it. This is the turn. Both players on
six. Very best gamer with the initiative
looking to break.
Work to be done. Lots of cards in hand.
Pretty good resource count. Double
conquer does win here. Enough runes to
do multiple equips and cascade through
this brutalizer.
>> Mhm. especially if needing to bait out a
rebuke, a push, something of that
nature. Grandmastered Arms allows one
move as well. Yeah, that is one of the
upsides here. So, Rebuke is very, very
powerful, but once you're in this late
game state, Rebuke is almost worse than
fighter flight when it comes to
equipment cuz fighter flight can lock
the equipment down.
Yep. So, this is the trick we talked
about leading into this game.
can go ahead and use the second part of
Grandmaster Arms. Unattach that
brutalizer, reattach it to Aphelios, get
an Aphelios trigger, and get the
brutalizer trigger to give that plus
two. That's nice
technology.
Zagna's also played in the back row. All
right, it is go time
and it Okay, it is really go time.
>> Oh, everything
>> party at the sunken temple. Everyone's
invited
and now that is uh that's a whole lot of
might. So two mechs and uh and a Draven.
Of course we know that there's uh I
believe two rebukes in Sam's hand.
Correct.
>> That's what I saw
very least one.
>> Y is guaranteed one.
>> So draw off Stellorn and now so it's
very best here saying okay I'll take the
seventh point and I'll hold for eight.
It's a strong idea with this much might,
especially because Sam had committed 12
might to the other side.
>> Yep.
>> It's not that hard for Draven to pivot.
It's hard for Draven to pivot multiple
units all at once.
>> So Sam ruined thinking this through. You
know, this is a bit surprising.
You know, the the feeling is that the
players are going to go for the double
conquer, go for the win, but this looks
quite good as well. I say just a a
boatload of might over there.
Will lose some on the way out both from
uh from the combat as well as uh the
brutalizer buff falling off.
>> Total of 12 might defending now. The
plus two is accepted by Sam.
>> Okay. So now where does Sam want to
start?
Total might count on very best gamer
side. What have we got? 4 8 9 10 11 12
14 15 6 17 8 20 22 25 is what I've got.
And of course, quick draw possibility
with jacks as well as well as other
tricks.
>> But it's just going to be pass.
>> Okay. So,
tradeoff and a win for very best gamer.
So, very best gamer goes to seven.
Maintains a good amount of power. The
Zagna saves the Jax. The Jax is now in
the back row.
>> Yep.
notably with Axan dying.
>> Sam now does own that spinning axe.
However, it is attached to Jax and it
will stay there uh until Jax is gone and
then the spinning axe will go back to
Sam.
>> Okay, so first mate, great pickup. That
adds a whole bunch more might of a
temple. So ready up, Jax is back in the
parties at Sunken Temple. Now Sam holds
seven. Both players at seven. very best
gamer in a great spot to force a game
three here in this round of eight.
Sam, what do you got for us? Can you
break what looks to be unbreakable?
My guess is no. I mean, this is this is
just way too much might, you know,
coming from hand. Draven already not the
best deck at accelerating. It does have
the Darius. It does have the Kaiser.
It's got some ways to do it. It's got
some decent pivots. Tide Turner, bring
something home, send it back in. Fight
or flight your own unit, bring it home,
send it back in. But even if Sam had the
ability to pivot all of this might, it's
not enough to break yet. 12 is already
not it. So you need all of this plus
something else that you're playing from
hand. And that's just not the most
feasible to get done. Looks like Ride
the Wind. It may have been Ride the
Wind, one Rebuke, not Double Rebuke. And
that's looks like what the case is.
Looks like Falling Star as well. That
can clean up six might from there.
Rebuke can get rid of one of the big
units,
but there's still three energy from very
best gamer. And we even see him reaching
for a response there. Brutalizer in
response because the Jackson match is
going back to hand.
>> This is cool from Sam though. He does
now have a spinning axe. Yep. That he
can potentially cascade through.
>> Yeah. So, freeing up the axe if there is
an accelerated threat of some kind. Axi
pop right on there. But there's still a
long way to go. That's not a bad step
one, but this is a manystep process.
Sam looking for a five-step program to
get into the top four.
Very best gamer wants to keep on gaming.
So, looks like five for a second there.
I think that Darius uh does seem like an
important piece of the puzzle if it is
available.
This game is going to continue. Next
step is probably Darius, the biggest
possible ready unit available,
pick up the axe, and then try and get
busy.
Also of note that uh the brutalizer kind
of turns off the the full might of
Falling Star and now Falling Star can
kill a two rather than a three. So
little bit of value there. Also,
>> there is exactly six might on a felio.
So, that's another potential target.
>> That's true. Yeah, it could also go for
the Celicorn six too. So, it could just
go out for one single unit.
>> So, I guess Star could go for one.
Rebuke could go for the other, but is
there enough to do everything? That is
the problem. Looks like one short.
>> It is one short of everything. Darius
could come down.
>> One short indeed. Very best gamer is not
done. Gaiman not done yet. Forced into
game three. Wants to continue in this
round of eight. wants to go into the top
four and wants to maybe have a chance to
battle for a trophy. We got a game
three. Nothing like it.
>> And now we're should be heading to a
battlefield that is usually very Draven
favored, which is the Tarun's Peak. Uses
it better than any other deck cuz of all
its tricks being at two cost. However,
Jax actually uses Tarun's Peak pretty
well. And the Dreaming Tree used quite
well from Jax also in order to just
continue to have this card draw. There
haven't really been any card issues from
Jacks. Historically, when I've watched
Jack's games, it feels like they end up
having card issues and that has just not
been a factor in this round of eight
game.
>> The Battlefields being super clutch
here. So, Samson's in the play one game
to see what player moves on. One
player's going to go home with a great
finish.
>> Wonderful memories,
>> but maybe just, you know, wanting a
little bit more. Here's Lucian.
>> Tie turner for Sam. Going back Sam's
way.
Dreaming tree on top. Targon's Peak on
the bottom.
Draven of course always hanging out.
Ready to rock and roll.
Brin Kaisa
4Runner Brin.
And that looks to be a hopeful on the
edge there. Lot of units.
>> Yeah. And the double brin at this point
in the game pretty clunky.
>> Yeah. So just going to be bluffing the
two from the Targon's Peak because you
would assume there's some kind of trick
in this hand, but it is all units.
>> Yep. So Draven get play gets played to
the peak. Lucian is in. Lucian is out.
One point for each player. Here's Lucian
number two. But that is it. Nothing
else. So we see a hold for Sam on the
Targons. Goes up to two now. Six runes
available. these Lucians, you know, kind
of make, you know, we've seen Draven
kind of like to hang back a little bit
and do these setups, but double Lucian
does not really allow for that. Um, if
you just kind of hang back, let both
Lucian both come in and both come out.
That's just two points every turn and uh
kind of need to keep mounting a defense.
So, Sam kind of unit heavy. I think I
saw multiple Noxious in there. So,
>> yeah, two Nox is hopeful. It was another
one off the top. So, double Brin, double
knock is hopeful, Ferris 4unner. I mean,
you know, there is some games, there are
some games with this deck where you just
you are playing a mid-range deck. Just
just go two, four, six. There's nothing
wrong with that. There's a lot of might
that gets to be developed, especially
because a lot of Draven's units are just
kind of above rate. I mean, Ferris forer
is 12 might paying six energy for.
Draven is six might. Yeah, you got to
pay that power cost, but So, Lucian
comes into the dreaming tree real fast
in and out if you missed it. So, point
is scored. Here's Jax, but Targon speed
gets held. So, Ferris Forwarder standing
strong. Sam goes to three with a chance
to go to four here and take that
allimportant point lead. Finally, some
interaction for Sam finds a rebuke to go
alongside all these units. But does feel
like, you know, maybe just maybe just
Kai'Sa plus a hopeful. You just start
kind of spamming these units out having
as much might as possible because that's
what the hand is telling you to do.
Yeah, a little awkward here. Uh, playing
foreigner last turn cost a rune. So, now
Sam at seven as we were saying a lot of
even numbers in this Draven deck. So,
the oddnumbered run oddnumbered runes
can get wasted at times. Sam going to
the tank. Draven's hanging out. Dreaming
tree is available, but at pretty large
personal risk.
That fourth point though is really
appealing, but just going to develop.
So, here's Kai'Sa. Here's Noxious.
Draven stays home. So stuck on three and
once again giving a free point to Lucian
if he wants to go into out. But now very
best gamer is feeling pretty good. Jax
is in a bunch of runes are up now. All
these equipments are quick draws. A lot
of interaction and uh
ready to decide what is the next stop.
>> Yeah, this pass ends up a little
suspicious in the sense that very best
gamer now has the potential to gain
point tempo. Right. This is a math
equation once again. Eight might on the
target's peak. One rune up. There's no
interaction at one rune, right? So, this
is just going to be up to barrier gamer.
Does he have the spells to actually make
it happen? The start with the clockwork
keeper is not promising. That is
certainly not what you want to be seeing
because that means he needed to dig to
continue to find more. Might be way too
unitavy with this hand and not finding
ways to buff over the top of the Ferris
4runner. That is what I am reading from
this body language from these plays so
far.
>> Yeah, whenever you see your opponent
start with a card draw effect, uh that's
kind of like cheap and finicky. That's
usually a sign of weakness and very best
looking to put it together. Sam unfaced.
These are two players who maybe didn't
expect to be in this spot. You know,
we've got very best gamer bringing Jax
kind of looking for a best of Sam's
first big tournament and uh now under
the lights
playing for all of it. But Jack's coming
in. All right, so
the armor's in, the buff is in. The
point is one. Not going to be a hit and
run. We're going to see Jax coming in.
>> Take the spot conceding the Targons for
the turn, putting Sam up to four. And uh
uh-oh. So this very best gamers play
spoke to a lot of interaction.
Thunderstorong the perfect answer. We
see a quick draw coming in as a a
guardian angel and another armor. So I
mean being able to use the runes
effectively at least and the guardian
angel can kind of back out if necessary.
So not a disaster.
>> Yeah, it goes to show that weakness
though. Two Warmogs in the hand. A bit
weak on the non-monaster game, but
because of the overall count of
equipment kind of need to keep them in
for this Jack stack. And it is just
going to be a rebuke following the Brin
here. We know the power that that holds.
And that is just going to be all of
these gear falling on the floor and
Jack's unmatched back to the hand.
>> Yeah. So Kaisa's in a draw for Kai'Sa, a
draw for Draven to put in the combat.
And now five points for Sam feeling in
the driver's seat.
Very best on three. Having to deploy the
jacks again is tough. Uh that takes time
and currently Sam is not giving very
best gamer much time. And now it's time
to reinforce. Here comes the noxious.
Here comes the Draven. We have Noxious
Draven and Kai'Sa on the Dreaming Tree.
Ferris Forerunner and Ty Turner hanging
out on the Targon Pe. They've been for a
while.
>> Yeah,
>> they're pretty well situated there. And
now we're going back very best gamers
way. And very best gamer has some work
to do. And very best gamer wants to keep
gaming this weekend.
>> Yeah, I mean he's shown he can't beat
eight over these last two turns. I mean,
eight has just been completely
stonewalling very best gamer with these
tap outs from Sam. And you know, one
more card is not seeming to make the
difference if the best that he could do
in response to the Brin here was to play
another uh guardian angel and a
Wormhog's armor. Just the plus two
might. This is only plus three might
have equipped to go onto a illusion
pushes up to six. Yeah, you could send
both Lucians in, push over that eight,
but all you're doing is putting back the
mechs onto the back row. A lot of
struggles here for the Jax deck. Makes
me wonder what the rest of these cards
are. It feels like it almost has to be
units based on what we've seen so far
and not the units you even want to see.
It must be something very slow to
develop. Could just be something like a
Stellicorn where there just hasn't been
a lot of room to play it out.
>> Yeah, cards like Stellicorn, Jax of
course in hand, very powerful, take a
little time to get going. And you're
right, a lot of the kind of like the
finicky equipments here, these double uh
double warmogs. So Jax is coming back
and you know Jax is a powerful card. Sam
is at five, not six. So, we're not
looking at, you know, total
total destruction here, but a very
precarious spot. So, here's Jax.
And now,
a lot of might on Sam's side. Sam, you
can almost see Sam little bit of the,
you know, the the kind of anxious
energy. And, uh, that's a common tale in
poker. We are in Vegas for a player
who's got it. When you're nervous, when
you're bluffing, you uh you're usually
calm because you're working so hard on
being calm. When you have it, you're
you're just so happy you do have it,
it's almost hard to control it. So,
feeling pretty good.
And we've got armor up. All right, here
comes Lucian.
>> Seven into six.
So, we are going to see about trade. So,
Targon is finally taken. The mechs are
in the back row though, providing a lot
more might. very best up to four. Also,
Targon's trigger is relevant, but kind
of running out of stuff
and Sam just being able to continually
jam might all this game has been so
effective
the course of these early stages.
>> Going back Sam's way, Sam is on five,
holding to six. So, cannot win this
turn, but very well poised.
We're going to see a draw. A lot of
runes, a lot of action available. still
that big party on Dreaming Tree. Lucian
holding at Targon's not, you know, the
most powerful. We did see the Guardian
Angel and the other Warmogs kind of just
hanging out, not equipped. So,
bit of a statement there.
>> Yeah, Sam thumbming the Britain here
again, just saying, well, I could
probably just pick off this Lucian, not
worry about the runes still left
available for very best gamer, just see
if there's anything there. It is going
to be a guardian angel. That puts Lucian
up to five.
>> Okay. also preserves Lucian in the back
row. So the angel will go away, Lucian
can get get recalled and uh so even if
the fight is lost here, still the might
next turn to kind of reattack. But with
Sam at six, if Sam's able to push here,
pile up on both battlefields and look
for a hold, that could be it.
And now Sam of course with very best
gamer under the thunder song. It's a
safe place to be coming in.
Trades off a mech to the guardian angel.
That's a point. So Targon's triggers Sam
to seven. Sam has the might. Looking for
a hold.
Looking for a path into the round of
four. Double conquer still on the table.
It looked like even third Brin here
potentially in the hand. That was a
third uh third one in the sideboard. Two
in the main. Third has come in. It's
been so good. Third one is there. Feel
like at that point you can just bring
all this might home. Wait till next
turn. Play out the brin here. There's
even a uh spinning axe. You can even
just bring everything home. Play the
spinning axe or play a hopeful or play
whatever unit you've got. Wait till next
turn and just Brin and push.
>> Yeah, Thundersong has been absolutely
fantastic. So many cards in it for Sam
too
at seven on the edge.
Really thinking it through. Very best
gamer is currently a spectator.
Unable to play anything, only able to
watch. Plot out for next turn.
And you are absolutely correct. We are
noxful. We are return everything back to
base at seven points. Say go. So we're
going back very best gamers way. Very
best gamers at four. That mech needs to
be dealt with in the fear of a hold.
Then of course defense needs to be
mounted in some way or another. So
jacks, Lucian, couple of equipments, a
lot of runes, but as the last few turns
have stated, very best gamer's hand is
not great. Not really able to do a lot
of uh kind of exciting stuff. So here's
Lucian. The mech is down. Targon's
triggers. That's a point up to five.
Lucian reads as well.
So Lucian can uh can back up here, but
kind of really can't.
>> Yeah, you're not allowed to.
>> You just got to hold, you know. So
>> got to lay up some defenses here. now is
very best going to go for just one of
these battlefield to try and really pile
up and just say, "Hey, beat this."
It's another Jack's weakness.
Unfortunately, there's not a lot of
pivot potential. It's all in first mate.
And so, if very best gamer goes for a
single stack, Sam can just say, "All
right, let me uh pick up this entire
board here, shuffle it up, and throw it
onto the one battlefield that you're not
going for. I'll just hold from seven to
eight on the next turn."
>> All right, so charm's a good starting
point.
one energy and a rune to deal with one
of these units to kind of start start
chipping away. There's a lot of work to
do. It's not a bad place to start. So,
Draven gets charmed in and we've got
five, six, seven, eight. D can go to
six. Doesn't really uh I guess the
spinning axe.
>> There is a spinning axe there.
>> Oh, boy.
>> So, spinning axe could uh could not not
willing to say, "All right, if you have
a re-triick here, I'm going to lose a
lot of my action." Just saving the
action for next turn, it looks like.
Yeah, the power cost I think probably
breaks some of the math that Sam is
doing for the next turn with the Brin
here and the followup. Can't see exactly
how many runes it is, but it's very
possible that losing one to the spinning
axe is actually detrimental going
forward, but it looks like very best
gamer is just going to scoop it up. Says
I actually cannot beat the might that
you've got on this board no matter what
you do.
>> And Sam is going to push forward to that
top four.
>> Sam's first big tournament into the
round of four. Very, very impressive.
Uh, awesome game for both players. Um,
great great stuff.
>> Just an awesome game. Really really
great.
>> So Sam kind of chatting it through.
Again, these are are our two uh two
Cinderella players, you know, players
that maybe didn't expect to be here and
uh, you know, have a both have a story
to last a lifetime. Sam's story is not
over yet. There is still much more to
write. Hopefully a lot more. Hopefully
two more rounds and then maybe a little
trophy ceremony.
>> Hey, maybe so. But the journey of our
Jacks, the very best gamer that there
ever was, is unfortunately over in the
round of eight does win the best of
though of the grandmaster at arms. And I
think that is a hell of a run for our
player here.
>> The very best Jax gamer.
>> The very best Jax Gamer. Imagine if you
had a real to to be sure. So let's hop
down and hear from our winner.
>> I'm here with Sam D. Sh after winning
your quarterfinal match. You're now in
top four in your first major rift bound
event. How does it feel?
>> I'm loving it. Uh yeah, I was pretty
happy to get that pairing. Um I I was
telling Jim earlier that I think my good
matchup is every metal card hunter and
you know that guy is a Jack's metal card
hunter. So I was I was very happy to see
that.
>> Well, unfortunately now you're walking
into a sea of Draven mirrors for the
rest of your top four. How are you
feeling about that matchup?
>> Uh I don't love it. But I mean, I don't
I think that the miracle version is a
somewhat good matchup, but it's
definitely losable. So, we'll see how
how it goes.
>> Best of luck.
>> All right, so we are back here at
regional qualifier. Las Vegas. The round
of eight is complete. The round of four
is coming up. Let's take a look and see
how that shaped out.
>> All right, so uh
>> Whoa.
>> It is uh the League of Draven. It is the
League of Draven. A few upsets coming
through I would say because you know
we've seen Prison Allen in the top eight
of Bolognia. You would expect them to
come in favorites. Both of them knocked
out in that round of eight.
>> Wow. As uh the surprises continue. So
Shisel takes it down over Pris uh
playing Draven. Of course we just saw
Sams. That'll be one of our semi-final
matchups. And then Colin, we saw Colin
play absolutely fantastically on camera
earlier of the tournament, taking down
Deluxe Phil Cheese playing Aurelia and
uh TTA taking down Allen, our former
champion. So incredible work.
>> We'll have a new champion here, which is
kind of a a thing to say. Well, yeah,
it's a huge tournament, but Allen of
course on a ridiculous heater. Still
incredibly impressive to see the
consistency from event to event. Just
really awesome to see.
>> Yeah, I mean, and it's back to back best
of Ezreal still for Allen. Cris did end
up with the best of Draven from
Bolognia. Not going to be able to repeat
that success, but still the consistency
of another top eight. Incredible.
Beautiful runs from these two. Of
course, unfortunate for Aurelia to have
the run ended there, but congrats again
to Deluxe Phil on that best of and Colin
that we saw earlier. He might still be
one of the favorites coming in going for
the rest of the game, but this is going
to be a lot of Draven mirrors to get
through. Yeah, very very impressed with
Collins playing the match that we
watched and uh Draven was locked out of
top four in Bolognia, correct? Correct.
Not make it in. And Draven said, "Whoa,
whoa, whoa.
>> Hold up, guys. I I'm still I'm still
here.
>> It's still a tier zero format."
>> Yeah, exactly. So, uh, a Draven top
four. That's going to do it for us as we
get into our round of four. And, uh,
just an awesome awesome event so far. I
cannot wait to watch these last few
matches. Uh, I'm just stoked. I'm I'm
going to run over to that crowd and be
yelling, hooting, and hollering as we
got Pastry and Ursy coming in to round
out the rest of the day and close
everything out. I had so much fun in the
booth with you, Jim. And I just can't
wait to see the culmination of this
event. So, round of four is coming up.
Don't go nowhere. Buckle up. Got a lot
more lot more fun to play.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
I can't get it.
Welcome back to the round of four here
at the regional qualifier in Las Vegas.
If you like what you've been seeing on
stream, perhaps you to head on down to a
local summoner skirmish, your kind of
next step in terms in terms of
competition play, maybe get a buy for
something like a regional qualifier and
play, you know, a little bit more
competitive with bounding your nexus
knights.
>> Yeah, so many people got the summoner
skirmish buy was really nice this this
tournament.
>> Yeah, I mean the preview that was
happening right before this event was
chalk full of people looking for those
buys. So very important if you're
looking to do well at an event like
this. I'm Patry Time. That's Earth today
and we're going to be bringing you
through the round of four and of course
our finals coming on up. But we have a
few things to settle here first in now
is now the League of Draven. But I am
unofficially dubbing the battle of the
best of because the winner of this
tournament is also not going to win. Get
their playmat get their special blade of
the rune king promo but they're going to
win the best of Draven as well. In the
top side it is Shisel and Sam Sherman in
the top half of the bracket. In the
bottom Colin versus TTA and I can tell
you up top it's mid-range Draven. in the
bottom. It's Miracle Draven. So, we're
going to see what the best Draven build
is by the end of this tournament.
>> Yeah, I am so excited to see the
differences here and I think that's
what's going to decide just that best
of.
>> Absolutely. We've heard so much about
how powerful the Miracle Shell is with
Ezreal as we are going to have a look at
some best ofs that we haven't quite
highlighted just yet. It is LS himself,
the League of Legends lord winning the
Teemo Swift Scout best of. He was
debating right before this event, do I
play Ezreal, which I think is maybe the
best stock, or do I play Teemo? wanted
the team of best stuff and got it all
the way there. Losing by the way to
prismaticism in round three of this
event. We have a custom dipped as well
on Victor. E3 TCG winning the volleyball
one. And of course, Gentle Giant on
Yasawo Unforgiven.
>> Yeah, I got to talk to him a little bit.
Was really really cool that Yasawo deck
>> also getting through there. Region Shin
taking that one down. Crossell winning
the Rumble best of which, which was kind
of a tight one at the end of it all cuz
no Rumbles unfortunately made day two.
Victor Lupin managed to pick up set the
boss best of and no veggies just barely
missing out on the top cut but did win
the best of for Civer.
>> Fantastic job by him. We've seen him
last tournament as well.
>> And of course Delil Chief in six of this
tournament did lose in the quarterfinals
but still wins the Aurelia best for
being the only to make top eight. Maybe
the the unsung hero of the event. The
very best gamer on Jack's grandmaster at
arms. An absolutely spellbinding
performance. Eric Jinx on Jinx Loose
Cannon who I believe has been a Jinx one
trick in riftbound for basically as long
as the game has been out and agre
winning Kaiser daughter of the void best
off a one a best off that was very
prized last year in Houston but we have
not seen a whole lot of Kaiser and as we
know we're here in the last four players
awful lot of Draven
>> that is for sure
>> it's even more we've got Alz winning
Ezreal once again have to note he did
say he wanted to win all of the medal
cards for Ezreal and he has done so
despite the eighth place finish his
depression. What a username on Fiora
Grand and Duality usurping T for the
best of Garen. And of course, you might
see April, we haven't quite filled in
the player for the final best of card
yet. And that's because it's a question
mark. In fact, it's going to be the
winner of this tournament, which is a
pretty nice additional prize on top of
winning the RQ.
>> That is going to be definitely so nice
for whoever takes the win here today. So
many Dravens for you to watch, but each
deck list in itself is, you know, has
their own pieces and they've decided
exactly what they think is going to make
it the best deck.
>> Yeah, I think it was very clear that
Draven was at least going to be one of
the best decks, if not the best deck,
and it was absolutely the most
represented decks as you see our
semi-finalist both squaring off in the
feature match area. We'll have a look at
our deck list for our upcoming matchup
because like I said, the bracket is
split between which is the best way to
play Draven. On the one side, it's
mid-range and we have the mid-range side
of the bracket for you. Sam D. Sherman
who's been on a tear in his first ever
major riffound event. This is their mid
Shven list.
>> Yeah, it's really exciting to see. Both
of these obviously are going to have
more might in their list just from all
these different units. But some things
to keep an eye on is spinning axe in
both of these lists. It's a super
important card in the mid-range Draven.
But a huge difference that I do note is
that Shisel is running Piercing Light as
well as Edge of Night. Uh but the other
list actually only ran Falling Star. So
very interesting choice.
>> Yeah, Falling Star seems like a pretty
good spell to have in a matchup like
this. But it's really interesting to see
who's going to get the best of uh not
just Draven. That was unintentional, the
best of the kind of might battle as it's
going to be, you know, more grindy kind
of big units wanting to really put
sticky units on the battlefields. Ferris
4 are definitely going to be a standout
as Chisel a player we haven't seen yet
on stream played off stream in their
quarterfinals defeating the number one
seed prismaticism at this point who was
maybe one of the favorites at least
doing Draven best of again certainly one
of the favorites in the event as well.
>> Yeah and both of these players are
running the same battlefield and they
are choosing Reaver's Row here for game
one. Uh, we all know how great Draven's
ability is on the leader because when
you win a combat, you get to draw a
card. And if your opponent when you move
into Rever's Row decides to take that
trigger and move back to base, you still
will win that combat and get that card
draw.
>> It's a really interesting thing as well
because this kind of battle unlike the
miracle where you know both decks can do
extremely explosive things, especially
as you get deeper into the game. This is
really kind of a game of inches between
these two decks. And Reverz, I mean, I
think the general Battlefield uh
shortcut is play my best Battlefield in
game one, right? And I would say Rezur
is probably Draven's best battlefield.
It is so powerful at triggering your
ability early. But at this kind of
matchup, you do not want to give your
opponent extra cards if you can help it.
You are trying to deny every single card
draw you can
>> for sure. And immediately we are into
this game. Both players do get their
twocost unit, but I and which we kind of
expect in mid-range. It has a lot more
two costs, has a lot of different units
in their deck. But a big thing to watch
out here for, especially in this
position, is I saw in Chisahhan was
piercing light. And a huge momentum
swing here could be that because Sam did
move this treasure hunter up into
Reaver's row and put Draven in base. We
could see this piercing light repeated
here and able to kill both the treasure
hunter and the Draven that we just spent
our runes on.
>> Yeah, repeat. Very powerful. It is a
unit out of battlefield and a unit
somewhere else up to one other unit. Two
damage twice. Lucian's little signature
queue there from League of Legends. Most
importantly, this is a regular speed
spell. So, Shisel cannot move into
Reaver's row. I mean, I guess at that
point there'd be a trigger you'd have to
respond to. But if the trigger is
denied, say, and Sam wants a trade, you
can't then piercing let the unit win the
combat and draw a card. instead commits
it all. And that is still so much power.
We talked about Falling Star being good
in this kind of matchup. That was
basically Falling Star here.
>> And it's going to be really important.
We're We've now cleared Sam's board. And
even though he did go first, there are
now no units on his board. A really nice
place for Shisel to be in and kind of
showcases why Piercing Light is such a
strong spell, but why it can also be
really nice in this deck list
particularly.
>> Yeah, makes sense. Again, the removal
there's a bit more of it I guess in
these deck list than maybe some of the
miracle lists, but there may be a bit
more recursion. But I do think in
general that again you are trying to
fight for the most efficient unit on
board. And the flip side of that is
fight to remove the units most
efficiently while trying to deny each
other card draw. So bin here, thunders
going to be the unit of choice. And
unlike you know its usual job of
shutting down things like Aurelius and
Ezreal, this is really just a six unit
that's got five might. And honestly,
that's kind of good enough here. Yeah, I
though I would not feel the most happy
playing it in this spot. There is a
second Brin here in this list that we
could find later. We really want to use
Brin here later in the game potentially
to bring lethal and take the win so that
our opponent's Draven will not be able
to have any response when we move into
Battlefield. So, we do get might here,
but it does decrease what we can do
later in the game. would much prefer
having the other six drop that both
these decks run three copies of and that
of course is Ferris 4 on a but tide
turner going to do exactly that on the
reaver's row push that treasure hunter
back to base and that means that
treasure hunter is now ready and ready
to move back onto the other reaver's row
and get yet another point and yet
another gold and a big difference
between the mid-range list and the
miracle list is that the mid-range list
do not run any seals so this gold is
very valuable
>> yeah this is going to be so nice for
Shisel as he plays some of these more
power costly units but Noxis hopeful
will be nice enough here. Getting more
might down as you mentioned earlier. We
want to build out our base, get it
pretty wide with might so that we can
fight later.
>> Yeah, not the most efficient hopeful
here. Actually have to pay the full four
for it, which is not necessarily what
you want to see, but we'll see what Sam
Sherman has as a response here. It is
going to be Brin here moving in and
Rea's row is going to be accepted as
Titoner retreats. But that of course
means that the other Draven on the left
does get to draw a card. And again, you
want to try and keep the card draws to a
minimum for your opponent. And of course
with two Dravens on in this match up,
one on either side uh can be tricky to
deny draws for the entire game.
>> Yeah, they still do want to take those
points and moving into Reavers Row does
give that option for combat. Obviously,
it's going to be hard to avoid it, but
both players are going to try to draw as
many cards as they can and also not let
their opponent draw as many cards as
they can.
>> Yeah. And kind of again talking about
key differences between the Midwinist
and the Miracle. You've probably, if you
watch us all weekend, seen a lot of this
card called Battering Ram. It's a very
efficient five might unit that often
costs one which is a very good rate for
something like that. No such thing
instead we got a little bit bigger than
that. Things like Darius here for both
these players as Sam Sh going to play
one play a TI turner ready up that
Darius that's now a seven about to
charge into a battlefield maybe going to
say hello to this treasure hunter asks a
question and the question is I would
like to retreat as previous on both
sides of the battlefield does make kind
of for some funny interactions but maybe
for Sherman more importantly starting to
farm a little bit of card draw with his
bigger might units forcing units out and
winning combats as Draven
>> yeah it's a nice position for Sam to be
in controlling both of these
battlefields but Shisel is just moving
that treasure hunter round as he wants.
And he's honestly up to four gold. That
is such a high count. I'm excited to see
how he decides to play with it later in
this these games as hopefully he can get
more and more runes as well.
>> Going to check on how many copies of
Falling Star available. Actually, none
in the main here for Shisel. So, that
was the thing that came came to mind cuz
there's actually no second red rune
right now for Shisle. It is simply all
those gold which would be great for
paying big power costs. And the card I
think of immediately when I think of
larger power cost is something like
falling star. So not all that many runes
here but plenty of possibilities here.
And again you'll get a slight rune
advantage over the course of the game if
you're paying for things like Ferris
4unners power and other things like
that. Even helps with your own champion
unit if you want to use Draven's little
attack or defend ability. But Nox was
going to move in and that's actually
enough to scare away the Darius. That
was four versus five and Zambi Chamman
wants nothing to do with that matchup.
Yeah, both these players are running
spinning axe, which is a reaction speed
uh equipment that can give you plus
three might. So, even though this Noxis
Hope is smaller than the Darius when he
goes into that Reaver's row with all of
our runes ready, there's still a lot of
might that we're threatening for our
hand.
>> This is a really good accelerate here
for Shisel using the gold to accelerate
this red Kaiser. This is again another
big difference between the list. This is
kind of a throwback to when Kaiser was
the best deck in Origins. Both these
decks running three Kaiser. This is an
extremely powerful card. We already
talked about how in these mid-range
matchups, every little card matters.
Every bit of advantage you can ek out is
so important. We already talked about
Draven triggers being something you
want. Well, now Kaiser double dips when
you by giving you a conquer trigger that
also draws you a card.
>> Yeah, you can really see how much this
Draven list can be about like getting
resources from these draw card draw
triggers. Even the Kaiso, the old Kaisa
list, really only ran one to two Kai'Sa
in it, mainly being that chosen
champion. But with three in Shisel's
list, he's going to be able to move into
the battlefield, get that conquer
trigger, and if there was somebody he
came up against, also get the conquered
trigger from his or combat win trigger
from his Draven.
>> Interesting stuff here. Looks like uh
stack deck, I think, was used there in
an action window that was available for
Sandy Sherman. only had one rune up, so
decided to use it there for a little bit
of filtering. Not sure what other trick
could have possibly had, but going to go
ahead and select a couple cards here. I
think Sam's currently looking through
the rest of their hand, seeing what he
can find. So far so good, I feel like
for sure, but this is such a funny first
game because Reavers are always on both
sides and where each player is basically
saying, "Okay, when I'm attacking, I'm
going to be ahead because you're
probably going to want to move away from
you cuz you don't really want to get in
combat." Unfortunately, you're already
in the combat even if you don't, you
know, get into direct contact with the
enemy, which is mean means each Draven
gets to draw some cards. And right now,
Shisel's winning the race on point. So,
I have to feel like if there's going to
be basically this back and forth of
moving into Rever's Ro and retreating
that the player that's ahead on points
is currently winning this game.
>> I do feel that way as well. And I think
that goes back to that piercing light
turn. You would think because Sam went
first and even got the first point that
they would have been able to keep that
lead similar as we see here going back
and forth, but it was such a tempo
swing. Not only killing the Draven in
base, also killing the treasure hunter
in the battlefield and then having time
to get our own points to come back and
take the lead.
>> Yeah, it feels like if we're just
trading units back and forth, not really
going to break any sort of stalemate
here. So, it feels like removal going to
be the thing players want to look at. Of
course, Brin here and Darius very big
units. So, we'll win two combats, draw
two cards, and get two points. But
again, if if this is the the pace of
game, if they continue this back and
forth doing nothing else, we already
know which player is going to win if you
want to trade points. So, there has to
be something else here. There are I'm
going to say a million cards or so in
Sam Sherman's hand right now. I see at
least a Rebuke as one of them. Sam does
have two falling stars in the main deck
as well. So, some options here to try
and make something happen. But, I feel
like at some point, you have to break
this pattern. You're going to have to
stay at the Rever at some point. Yeah, I
do think at some point we are going to
have to hold. But it you also see on
Shisel's side just how nice this
Reaver's Row is because while it feels
good to get all these card draws from
the Draven leader ability, Shisel's
units just continue to survive and he's
just getting a bigger and bigger base.
Meanwhile, Sam is still only at three
units. He's going to want to grow his
base as well.
>> Yeah, Symbion are a little bit bigger,
but uh I guess do a quick mic count
while we're here. Let's call it five a
piece. Actually, it's easy on Sam's
side. It's only 12. Two fives in a two
is easy math there. But 6 1 from the
treasure hunter only. So 7 + 2 is nine
and Kaiser is only four. So 13 versus
12. That is actually very close given
the unit differential. So the big units
are helping here for Sam Duming, which
when you think of mid-range, you kind of
think of bigger units. And I do see a
ferris fullerunner all the way to the
right of Sam's hand. Wonder if that's
something you consider to make a stand
on one of these reavers rows because
again can't let this pattern continue
too longer and kind of the annoying
thing about reavers row is that these
little units that you think would
finally been picked off in combat they
just keep on retreating.
>> Yeah, that's very true. I do wonder why
Sam is choosing to wait on this fair
Ferris 4runner, but I was talking to
some of the players uh today about this
Draven deck. And the point that they
said is Ferris 4runner, you really have
to be able to protect it, especially
against Rebuke because if you decide to
play Ferris 4runner and you get rebuked,
then you've just committed six energy, a
whole power, and you're getting nothing
from it for only two on your opponent's
side. So presumably we may see a they
said that you would want to hold it
until you get a fight or flight to hide.
So hopefully we'll be seeing that come
out, but it doesn't look like it on
Sam's side.
>> Yeah, no fight or flight. I did spot a
falling star as well, but no obvious
targets for that spell right now.
Holding up rebuke right now as well as
you know from Sandan Sam's hand and
plenty of cards in and amongst them all.
But again, Falling Star, very powerful
spell, regular spell speed as well. also
not something you can play on your
opponent's turn when showdowns are
happening. And there are always
showdowns happening when Draven is
involved. So here we're going to start
with a stack deck out of Shisel side.
See if we can't kick off the 11 might
that's currently down on the bottom
Reaver's row. I did see a fighter flight
but also a spinning axe which is going
to be absolutely gigantic I think for
Shisel. He is at five points. So, we're
not exactly at the turn we're going to
win, but be we could potentially pose it
as multiple times on our turn. We can
still reattach it when one of these
units dies. So, we can trade up into
some of these bigger ones that Sam has.
Looking at six and five on that Brin
here, but you can now do plus three with
spinning axe. Your unit dies. You do
lose a couple draws, but then you can
keep reattaching it and clear out these
rea. Yeah, just kind of checking through
other spells players have access to.
They actually both have access to two
copies of Rebuke, which is a spell
that's going to be pretty good against
these much beefier units like the Ferris
4runner. Shisel looks like going through
a couple cards here. I do see Rebuke in
the middle of the stack of three that
are currently looking through with this
stack deck that is still resolving.
Yeah, Rebuke is definitely a I mean
could be a good choice, especially with
that target already in Reaver's Row. I
can't exactly see the other cards that
Sigil
Shisel has just yet. Uh but we'll have
to see.
>> Yeah, I think certainly winning on cards
is Sam. The bigger units kind of
bullying out the smaller ones. Even
though you're behind on points, you do
get draws off of Draven from those
Reaver rows. So happy to win those
combats and grow the hand pretty
significantly. But kind of feels like
the first big turn here between these
two decks where Sam has decided, you
know what, I I'm going to commit a
bigger unit here to this battlefield and
in a the kind of matchup where you just
want to be a little bit bigger than your
opponent. That's kind of mid-range's
general thing. Uh currently a lot bigger
with the first four runner there. So
Shisel kind of has to figure out a way
to get rid of that particular problem
and stack deck number two is going to be
at least searching for the answers.
>> Yep. Let's see. We get We do see that
option for rebuke again. I do think I
see a Ferris 4Runner up top missing what
the bottom one is
>> in the shadows.
>> Uh it is in the shadows. But we do have
to keep in mind Sam does have those two
runes up that Shisel is debating what
could Sam have that I need to account
for. Be it if I go to that northern
reverse row or if I go to the southern
one.
>> We can actually take a quick look
through the main here and just fan to
the possible options at two. Falling
star. As we already pointed out, not an
option. Uh fight or flight kind of the
obvious one. hard bargain available,
rebuke and ride the wind and spinning
axe of course the other one there. So
those are kind of all the options and
you said it quite a lot over the course
of the tournament here. Uh whenever a
Draven holds up to you have to think of
like a million different possibilities
cuz it could be so many different
threatening effects
>> for sure. And
especially in top four now you don't
just want to send those units in
willy-nilly. You don't want to, you
know, lose the tournament based off of
some card that you didn't account for,
but maybe you should have. And it So, it
does look like we're coming in here with
eight might versus 11, but we, you know,
we have six runes up. There is so much
we can do and we're kind of saying like,
you know, I dare you to dare me to have
it.
>> Yeah, it does feel like Shisel is the
one that has to make something happen.
It's currently losing the battle pretty
badly as far as might goes. So, it is
going to be Rebuke. Two gold cash in to
keep the resources flush and Ferris
4Runner is going to go straight back to
hand. Not where you want to see that
powerful six drop mech.
>> Yeah, that is not where you want it at
all.
As we mentioned earlier, we spent six in
a whole power. Comparatively, Shisel has
so had so much gold after all those
treasure hunters. He could spend that a
little bit easier. And meanwhile, Sam
wasn't able to do that. To note, Revis
only can choose one unit to potentially
retreat when the defense trigger goes
off. And we are already very clearly
past attack and defense triggers because
we've started playing action spells in
showdown. So Sam decided, I have the
bigger army. I want to keep it here on
the battlefield. I know I need to in
order to kind of push this game forward
to any point where I'm going to win. So
it's time to ride the wind away to the
other Reaver's row. Oh no, Darius is
coming in instead, but he's going up.
>> Interesting. So wants to maybe take out
the Kaiser here on the bottom side and
take a point still. This is a way to
take the tempo back.
>> Yeah, this is one thing you have to kind
of account for when going up against
purple, not purple, but against this
deck, especially when you know that it
has Ride the Wind in it. Uh I do believe
Top Cut is open deck list. So Shazel and
Sam do both know that there is Ride the
Winds in these lists. And so you're
going into this battlefield with the
knowledge that there is, you know, no
thread in the other battlefield to stop
ride the win right now.
>> Yeah. Just to clarify, open deck list
pretty common practice among TC
tournaments. The way it works when you
sit down too much, you get handle your
opponent's deck list and you get a few
minutes to look it over. You then put it
away. You don't get to look at it again
during the game. You have obviously
these players at this level can memorize
pretty much everything that their
opponent could have in their deck. And
then when side happens, you get to look
again. And then of course again for game
three if we get there. So, uh, have to
imagine both players are certainly aware
of the tricks that could happen. Ride
the wind. Both players actually playing
two of the, oh, sorry, two versus one
the count for Sam and Shisel,
respectively. But Darius kind of
throwing a wrinkle into the plan. Not
just scoring a point on the opponent's
turn to again kind of break the tempo,
but also doing this threatening another
battlefield cuz all of a sudden these
little units that were going to take
this free point. Well, that point's not
very free anymore.
>> Yeah, it is not free at all. And Sam
kind of gets almost like cheats that
point by getting into Reaver's Row
during their opponent's turn. Kind of
changing that point game that you were
talking about earlier that it seemed
like Sam was behind. Now, not only was
he trying to hold, but he's also able to
skirt into that Reaver's Rome.
>> Can't imagine Darius wants to retreat
here.
>> Yeah, I can't either with it being two
versus five. But I mean, four runes
still up.
>> Yeah, it's only I mean, it's only four.
It's only two right now. It's five
total. uh if you count the units back in
base, but they have not moved in. And
Sam is going to take the retreat. He's
going to give a card and a point over to
Shisel. Not necessarily the point you
want it to be at, but a little maybe
respecting the runes that are up, which
I think is as a reasonable decision
here. And is it six points? So, with the
army that's assembled in the backline
could maybe make something happen for a
double conquer, which would result in a
win.
>> Yeah, I think it was smart longterm to
move this Darius back. We've already
gotten that point. Darius has done his
job and we still have so much for him to
do this following turn. We have to take
both of those battlefields and or at
least clean them out from Shisel's side.
>> Yeah, we do know that uh Shisel isn't
going to win this turn. Doesn't have
access to something like Draven
Audacious. Not being played in this
version of Draven. Much prefer the Fury
chosen champion. So, seven points is
where Shisle's going to be for this
turn. Not able to get another conquer to
maybe draw a card off it either. So, it
is actually going to be back to Sam to
set up to try and win the game. A double
conquer would get it done. Which means
all these Reaver's row retreats we've
seen are going to be a lot less
attractive on the following turn. And it
is clever that Sam is using this ride
the win to kind of steal a point at a
critical moment cuz we're not sure he's
necessarily going to win next turn. But
he was not on pace to do so with the way
the game was going and is now suddenly
snuck into first just barely.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. I think
Shisel is trying to decide where to move
these different treasure hunters though.
He only has to keep one side to win by
holding that following turn. But if he
loses both, it will also automatically
be a loss because Sam conquering seven
and eight points during his turn. We do
still have those four runes up and it
looks like we're going to be playing Nox
is hopeful for that Legion cost of only
two. And then do we leave two up, you
know, to potentially have something to
play or do we fill fill out our
different battlefields a little bit
more?
>> Looks like we're hiding a unit here. The
question, sorry, I say unit cuz I'm
pretty sure I saw it was a tie turner.
Hiding a card here for Shizzle. I think
we're deciding which battlefield we want
it to go. Does make sense over there
because you can maybe trick some might
over, move one of the hope pools over
and make it a little scarier than it
might look. And of course, it always
looks like a fight orflight whenever you
do this. Edge of knight also in Chisel's
list. So, a few different hidden cards
for Sam to consider. But again, if Sam
can find a way to conquer both
battlefields, to score on both
battlefields this turn, that would be
enough to get to point number eight,
which is the last point needed in this
opening game.
>> Yeah, it's almost too bad it feels like
that we have not run into the edge of
knight on Chisel side. It feels like
such a strong card and a huge difference
between these two decks. Shis Shisel is
running one. Sam is running zero. But it
is a hidden equipment that you can then
equip to one of the different units at
that battlefield.
>> Spinning axe going to be the card
deployed here. This falling star by the
way looking very good in this spot.
Trying to pick off the tie turner up the
top which would also destroy the hidden
card remind you and cut down the mine at
the battlefield. So overzealous fan was
actually the unit put there. So is going
to try and stop the fan which actually
is getting the axe. So Shisel valuing
the fan's push ability more than the tie
turner navigate occupying the top
battlefield which I think makes sense.
Overall fan is such an annoying card to
try and get through. Like when your goal
is to get into a battlefield that's how
you're going to win. Real annoying to
have fan there as tieer is going to swap
around. I think just going to yeah knows
it's going to go down anyway. So just I
guess plays the hidden card so it
doesn't get lost. There's still a unit
occupying that battlefield. Seems
totally fine. But three damage marked on
this fan. And there's probably more
where that came from if that D is coming
out.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. We have so much
I mean so many runes up on Sam's side.
We could have more falling we could have
more falling stars. There's other spells
that we could play as well. But that
that spinning ax is so nice. Not only
are we saving the two might of the
Overzilla span, we're threatening that
fight orflight uh ability if we decide
to use Overzilla. And now we have plus
three as well, threatening even more in
this attempt to hold at least one side
of these two battlefields.
>> Well, another Darius is coming out here
and Chisel is out of active rune. So,
both these Dariuses are very big. But
can we deal with the overzealous fan?
Cuz it's four. It's only nine might if
the fan goes down. Rebuke on the fan. I
think that's going to be enough. Titer
can't win the exchange in the top side
and I think both Dariuses can crash in
for the win. Reaver's row be damned.
Darius is going to move on in. And there
we go again. And Chisel, do you have an
answer?
No, you don't. It's game one. Sam D.
Sherman.
>> Ouch. And yeah, what a fantastic game
one by Sam. It did feel like we had lost
tempo early in the game and yet that I
feel like that ride the win was able to
bring us back into the game and sadly
Shisel did take the loss here.
>> If you cut a letter off that card, it
seems very appropriate for how that game
went. Ride the win for Sandy Sherman in
game number one. We're gonna move on to
game number two as a player in their
first major riftbound event is looking
to make it all the way to finals
potentially. But Chisel, who's already
taken out quite a competent Draven pilot
in his quarterfinal, going to have a
thing or two or three to say about it as
Treasure Hunter is back on board to kick
things off. And it is Obelisk versus
Targon's Peak throughout game number two
as far as battlefields go. So, Treasure
Hunter going to be deployed on turn one.
And four runes now for Sam Sherman,
which is a pretty nice little way to uh,
you know, alleviate the uh,
disadvantage, I'll say in air quotes, of
going second.
>> Yeah, that is very true. And just look
at exactly what you're saying here. two
units here coming down on Sam's first
turn. Shisel doesn't have the same exact
threat, you know, coming at him this
game because while he was able to swing
tempo last game with that piercing
light, Sam neither has it in his side
deck or his main deck. Obviously,
Falling Star is kind of an option, but
if Draven Vanquisher does get played,
then we won't see uh that Falling Star
being able to kill both of them, just
one.
>> Yeah, interesting kind of things just
going through the sideboards quickly.
Falling Star, an extra one there for
Sam, which looked pretty good in that
game. Also, two blind splitters might be
something you want to bring in here. And
also a last rights if we're really
trying to go late. In fact, both players
with the shovel in their sideboard. Have
to think that's coming in in a match up
like this. It can get pretty grindy at
the end of it all. And there is a
falling star just or single copy here
for Shisel likely for this matchup as
well. And uh there's a lot of fans and
treasure hunters on that top
battlefield. It is fan hunter make a
gold get a point. Shisel really locking
down the targon's peak.
>> Yeah, I will say Targon's Peak is such a
strong card or strong battlefield in
Draven. For a lot of matchups, I feel
like the Targon's Peak is almost the one
where you're like, "Yes, this is my
game. It doesn't matter really what you
do. I have it. But it's Draven versus
Draven. How is that really going to work
out here? I mean, two is the magic
number. So, we were able to ready two of
them. But Sam can do that, too.
>> Yeah, it's interesting cuz like you said
at the top of this match, both players
do have the same battlefields here. So,
choosing to bring in different
battlefields for this second game, which
makes some sense given that generally
the thought is you play your your best
battlefield to open with and then you
have a battlefield for when you're going
first and a battlefield for when you're
going second. And after game one, you
always know what's going to happen cuz
your opponent gets the choice and you
just kind of pick whatever battlefield
works out for you. It is going to work
out though because of obelisk. Both
players are going to kind of get obelisk
when they want it, which does also give
obisk to your opponent. But in general,
I feel like on even playing fields quite
literally in this case. Both players
happy to navigate here cuz again it is a
mirror at the end of the day. And
they've certainly played plenty of these
on route to this round of four finish.
>> Yeah, we could see piercing light again
this turn just you know able to take out
treasure hunter and Draven. It won't
have the same exact effect as game one
since we got that second unit because of
the obelisk. Uh but that being said,
stopping Sam from generating all that
gold will be nice. And taking a four
might unit off the board super early
could be good as well. But instead, it's
going to be an accelerate accelerate
Kai'Sa. And you can't run treasure
hunter away the same way you could on
Reverse Ray Row. But ooh, a fight or
flight is coming down here.
>> A hard bargain out of here for Shisel.
That would be such a good punish cuz
this Kaiser looks so good in this spot.
Looking to conquer draw two cards thanks
to her conquer trigger and Draven's
ability, but does not come through. The
fighter flight does successfully push
the Kaiser back to base. Keeps the
treasure hunter on board for potentially
scoring a point for holding and kind of
mean Shisel has to go back to the
drawing board here. So, what spells
coming up next? We're going to cycle one
power, ride the wind away, and do it all
again. Get out of there.
>> This time it looks like we will succeed
at uh both staying in the combat and
winning it. And you, as you said, get
those two card draws. One from her
ability when you conquer and one from
when you win combat.
>> Such a good punish here for Shisel
having a way to get back in after that
final flight. Was trying to prevent that
play again. Definitely don't want to
make missteps in combat versus Draven. I
think Shisel correctly going to retreat
Kaiser back to base here. That unit is
so good when it's conquering. So, you
basically always almost always want it
home when you can. And again, extra
punishing in Draven, even though you
don't have the same access that Kai'Sa
did in Origins as her chosen champion.
Still a card that both these players are
happy to run a lot of. And there are
three in each of these decks. And Sam
hasn't seen a single one so far. Shisel
having one in both games. But still
plenty of play here. Three points to
one. Looking good for Shisel trying to
make the comeback here and even up the
match, the game score, excuse me. But as
we as we know, there's a lot of play
left still in this game.
>> Yeah, I mean, we were so confident at
the end of last game and Sam was was
able to bring it back. I think that I
mean Sam is definitely feeling a bit
more confident this game, but Shizzle
has moved all of his units from those
battlefields. He's going to protect them
in his base and kind of decrease the
amount of ways that these the might on
his board could get decreased. Falling
Star could still kill them. It can hit
in the base, but that's only one of the
few options. Yeah, again I think over so
good at protecting your bigger units
that you're kind of wanting to wait
until you can maybe do something like
deploy a ferris 4runner. So just going
to be patient here and the fan's going
to go down to the target peak. Grab a
point and once again Sami Sherman kind
of playing catchup as far as the points
race goes. This is going to be two. That
mindsplitter though is going to be huge
in this spot. Fans out the hand. Only
three cards left. Kaiser and sorry four
cards. Kaiser though just drew a card
and so do Draven. So Shisel has
basically nothing to work with now after
this. Mind split is going to strip the
best card away.
>> Yeah, I wonder what uh Sam will decide.
Obviously the one of Darius is kind of a
threat and I wouldn't be surprised if it
is since it's a one of otherwise
spinning axe is such a huge I mean
monster in this mirror match. It's
something that Sam really has to worry
about. But there's not one of them that
it would really matter with. There's
two. So does it matter to take one of
those away? I think if you know the axes
are there, it's definitely not worth
taking them away, especially because you
can't deny the effect outright. I think
at this point, if I'm Sam, I'm deciding
between Ferris 4unner and this Darius,
which do I care about more? Do I care
about the unit that readies quicker,
that has more might when it's coming in
aggressively, or do I care about maybe
the better defensive unit, once my
opponent gets on the battlefield, and
Ferris 4 sticks there, especially next
to something like Overzealous Fan,
that's a pretty tough battlefield to
crack if you don't have something like a
rebuke to kind of reset the situation.
So, Mindsplitter is big. It's a seven
and there's an Overzel fan standing next
to it cheering very very loudly and
instead it is going to be the Darius. So
I think wanting to protect the
battlefield that Sam has set up and uh
make sure that Darius can't come
crashing in to try and mess up the
plans.
>> Yeah, I think Darius is a good pick. Sam
is up a game so he can also make less
conservative choices. Not saying that
the Darius is that, uh but he can do
that. He has a game that he could lose
and still come back in game three if so
needed. Uh so but you know Shisel is on
the ropes here. He has to win this game
or he won't be going to a game three.
>> Yeah, points feel valuable enough here
for Sam that going up with the Draven
does feel worth it. Pretty tough to
challenge this Draven as well on Shisle
side cuz it is going to be six might
almost always. And there's going to add
a hidden card into the uh into the mix
as well giving Shisle something extra to
think about. Targon's peak being
conquered means runes are ready and all
of a sudden a lot of might being put in
a battlefield. Both points being scored
and runes being left open all feel like
excellent things for a mid-range Draven
player on the left. I talked about how
in mid-range going a little bit bigger
than your opponent having the biggest
thing is usually the best. Mindsplitter
I think one of the best big things you
can do.
>> Yeah, I think it is so nice. I mean it
threatens all those might just like you
said. We also got to decrease what
Shisel has in his hand. Hope no and gain
knowledge of what is there as well.
Chisel will have one extra card this
turn, but Sam knows three of the four
cards, which is really, really
important.
>> Yeah, the hand information is very
valuable. And this is a new card cuz
whatever was being cast does not cost
that. It is piercing light repeated. Two
to the fan, two to the mind splitter,
and I imagine four to the Draven. Does
that work out? Yes, it does.
>> Yes, that would be perfect. And I think
that would be the math that Shisel wants
to do as well. Uh this repeat on
Piercing Light is just so nice uh to be
able to kill the units on Sam's side. If
we could take out that Draven, it won't
only take out Draven, it'll also take
out that hidden card, which more than
likely is a fight or flight, but
technically could be something like a
Tide Turner or even a Switcheroo, which
was in Sam's side deck, which he's now
had access to since we're into game two.
Yeah, that actually kind of a fun one in
this spot as well. But unfortunately,
all the hidden cards don't matter when
everything's just kind of getting shot
at the battlefield. It's kind of like
falling star here for Shizzle, who
doesn't have that many copies of that
car, but does have two piercing light in
the main and of course being used to
great effect here. That hidden card does
go away. It was in fact a tide turner.
And the overzealous fan loses its best
buddy, Mind Spplitter, going straight to
the trash. So now this Kaiser, a couple
treasure, a treasure hunter, and a
couple of fans of his own can move over
and maybe try and challenge the mindset.
But of course, first things first, I'll
take my point and my card. Thank you
very much.
>> Yes, that will be really nice that we've
cleared out so much so Kai'Sa can just
ease in to that obelisk. I mean, Sam has
three runes up, but I don't think it's
going to be too much of a concern here.
Looks like we were able to get that
point, that draw, and now we just have
to deal with the mind splitter, who I
believe does have two damage on it.
>> It would now have cleared if it did have
damage cuz has happened. That that one
definitely gets confusing. Looks like
Shizzler's deciding to stack one of the
battlefields. They're going to play
Draven to base though. But it's two it's
a fan of treasure hunter and a Kaiser
all up top and mine just is going to be
left alone. So players will be tied dead
even on points actually. And all of a
sudden a race that Chisel seemed like he
was winning going to be basically closed
completely. I did see Sam hands Sam's
hand earlier though and I believe it is
ride the wind falling star and then
whatever card was just peeled off the
top. And again, when your opponent is
consistently denying you combat wins,
especially with things like Overz Fang
where you're trying to move in, you
don't get those Draven draws and your
hand can get thin pretty quickly. Both
players pretty low on cards. And there's
the falling star I spied earlier.
Overzale's fans getting kicked out of
the venue and straight to the bin.
>> That is such a nice play by Sam. Those
Overzilla spans are just like an a
constant threat similar to that of a
fight or flight if he decides to go into
those battlefields. But we are going to
be having another falling star come down
it looked like to put more out and then
mind spplitter in to wipe out obelisk of
power.
>> Yeah, ride the wind doing a pretty good
Yasum impression to MF impression
ganking over to the Obelisk of power
winning a combat clearing the
battlefield and scoring a point. And of
course I me as I mentioned drawing a
card something that both players are
getting a little bit low on. And once
again all of a sudden it seems like ride
the wind is the card that's making the
difference here for Sam Sherman. Kaiser
deployed, not accelerated. Huge force
left in the base now up again on points
and is starting to make it really
challenging for Shisel to get any sort
of foothold on the battlefield cuz again
this mindsplitter I mean the hand
disruptor is one thing but it's just so
big.
>> Yeah, and that ride the wind was able to
ready it as well. It is an additional
text on the card and so we can protect
that mind spitter splitter back in base
threatening 11 might next turn that
Shisel is going to have to account for.
Sam won't get two runes this turn even
though he held on targon because it is
conquer only but Shisel could
potentially take advantage of that this
turn. Play what he needs to use his
resources to the fullest extent then
take Targon's Peak and have two more for
when Sam tries to reconquer it. Yeah, we
actually haven't talked about this this
much, which is funny cuz there's been so
much Draven this weekend. But one of the
things that's kind of happened in Spirit
forge when with Draven being so popular
is that people just don't really want to
play on the battlefields all that much
because it just leaves you vulnerable to
combats and combat is exactly where
Draven wants you. So that extra ready
that you pointed out on Ride the Wind
helping out by just being just being
able to retreat and say, you know what,
I'm ahead on points. You have to come in
and conquer these things. And that's
exactly what I want cuz then I can come
in, beat up her units, and draw more
cards. Yeah, that is a great point. And
we are up into Targon's peak now. Just
going to
we looks like we only have five cards
here in hand. So, we will have to decide
how we want to develop our board. We
also have eight runes that are ready. It
looks like though, you know, I may not
be the best at counting, so I could be
wrong with that. Uh but
>> but correct.
>> Awesome.
>> It's a first four hand chisel spinning
axes that we do know. But again, Sam has
decent hand information here, but I
think Shizzle deciding how much to
commit to these battlefields. Have to
imagine a 4Runner is going to make it
onto this peak, though. That seems to be
what's tapped. Oh, is that a mine
spplitter of Shisel's own? No, that's
six roots tapped, one power depleted. It
is indeed Ferris 4runner. Shisel is
going to make a stand at the bottom
battlefield here.
>> Ooh. Yeah, that Ferris 4runner. And we
see that hidden card come down. This
hidden card is going to be so important
for Shisel. So, when you see that hidden
card come down on Ferris 4Runner, uh you
basically always know it is going to be
a fight or flight, and I mentioned this
briefly, but a big threat for the Ferris
Berrunner could be a rebuke from Sam.
Um, and rebuke I do believe has to be at
a battlefield. And the problem is is if
they're able to take out that Ferris
BRunner for only two and two, where if
you paid six for one, there's a huge
issue. However, fight or fight when
hidden is actually a reaction, not only
an action. So, you would be able to
react to that that rebuke and send it
back to base where it is safe. S safe
versus if you keep fight orflight in
hand, it's an action and you can't
respond to a spell with an action.
>> Yeah, leaving that top battlefield open
feels a little awkward here, but Chisel
didn't really have much of a choice.
It's might spit a number two just going
to get all the hand information. We know
about the two axes. What is the third
card that Shisel is holding on to? And
that's going to give basically perfect
information for this splitter if it does
want to come into the bottom
battlefield. I can't imagine with a
hidden card and 10 might though being
represented that mindslitter is going to
go walk about down the bottom side
anytime soon. But Shisel just deciding
what do I want to respond with again.
The two axes are known and uh you've got
four runes up so might as well deploy
them.
>> Yeah, these spinning axes are going to
be so nice. As long as we don't lose
them during our opponent's turn, we can
reuse them and reattach them if they get
lost, which is going to be really nice.
Does look like both of them are coming
down and leaving Sam with only one
option for this Mindsplitter of Edge of
Knight, which is one of my favorite
hiddens. Honestly, this set,
>> it's actually like decently some good
information there for Sam cuz it's one
of the hidden cards you can cross off
the list. It's only a one-off in
Shisel's list. And now that you've seen
it, you know it's not hiding at that
bottom battlefield. Of course, you
mentioned already it's very likely to be
a fight off. That's kind of what you
always expect. But I think Sam has
decided I'm actually ahead on points.
I'm just gonna play to win by holding
this top battlefield.
>> Yeah, and it's not a bad plan. Uh, this
Darius though currently is a tin, which
is a pretty not Darius, Draven is a
pretty big Draven. We could still move
Draven out if we can get something. Both
of these units are ready. So, if we have
either a fight or flight in hand or
decide that we are no longer going to
use this defensively for our ferris
4runner, which is what it looks like
it's going to be, we could bring that
Draven back and it would maintain being
ready.
>> Yeah, more accurate Draven holding two
spinning axes is always nice to see.
She's looking to retreat the Draven with
both axes and going to go ahead and
waltz on over to the other battlefield.
14 + 4 is 18. That is not how much might
Draven has. 6 + 4 is 10 plus two for the
Draven is 12. So, there's going to be
something else here for Shisel
>> to note. We did kind of see the card
that got drawn. I do believe it's a
rebuke. Uh so, that Yeah, that's going
to be really nice here going into this
mind this these two mind splitters. And
because Sam has no runes up, we know he
can't do anything to stop it.
>> Yeah, and that's going to be uh both
units down. Draven getting in there, a
conquer happening, a point being gained,
and of course, a card being drawn. And
Shisel is desperate for cards right now.
Out after that minds splitter happened.
Used the two axes, committed everything.
Finally getting a few cards back in as
Sam is going to have to try and find an
answer. And I talked about mindsplitter
being very good in these kinds of games.
It is pretty resource inensive. I don't
think you're going to win this game when
Chisel's at seven points threatening to
hold on either battlefield by playing a
mindspplitter and hoping you hit
something good.
>> Yeah, it is going to be difficult. Here
we do or we are effect to three cards
now on Chisel side which is a lot nicer
than that one or zero even that we had
at the end of our opponent's turn there.
Uh I guess we have one card right now.
>> Yeah, picking between stack deck doing a
little trickery there. Looks a little
like brainstorm sometimes but instead
it's no hopeful reinforcing the bottom
battlefield. I don't think Sam can win
this game and and he's going to draw his
card as a pleasantry but this is a lot
of might and a lot of units to kick off
these battlefields. You have to dislodge
both of them to get anywhere. So stack
deck's going to start and see if we can
get somewhere else. There's one rebuke,
but there's four units. You have to move
out of the way and you sorry, three
units, and you have no units of your
own. So instead, we'll play a third game
here. See who's going to make it to the
finals on mid-range Draven.
>> Yeah, let's see. Fantastic game by
Shisel. We'll be going into a very
similar one for game three. Obliska
power and Targon's Peak will both make a
uh reshow into game three, but on
different sides here. Again, we'll have
to keep an eye on who's conquered.
Keyword conquered uh Chargon's Peak on
their turn because that will help them
keep runes up during their opponents
which they can respond with those spells
in hand. We are going to see what they
have here with three runes up though
because of that obelisk. Sam will be
able to stack deck and try to find one
of those two costs.
>> Shisel's hand is really slow. I can see
him flicking it back and forth pretty
rapidly. There's a single two. It's a
tie turn and not all that exciting. A
seven and a five. Sorry, a six. I think
Britney is a six. Uh but the reason I
think Shizzle is happy with this keep is
cuz he's going second. There's an Obis
can play and the unit he can play on
turn number one is none other than
Kaiser, which has been very very good
all game long.
>> Yeah, he's got a couple different
options with these four runes. We could
decide to go a little bit slower, keep
two up with just playing that I think
it's a tide turner he has or go for
Kai'Sa who could draw more cards later
because of her conquer ability or Draven
who obviously is our chosen champion and
is not in hand but is accessible on the
table.
>> Feel like Kaiser no looks pretty
attractive. It does not want to actually
wouldn't even DM cuz it only happens if
you accelerate. I think Shisel may be
valuing the surprise, let's say, of
Kaiser accelerating out conquering and
getting two draws between her conquer
trigger and the Draven legend ability.
So, Titan is going to be left to hang
out to chill and probably conquer this
Targon's Peak. It's kind of it's I mean
it's the same Battlefield match up as we
saw in game two. So, texture of the game
battlefield wise is exactly the same as
what we've just seen. Felt like Rebuke
has really been the key card at least
for Shisle in that last match and did
help Sam get over the line in the other
one. Speaking of Kaisa, by the way,
there she is. Over we go for an extra
point and a card. Now it's this now Sam,
sorry, with the fast start to this game.
>> Ooh, getting these two points so early
just on our second turn is going to be
so nice for Sam. And I did see a couple
of different cards in his hand that he
can use to help protect his position in
these battlefields. We have those two
runes up from Targon's Peak and there's
options like fight or flight right in
his hand right now. Yeah, that peak is
absolutely that at this point of the
game would not have looked all that good
if you just conquered one of these
battlefields and certainly Kaiser would
feel a bit risky, you know, against the
face up Draven in the base of Shisel,
but with a couple of interaction spells
to play for here. Kaiser feeling a
little bit more protected. So instead
going to go top side and try and take
out the tie turn. It does recycle one
floating a energy and pumping up the
Draven.
>> Yeah, he's really respecting the fact
that there's different things that these
two runes could be. It looks like it
will be fight or flight coming down
though to push I think Draven back.
>> That does seem that I assume that is the
target here. Titer not really a unit you
want to save all that much. They're
happy to try and take the tempo here and
push Draven back to base. But Ride the
Wind in Chisel Sense I believe his only
copy of this card. It is in fact the
only copy of this card. Doesn't even
have an extra one in the board. Might
kind of undo all the plans. In fact,
Hard Bargain's just going to do the easy
work there for Shisel. Stopping that
spell, getting that conquer. We can
still ride the wind over if we want.
Take out the Kaiser, get a draw from
linear combat again and kind of undo
Sam's excellent start.
>> Yeah, this is so nice. That hard bargain
does mean that the fighter flight would
have costed at least four. Um, but we
only had the two runes up. And as you
said, fighter flight, not fighter
flight, ride the wind is going to come
down. He's going to go into that obelisk
and with six might kills the Kai'Sa. And
of course, the text we always forget on
chosen champion Draven. Uh whenever you
win a combat, get a gold. It's not just
draw a card for me legend ability, you
get extra gold as well. And even with
the unit being ready, can retreat back
to base if Shisel is so inclined. So,
lots of good stuff happening on that
turn there on the right hand side of
your screen. And Shisel is going to
retreat the Draven slowly but surely
back to base and will reset two runes
thanks to Tigon Peak. So, Tide Turner it
is. Yeah, that is going to be so nice.
Knowing that you're going to get those
two runes up means that we can use our
resources to our fullest the fullest
extent that we want. Does we aren't I
think we may have forgotten our trigger.
>> That's okay.
>> It's late. It's been a long weekend and
it's not going to matter too much here
as Sam taking kind of a turnoff just to
redeploy some units in the base. It is
Draven and his overzealous fan occupying
the bottom section of Sam's playmat. But
Chisel untaps with all the tempo now.
ready to take two more points, ready to
maybe do some conquering, maybe ready to
play the Kaiser that's been in hand that
we know about.
>> Yeah, Sam had to take basically a turn
off there to re get his units. That turn
by Shisel last turn was so nice to, you
know, stop and reset Sam's tempo while
we are at equal points. He couldn't take
any of the battlefields. And now Shizzle
potentially going to four here knowing
that there are no runes up on Sam's side
because he had to dedicate all of them
to creating units in the base.
>> Yeah, when you don't have runes up, when
you don't have a hidden card, really
nothing to fear when Draven is tapped
out. Genuinely true in Riftbound, there
are very few spells that are free,
although there are some. And stack deck
kind of going to be the cherry on top
here. And again, if Shisel remembers the
trigger, we'll reset two runes at the
end of this as well. So already drawing
a card off Kaiser for the conquer
already getting a point getting back in
the lead as far as that race is
concerned up one point overall 3 to2 in
this game and stack that going to give a
little bit more selection as we'll have
to see if Shiz wants to claim point
number four have to feel like tide
turner relatively safe unit to push over
there especially if you have some tricks
you can untap with I do see a fight or
flight in hand we are going to pop the
gold to hide a card perhaps certainly
seems to be the thing that Chisel is
thinking about let's hide that fight or
flight shall we right under the targon's
peak
And then it's just a matter of do we
want to potentially throw away a unit
quote unquote to get an extra point. And
the answer is actually we don't. Again,
respecting Draven's legend ability.
Don't want to give an easy combat for
Sam D. Sherman to win.
>> Yeah, I mean it does look like he has
five to six cards in Sam Sam's hand, but
we don't want to give him the ability to
keep drawing or as well to start
generating gold on Sam's side, which he
could use to keep his resources up. See
rebuke see a spinning axe here for Sam D
Sherman. I see a Draven rumbling on in
and just saying I guess it's a fight off
light. I guess I have to play against
it. I mean you can't do nothing. Kaiser
is a card that is very very good if you
leave her unchecked. I see Switcheroo as
well. Not all that good in this
particular spot. So Draven's going to
send on in recycle a rune float and
energy. I have to assume indeed the die
comes out to indicate that there is
still a resource remaining for the rest
of this turn. And now Shisel has to has
to answer the question. Do I want to use
a card in my hand or the fight or flight
hidden under this battlefield? And if
you do so, are you saving Kaiser or are
you pushing Draven? I have to think with
Draven's legend text, you're probably
pushing the Draven away, but Chisel
likely a bevy of options here in hand.
>> Yeah, I we'll have to see what he does.
does. I mean, he could also fight or
flight to protect our Kaisa as well, but
it looks like it will be done
offensively pushing the Draven back to
base. We do still obviously have so many
runes up here, which does mean Sam could
find a way back in. And that is going to
be that same ride the wind into Targon's
Peak and finally killing the Kai'Sa,
sending it to the track.
>> Yeah, I like that. Taking the time
before the showdown is done to move the
Draven back in. So, you're the one that
wins the combat, not the Kaiser. So
Kaiser down, Draven in, points scored
and card drawn. Everything coming up Sam
D Sherman in this turn. Now just another
question of what is happening at the
Obelisk of Power. Are we taking the
point? Are we playing it a little bit
slower here? Are we going to deploy the
Ferris fullr runner? I do spy in hand
alongside Switcher spinning ax and
double rebuke is the hand of Sam D.
Sherman. I'm impressed in the low light
of the feature area this late into the
convention hall here in Las Vegas that I
can just barely make out what cards are
in the hand.
>> Very good. I've seen enough of them so
far this weekend.
>> Yeah, we I think that uh you know, we've
seen these cards enough that just a
couple hints can help us figure out what
they are. I'm interested to see exactly
what Sam decides to do with the position
he's in. Uh he obviously still has those
six runes up. Could develop some more
might here in base.
We'll have to see. I
>> think pretty telling though that this
isn't the kind of matchup where you just
want to willy-nilly get all the points.
I say that and Sandy Sherman's about to
move the Overz fan in. Does decide that
this is a point worth claiming and
Chisel's going to think about it for a
moment before saying, "Okay, four points
now for our Draven player on the left."
>> Yeah, I think getting, you know,
equaling the same points is going to be
or nice and then getting above that.
Slowly trying to gain a lead on Shisel
here so we can take that win. And
overzealous span is kind of safe on uh
the I want to say completely safe on the
combat side. But if you decide to only
bring one unit up or if we decide to
protect it as well with a Ferris
4runner, we can use that ability that it
has to kill the overzealous fan and push
something back with a fight orflight
ability.
Sam also puts down that fair sporter,
but I wonder if he has a fight or flight
to protect it as a hidden card because
while we don't have any runes
unexhausted, we can still spend a power
to hide something.
>> Yeah, already this battlefield looks
pretty gross to try and check into it.
Went from being kind of puny to being
very overwhelming and it's going to get
even worse as a card is hidden under the
obelisk of power and Draven is going to
retreat after already doing his job. Sam
D. Sherman making, I would say, the
first big move here in the middle
section of this game to try and really
overwhelm
>> and stack a battlefield in a big way.
>> Looks like we're just deciding we want
to use different power and of course the
Targon's peak trigger
>> holding up maybe the best form of safety
Draven can ask for. That is rebuke ready
and available. Runes are getting a
little bit low, but the position is
really good for this Ferris 4unner.
Yeah, I think we're pretty happy here uh
for Ferris 4runner. It's protected
potentially by that fight or flight if
Shisel decides to use a rebuke. Uh and
obviously we do have multiple multiple
cards in hand that we can use as well
with those two out two unexhausted runes
from Targon Speak.
>> Look, I'm no master at reading body
language and I can't quite make out
Chisel's hand with the lighting right
now, but that does not look to me like a
player that has a rebuke in hand cuz I
think the decision gets a lot easier if
you do. potentially, right? But what if
we then spend those two runes and he
just fight or flights away? I guess is
one thing to think about because sending
two runes to the bottom of our rune deck
might be a price that we don't want to
pay if we don't get an effect from it
while Sam is also at a a point lead.
>> Makes sense. But uh if you I guess if
you feel like you have to get on this
battlefield, that is a way to do it. But
you are right. It kind of is just a
sucky situation all around. There is at
least a TW peak to go visit. I hear the
scenery is quite nice this time of year.
So, we'll see if Chisel wants to take
the easy points first or if Tide Turner
is going to go ahead and uh yeah, never
mind. Tie Turner is going up top. Does
not want to be involved in whatever
potential barbarism is happening in the
bottom side of the map. Just going to
take the point and keep it simple.
>> Mindsplitter. Yep, that looks like
mindspplitter to me.
>> Does look like it here. Potentially have
that mindsitter come down. I do think I
also saw a Darius in hand as well as a
stack deck potentially. Um, but yeah, we
will get to see our opponent's hand here
from that mindsplitter which is just
going to be so nice for Shisel gaining
that knowledge what's there and also,
you know, removing what he doesn't want.
I think Sam is trying to decide if he
wants to react to the ability before his
opponent actually gets to see his hand,
which would let him use these two runes
and potentially remove something from
what Chisel has the option to discard.
It's
>> interesting to think what card you might
play here. I guess you could rebuke, but
you're not going to stop the potential
conquer. Just a spinning axe here going
to be equipped to the Draven. Costs yet
another power. There is a golding
reserve, but have to awaken first for
that. And the choice is easy thankfully
for the mindslitter cuz it is just two
rebukes left and now down to one. I do
know piercing light is in Chisel's hand.
I saw overzeal fan. I believe I saw
Ferris 4runner and Brin here thundersong
are all the things I can currently
update you on. And looks like players
have decided that at the midsection of
this game the pivot is going to be to
try and stack a single battlefield. And
Chisel has decided that the Targon's
peak is where he wants to be and Sami
Sherman is firmly entrenched at the
obelisk of power. Yeah, I mean as long
as we've already conquered it at some
point now we're holding both
battlefields kind of don't have text on
them so it's not a big deal which one we
are holding long term. We did see during
game one uh
during the earlier games that Mines is a
great holding unit. Um but we do still
have three runes up here a threat for
whatever Sam Sherman does want to do. It
is a currently seven might Draven which
is enough to kill the mine spplitter.
And with it being Sam's turn, we could
still then reattach that same same
spinning axis to one of the units at the
bottom battlefield or to one of the new
ones that we might play with these five
runes.
>> Yeah, what I was going to say is that uh
by base might mind splitter is easily
the biggest unit in both these players
decks after sideboard. But Draven is
currently also as big as a mind spitter
at seven. And if we uh pay a power,
which we are going to do right now with
that gold, that's going to go all the
way up to nine. And I don't know if
we've done the math yet, but uh 7 plus
two is the same on both sides. Right
now, it is nine a piece as Sam Sherman
charges into the tagon peak and tries to
disrupt the festivities that were going
on up there.
>> Yeah, that's potentially enough to kill
both of Shisel's units. We if we aren't
enough to survive right now, but if we
can get something in there, we could
also get that Targon peak ability. So,
it looks like Sam has passed in the
action window. So, Shisel, I think, is
just considering, do I want to do
anything here? I'm just happy to trade
all these cards away. And looks like the
answer is yeah, I'll trade away.
Spinning axe, of course, is going to be
redeployed. You have to imagine on one
of these units. Now, the question does
become where do you put it? Cuz first is
rebuke target number one, and Overz Fen
sacrifices itself very often for the
greater good of Draven drawing cards.
So, not an attractive equipment option
right now, but maybe there's another
unit in hand for Sam to equip with that
deadly axe before it goes away.
>> Yeah, and it looks like we will be
spinning our five runes to accelerate
Kai'Sa uh or not acceler I'm not sure if
it's actually accelerate or it's just to
attach the spinning uh spinning axe, but
it is going to be the accelerate up into
Targon's Peak to get a point, get those
two runes unexhausted at the end of our
turn. And I'm assuming we will see that
spinning axe attached.
>> I have to think so. I mean, maybe think
about the runes you got cuz again, Sam
is burning through runes right now
trying to set up these really powerful
battlefields with pretty tough might
values to break, but the axe seems good
enough here to give three more points of
might to Kaiser. So, we're going to pass
back holding both battlefields at six.
There's a full run and a fan on the
bottom and a seven might Kaiser on the
top. And there is only a Draven here for
Shisel. Granted, a bevy of cards in hand
to play with, but once again, we are in
a position where if a player cannot
crack both these battlefields or at
least one of them, we know who our first
finalist is going to be.
>> Yeah, I mean, luckily Shizzle as long as
he can take one would be a or at least
clear one would be able to hold like
hold out one more turn, but it isn't
feeling good once you get to six points.
And when your opponent is threatening
already both of those battlefields, it's
going to feel even worse. Kai'Sa is a
seven right now. We've been talking
about how much might that is in this
deck, and that's a lot to break through.
Right now, this Draven is only
threatening maximum six unless we're
seeing spinning a uh spinning axes come
down for Shisle side as well, unless we
see some of those damage spells or some
spells to push Kaisa back into the base.
>> I'm pretty confident I've seen a
piercing light already out of Shisel.
And unfortunately, there's not much that
does. does I mean you can't go bottom
unless you deal with the fan and
piercing light can take care of that but
you don't really have good options for
repeat here if you're trying to take out
a unit cuz frankly Kaiser and Ferris are
just too big it's a six and a seven
which again we already talked about
seven is the biggest might total that
both these players are playing just on
its face so she's going to have to
puzzle through the rest of this turn
here I see a noxious hopeful I see a
Darius that might be the ticket here to
break up one of these battlefields and
there's no fan to maybe get that started
but not a lot of runes and a lot of
potential lines here for Shisle to think
through very carefully because again we
are now at the point in this game where
a misstep is going to cost you a spot in
the finals.
>> Yeah, so much to think about what can we
do with these eight runes that would
help us win or at least save a turn.
Shisel's really got to think here
because you don't want to look back at
your top four and say if I had just
played this this X card it would have
gotten me there. So we'll have to see
what he decides. Can't see every single
one there, but Darius could be a good
option. It could also threaten seven as
long as we can play a second card. And
since he is only five and one power,
we'd have the runes to do so.
>> Yeah, certainly plenty of uh options to
ready up that Darius if Shisel does want
to. As a reminder, it's not just a spot
in the finals these players are playing
for. It's not just the champion of the
original qualifier in Las Vegas. It's
not just the Blade of the Rune King
promo exclusive and playmat that goes to
the champion. You win this, you maybe
win honestly the best prize of all given
how the best of us have been doing. You
win the best of Draven. You are
officially the best Draven in Las Vegas.
Certainly likely in North America. In
fact, you know, it's been a pretty
global tournament. Maybe you're the best
Draven in the world cuz I don't think
Draven has run an RQ yet since Spirit
Forge has come out in the West. I'm
going to have to caveat that.
>> Yeah, I mean that's a great point and to
some extent if you win this one
particularly, you're the best of
mid-range Draven. You don't get an award
for that one, but uh you know like you
can pat yourself in the back and say my
mid-range Draven was the best mid-range
Draven.
>> Then you got to ask the question is
mid-range or miracle better? Something
we'll find out in our finals when we get
there. Shisel deep in the tank here in
our semi-final.
>> Again, all the the options can't be the
best ever if we have to think this long.
Clearly not a line that is clear.
Clearly quite a lot of uh problematic
things to deal with because again it's
also multiple turns from now. It's not
just what do I do to survive because
again I have to break at least one of
these otherwise I I'm going to lose. But
uh once I do that if I break only one
side well then what do I do next turn
when I have to also contend with the
same question but now if one of them is
holding I lose. So a lot of questions
and answers are only going to be in the
mind of our Draven player on the right.
We're going to start things off with
that piercing light and I think this one
is just a baby piercing light only for
two this time. So, Overzalis fan going
to be the first target and Ferris
forrunner going to be the second. So,
two damage marked on the 4Runner.
Overzalis fan kicked out of the pit at
the obelisk of power. And that's good
news for trying to take out this 4Runner
here and break the bottom battlefield.
This was certainly the trickier one to
take. But what else does Shisel have in
the tank?
>> Yeah, we do currently have Draven who is
four because of the two damage on Ferris
Berrunner. this Draven potentially could
kill it or trade with this Ferris
4Runner if we I don't think we would
want to pay the power because we would
so just trade six for six and we'd lose
a power we could trade otherwise but we
do have to worry about this hidden card
again we do assume it is going to be
that fight or flight to protect Ferris
4runner from a rebuke and it could be
used to push Draven back but by doing
this early before we've spent too many
of our runes we can you know threaten
Sam with six different runes as well as
make more plans later. It actually like
switch a route and it's still just going
to be six versus six
>> and I believe that's just base you go to
swap around. So, uh not really anything
worth swapping for there over with the
Kaiser. Yeah, swap the might of two
units at the same battlefield this turn.
So, actually the only option was the
four might Draven. So, uh pretty heads
up play there for Shisel to kind of mark
the damage and send on in. playing
around the switch rooms that are in both
these players list. Playing a pretty big
stack of those cards on either side and
also leaves up the Darius to maybe go
back in if it was a fight or flight. But
now that it isn't, can Darius go in the
top side and maybe boot this Kaiser out
of the Targon's Peak? Off the mountain
she goes? But seven might is a lot.
>> Yeah, I will say I do think Oh,
>> that's it.
>> Looks like it's going to be concede here
and I think
>> didn't have a way in. Kais was going to
hold for point. the two mess in the base
were going to get a point and there was
just nothing they could do. Couldn't
stop the conquer, couldn't put might on
the battlefields and all of a sudden
Sandy Sherman been taking out everyone
so far in this tournament. Still in the
running for the best of Draven advancing
to our grand finals.
>> Yeah, fantastic, fantastic job by Sandy
Sherman able to take game one and three
here. That Ferris 4Erunner was too much
to deal with and I loved that uh bluff
of the hidden. I think everyone you see
the hidden you say okay that's a fight
or flight how I'm going to deal with
that and he knew that would be in that
in everyone's mind so hiding switcheroo
not as good doesn't protect against a
rebuke but you could hope that he thinks
it will
>> yeah it's funny cuz I feel like for how
much ferris 4runner we've seen we
haven't really see it do the ferris
4runner thing I think we see we got two
mechs being made and didn't really make
a difference but actually it made quite
a difference this time cuz not only was
that battlefield tough to crack but even
when and cracked it. The conquer is
still being threatened. And Shisel had
to use all of his resources just to
break one of those. And turns out that's
not enough because it's not just the
hold that they're threatening, but
they're basically threatening a conquer
behind it as well. And you can see why
in mid-range matchups protecting
something like a ferris when your
opponent does have rebuke is a very good
way to win games.
>> Yeah, that is a fantastic point there. I
mean, you would want to be able to clear
both battlefields, but still three might
units each. And then you also have the
worry, right, that you're not going to
be able to continue turn after turn when
you only have four points.
>> Yeah, definitely a really uh intricate
game between these games. I think
showcasing that, you know, Draven isn't
just about, you know, playing these
great cards and shoving onto the
battlefield. There are a lot of
different decisions you have to make and
I think we saw both players pretty
expertly navigate around Draven's legend
ability. I think if you looked at all
the cards, probably not that many cards
drawn between the things. As we are
going to pull up our bracket because we
do have our finals. And in Miracle
versus Mid-range, TTA won the Miracle
Showdown 200. A player that has taken on
Allen ZQ and is now only one match away
from being crowned the champion of the
regional qualifier, Vegas.
>> This is going to be an interesting
matchup. I mean, we've talked about it a
little bit. It is Miracle versus the
more mid-range that we've been watching.
mid-range obviously is not as well
doesn't have a great matchup into
miracle itself. However, we are going to
want to see a quick rush I think.
>> Yeah, I mean I'm very curious to see how
this matchup goes cuz you kind of see in
Sam Sherman speed right mid-range kind
of have these chunky units that are good
kind of in the middle section of the
game. Certainly some play in the later
stages with things like ride the win.
Can build up very imposing boards. But
again, it's the explosiveness of Miracle
Draven that I kind of feel like gives it
an edge in almost any matchup again
given enough time. So, will mid-range
Draven be able to give uh give that time
to the miracle play? Cuz mid-range
Draven not a deck that is blazingly
fast, but it's not particularly slow
either. It's not trying to get all the
way to, you know, 8 10 runes and make
things happen. It's playing a two drop
and challenging you very early on.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. I mean, even
I think in the miracle matchup, you're
really hoping to get those two drops.
And Sam is running so many more than TTA
is. I'd be really interested to see how
much points that Sam can get before TTA
has his engine set up.
>> I have to tell you, we had Con on stream
earlier. Uh, very, very competent Draven
player. Was our last undefeated player
until being defeated by TT who's
honestly taking out absolute killers so
far of this tournament. I mean, beating
Allen is already a massive achievement
in and of itself. So, the fact that uh
TT also won the miracle match up against
Colin, who's an extremely good pilot,
finishing in uh in the semi-final is not
the result he may have wanted. And TTA
now advancing and maybe adding a new
household name to the riftbound scene.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. I was
actually talking to the players earlier
and it sounds like TTA and Colin faced
off during the Swiss rounds and TTA lost
there, but he obviously gained some
great knowledge about Colin's deck as
well as how he plays it and he was able
to bring it back and win in this rematch
that happened.
>> Yeah, was a two-0 as well. We did go to
three games in our game, but it was two
zero on the other one. So very excited
to see it's again again we kind of set
up the bracket not intentionally in a
way that where there's just uh two
different archetypes of Draven on either
side of the bracket and we haven't seen
them play each other yet but we got a
little bit more information about how a
winner went in an interview that we're
going to throw to right now.
>> All right Sam we're making a habit of
this and uh first Riftbound tournament
first big event. You find yourself going
into the finals with a chance to win it
all. How are you feeling?
>> I'm so excited. The farthest I've ever
gotten in a Magic tournament is top four
at a Grand Prix. So, uh, this is a new
personal best, you could say. And I've
really, ever since I've been competing
at big card tournaments, the one thing I
really wanted was to win a trophy. So,
you know, I got one match for it. And,
uh, yeah,
>> you have a chance for that right now.
You're going through a Draven Mirror.
You played a lot of you so far. Are you
confident?
Um I my understanding is he's miracle so
I think I'm a little favored but you
know anything can happen. Um hopefully
it goes well for me.
>> All right so a trophy on the line. We're
going to find out what happens. Finals
is coming up. All right. Well it's time
to go to break. Regional qualify. Las
Vegas is so so close to finishing it
off. There have been incredible games,
incredible matches all weekend long here
in the feast match. We've seen Leona.
We've seen each other. We're popping off
at every possible step. But the feature
match era can only contain matches for
so very long. And there's one more left
to find out who's going to be our
champion. Stay tuned.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat up here.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Welcome back to our final bit of
coverage here at Regional Qualifier Las
Vegas. on Patre time and my voice is
followed by Earth days in just a moment.
But if you like what you're seeing here,
you know what you should do? You should
get on down to your friendly local game
store and play at Nexus Nights. The best
way to meet new people, play games, have
a good old time, and you know what?
Maybe win some prizes. There are some
pretty sweet promos available at your
Nexus night.
>> Yeah, I think they're one of my
favorites right now, the Nexus uh energy
arts. They are so pretty with the spirit
blossoms from Spirit Forge. So, that's
my pull for this this.
>> We saw Randy rocking them all weekend
long, which was pretty sweet to see.
Lots of cool rumors you can get. Some
are honestly pretty valuable as well at
times. And I feel like they keep coming.
They keep getting better as the sets
keep releasing.
>> Yeah, that is completely true. And I do
believe they're supposed to kind of do
the competitive cards as well. So, a
great way to catch up.
>> All right. Well, here's our bracket.
Just to remind you how we got here. We
had eight players to start off our round
of eight. And we have whittleled it down
to two. We just draven all the way down
since we fit our final four. Sam D.
Sherman, our mid-range Draven player,
going to be up against TTA, the Allen ZQ
Slayer on Miracle Draven.
>> Yeah, this is going to be a great match
to watch shortly here. Really excited to
watch that Miracle versus the mid-range
Draven lists.
>> Kind of had a little bit of everything
so far this we had a Jax in the top
eight. We've had a Aurelia that we
didn't get to see on stream. We had an
Ezreal, but all of those legends have
fallen by the wayside. the fin the best
offs have been giving out for just about
everyone but Draven which we are going
to determine also with this finals but
before we get there we have something
fun to show you and I'm very excited to
see this because I haven't seen it yet
either unleashed as you know is going to
be the third roof bouncer coming out so
there are some things we can show you my
goodness that looks gorgeous
>> that is so cool looking another really
cool rune we were already talking about
him and this is so pretty
>> feel like we keep getting runes every
single set there's the karm okay okay
that's going to be extreme extremely
problematic for me as a player that
really does love Karma. I have to say
the runes have looked pretty nice, but I
haven't quite have uh my eyes snared by
one just yet until very until right now
when I saw this on stream. Here's the
chaos run for you all. A nice little
squiry thing in the sky. And there's a
scuttle crab in the bottom section of
the P. Blabberfish will be happy.
>> These are adorable. Yeah, I mean I feel
like they do the most fantastic runes
every time.
>> Yeah, I mean it's so cool to see each
set have their own themed set of altars.
We saw the spirit box ones you were
talking about already. We had the
original ones out of Origins. Now
unleash is going to give us even more as
there's the mine rune sitting in the
fountain. I believe that is a nexus
crystal or maybe an inhibitor crystal.
But a fun little bit of landscaping here
from League of Legends as more art and
more landscapes get brought to the
games. The final one here is going to be
the auto rune. And those are all looking
real nice. Unleashed brings League of
Rift Fantasy to Riftbound through
leveling, perfect timing, and explosive
play. If you're a fan of League of
Legends, this set is going to look an
awful lot like the League game you
already know and love. Previews kickoff
in full on March 16th, but keep an eye
out for another reveal reveal before
then. The dev drop will feature some
names players will know. And for the
Chinese dates, the pre-ift begin on the
3rd of Oh my goodness, my dates are hard
to read cuz I'm from Australia. The 3rd
of April, 2026, and the release is on
the 10th of April, 2026. For English,
pre-ift begin on the 1st of May, and
release is on the 8th. And as a
reminder, Unleash is the final set
before the English and Chinese launches
converge together for set number four,
which is an incredible feat given how
the timelines began that they are going
to converge that early. The final set
with not simultaneous release is going
to be unleashed. And already just from
those rune reveals alone, it's looking
pretty sick.
>> Yeah, those runes look so pretty. I am
torn what I'm going to be running in my
decks coming up, but I'll have to be
looking for my pre- rift. I am so
excited to get to see all these cards,
especially with the releases coming out.
>> You can do the truly chaotic thing and
get kind of slowly get one of each as
they release more sets. I think a rune
deck is just, you know, 12 different
unique altars.
>> That is true. It would kind of be cool.
Honestly, I think I might actually like
that. Uh, as long as actually one of
each.
>> Yes. Uh, I would not like that because
that that irritates me for reasons I
cannot fully explain. For some people
out there, that is a thing you can do.
And for players, they're going to be
playing some Draven Mirez. Here is TTA's
disc as deck. Sorry, as we noted on the
miracle shell, three russes, three
seals, three battering rams, a couple
fizzes, a falling stars, and a partridge
in a pantry. Bushwack definitely a card
to keep your eye on there as we look at
Sam Sherman's mid-range draven list,
three ferris runners, three Kaisers,
three Dariuses, two Brin here thunder
tongs, which are going to be pretty good
in this particular matchup and a little
bit more removal in things like falling
star. But of course, we have to look at
cards like fight or flight, which both
players will have access to. We heard in
the interview that Sam said he feels a
little bit favored in this matchup. So,
we'll have to see who is going to reign
supreme. The best of Draven is on the
line. And everything is now coming down
to this. We started with almost 1,600
players, now down to just two.
>> And I am so excited to see how it
starts. I think one thing that's really
important for both of these players was
kind of actually starting with a twocost
unit. It does look like TTA did miss
that. He is only running three to cost
is going to be that traveling merchants.
Meanwhile, Sam had nine in his list. So,
it is no surprise that we see that
treasure hunter in the base right now.
>> Yeah, I think the general expectation
and maybe why Sam feels like he is a bit
favored in this match up certainly as
far as getting on board early and
getting some uh some points into the
game. Uh mid-range Draven on the right
is going to be doing a little bit more
of that. But Miracle, as we know, can
have some very very unfair looking
turns. So, I don't think Sam can let the
game push on too long, but again, his
deck is one that is kind of designed to
get ahead early and then get really
ahead in the mid game and shut out the
game with things like Ride the Wind.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. And I think
it's really interesting here looking at
these different battlefields that our
players decided to run. I feel like a
lot of times, especially with mid-range
Draven, we normally see Reaver's row,
especially so we can protect our units
when someone comes into attack, just
continue to add more and more might in
our base. But Targon's Peak is one of
our strongest ones. And we know in this
case that TTA is going to take a little
bit longer to come online. Sam Sam's
List starts a little bit quicker, has a
lot more units, and TTA is going to try
to get to that later game with that
miracle shell.
>> Going to be even more units here.
Treasure Hunter and Nox is hopeful also
coming through as Titan are now the one
occupying the battlefield in the bottom,
resetting those two runes and passing
the torch back over to TTO. Started with
Trafarian War Camp, which I was looking
at the list and trying to figure out
what's going on there. And I have to
feel that maybe it's just a way to get a
bit more might on Battlefield so that
things like falling star aren't so easy
to pick off your smaller units or maybe
a way to dodge some damage spells. But
does feel like in this matchup in
particular for the most part it just
kind of is a wash right every the buff
applies to all units at the battlefield.
So yours and your opponents but with
things like Ferris 4runner those mechs
can get a little bit bigger than you
might expect. So I don't think TT can
really take advantage of this
battlefield quite so much but I'm sure
Sam can in some niche cases.
>> Yeah it's going to be interesting to
see. I do kind of wonder if it plays
into the fact that a lot of these uh a
lot of these decks have things like that
fight or flight where it doesn't matter
the might, right? Or rebuke. It doesn't
matter the might. Meanwhile, if you go
into a deck that is running things like
the falling star, the piercing light,
suddenly there's extra hoops to jump to
actually kill your units.
>> Yeah, it's interesting too. There are
spinning axes in the list list as well.
Don't always see too many in the miracle
shells, but uh TTA does have two. one
rebuke. We've seen that card be pretty
good uh most of this game. And then
Ezreal, of course, the one of the big
departures in list this versus Sami
Sherman not playing this card at all,
which has been kind of the talk of the
tournament. So interesting to see that
Ezreal is going to make it to our
finals, but maybe not in the fashion
that we expected it. So, a bit of my
added here. A big battering ram also
added, and that is a way for TT to kind
of outmuscle the mid-range deck, right?
The units are pretty big, have a lot of
good base might printed on them. can be
kind of annoying things like Ferris
4unner but when battering ram doesn't
cost too much energy it feels awfully
unfair.
>> Yeah, that is completely true. And DDA
is getting this early seal of discord
down that is so important for his list.
He's got a lot of units that do have
power and it's just really nice to be
able to keep your runes, not have to
recycle them to the bottom of your deck
and start to expand on how many
resources you have and hopefully more
than our opponent. Yeah, we've seen
those seals be pretty important and
actually we aren going to talk about
gear destruction in game one cuz I don't
think Sam Sherman has any having a
glance at list. We'll talk about it a
little bit more in sideboarding because
there's at least one spell that might be
pretty good. But for now, we aren't
going to bother with that because Ferris
4unner has come crashing down onto the
trifarian war camp alongside that
treasure hunter and all of a sudden that
one might that was technically two with
the war camp there. Looks an awful lot
bigger and even though there's no
overzealous fan protecting the ferris
4runner, there's a single rebuke here
for TT which has been the card we've
seen most often deal with the forrunner
and it's going to have to do a little
bit of overtime to get it done here
especially with a card being hidden at
the battlefield as well. Yeah, you did
say TTA has that rebuke in hand and but
we talked about this briefly last round.
Uh the fact that oftent times you don't
want to play Ferris 4 Borrunner until
you have a fight or flight to hide and
it looks like we are going to be hiding
a card here. This card most likely is
fight or flight to protect rebuke
because it has to be a card at the
battlefield and while you could use
fight or flight sometimes it is normally
an action card but by playing it hidden
it's actually reaction and we can
respond to that rebuke. You can see both
players kind of looking off as we had a
little bit of a bang in the hall. It is
getting a little late here in the hall
in Las Vegas. Things are starting to
shut down and the only thing left is us
here in the coverage booth bringing
these matches and our two players
fighting to be the champion of Las Vegas
and also win the best of Draven metal
card. There were four Dravens in our top
four. There were five Dravens entering
this and that single rebuke has made
their way in. And looks like we are
denying our Draven trigger. moved a
little quickly there for TTA, but the
rebuke is in hand and that is going to
be the target here for S uh for TTA as
Sam Sherman has to decide what do I want
to do and I want to do exactly what Ursa
Day told me to do. That's retreat my
first fora with a fight off flight.
>> Yeah, I mean it is so nice. We tried to
use that two uh two power two energy
card to get that six energy one power
out of the battle out of the field. but
instead a hidden card we've already paid
for is going to be able to stop that.
>> Yeah, had a gold there as well. So, kind
of prepaying for your power cost, so it
doesn't feel quite as bad to hide there
when you don't have seals. But a gold
also generated for a combat being won by
Draven on TTA side. And of course, a
card being drawn for Draven as well. And
we talked about Mind Splitter being a
pretty big might unit in the mid-range
Draven's list. Well, that's a seven.
Battering Ram and Rasa are fives and
sixes, and they're a lot cheaper to try
and deploy as the game goes on. So yes,
Sam Sherman in general has the bigger
units is wanting to try to play a little
bit bigger. But when your opponent has
multiple fives and sixes to throw at the
battlefield, your units do do not matter
as far as their might vales go values
go.
>> Yeah. And maybe that is something the
Trafarian War camp plays into as well
because we just have so many of those
larger might units. Even though it's a
lot of fives, suddenly it's a lot of
sixes and that does add up.
>> Well, Cold Shot uh probably the
interaction of the tournament at this
stage. Ezreal and Cold Shot and usually
with their best friend, Seal of Discord,
have been in perfect harmony all
regional qualifier long. The TTA going
to get to look at a lot of cards here.
Not it's not just the Draven Legend
ability that lets you draw cards. There
are plenty of ways for purple to power
through their deck. A stack deck now
going to get played for a bit more
selection and replace itself. Find a
card we like. Put the other two on the
bottom and perhaps pass things back
over. We'll see uh TT has anything else
left. I think it's two cards so far for
a potential battling ram. And I do see
three energy, but first things first,
Tyon's Peak going to be conquered here
by the War Machine.
>> Yeah, these COD shots and stack decks I
think are a huge difference between Sam
and TTA's lists. While obviously Sam
does have stack deck as well. TTA is
actually able to cycle through a lot of
his deck and decide what the order of
the deck he wants is while Sam won't
have that same option. Oh my gosh,
another battering ram though.
>> Someone didn't count nearly enough cards
being played. That someone is me. Cuz
those battering rams all cost one
reduced to their absolute minimum that
you can have. They cost one less for
each card you played this turn to a
minimum of one. They do start at five.
They have five might. It's all very neat
in the numbers department until your
opponent vomits out three of them in a
single turn, which is exactly what TTA
and the Miracle Draven build did, which
is exactly what Miracle Draven wants to
do.
>> Yeah, it is what Miracle Draven does
best. And it's discounting these units
just from all of the actions they're
able to do each turn. And suddenly 15
might for just three energy.
>> Looking pretty good there.
>> So, uh, TT going to fan out the
graveyard a little bit. And Sam Sherman
going to go into the tank. There is 10
might on that bottom battlefield. There
is seven up top and it could be two more
with a flick of the fury rune to the
bottom of the rune deck. So, call that
nine at the top part of the map. Call it
10 down the bottom. And we're going to
have 10 might roll in here. Nox is
hopeful. And Ferris 4Runner going to try
and do some damage. And uh TDA does
indeed want to trigger Dravens when I
attack or defend trigger. So two more
might going to be added over there. And
a fight or flight going to push out the
forerunner once again. This time cast by
TTA and not by Sam.
>> Yeah, a little bit different here. But
now suddenly this this Nox is hopeful is
really getting threatened. But it looks
like we're going to have a rebuke of our
own come down which does mean that that
Draven which was six by sending a power
suddenly not really something we look
at.
>> Yeah, kind of reduced a bit more simply
here in that exchange in top side.
Basically two sixes looked at each other
both flew away magically to different
zones of the board and then a four and a
three was staring at each other and Nox
is hopeful going to win the fight versus
little old Ezreal just about every
single time. So winning exchange there
for Sam. A card being drawn and the
points lead still in his favor. These
battering rams looking a bit imposing
again. They are so efficient when you're
able to play them for only one or two
energies. So plenty of might to answer
back with and there is one at home. I
like that TTA decided not to overstack
one battlefield. Knows that I do kind of
want to keep challenging for these
combats and not make it too easy for you
to sit at these different stations. But
a stack deck here is going to see at
least a falling star for Sam Don. And I
have a funny feeling that's the card
that was taken. But we'll find out in
just a moment as Sam likely going to No,
not going to pass back just yet. We have
six runes, so surely something else is
going to get played here.
>> Yeah, we have a lot of options with
those six runes. Uh Sam did have the
falling stars in his deck, but I'm not
sure we're going to see them come down
just yet here with this tin might in the
Targon's Peak. To note, I do think it is
great that we kept that battering ram in
the base just because while it's not a
great chance we're able to clear both
battlefields, on the off chance that we
do, we want to keep this moving and not
completely lose tempo. Well, if you have
10 might on one battlefield, I'm going
to have 10 might on one battlefield as a
tie turner joining that Draven
reinforcing from the champion zone. I
did get another look at Sam's hand. And
unfortunately, I am a liar this time
around. It is not Falling Star. It's
spinning axe at least as one of the
cards in the hand. And I think one more
for Sam to ponder over. So TT going to
awaken, score a point from the Targon's
Peak, which as you've noted many times,
importantly, not going to give yourself
the on conquer trigger. But the miracle
deck is starting to get its engine
online. There are eight cards in the
trash. There is one seal in play and
there are many more cards to be drawn,
especially when Ezreal makes his way
back onto the battlefield.
>> Yes, Ezreal is going to be able to
discard and draw two more cards. It
looks like we're discarding that falling
star to get those draw, but also he's
going to be able to discount additional
costs coming up that includes repeat
costs like calling shot and accelerates
or other things like that. but also are
dangerously getting close to that 10
cards in the discard pile. And TTA does
actually run three Rasa the Sunderers
which gets discounted by how many cards
are in the discard pile.
>> Yeah, between Rasa and Bushwack, those
are kind of the turns you really want to
look at when Miracle can start to
outmuscle you on a single turn and kind
of put so much might on a battlefield
that you can never find your way back
into the game while also simultaneously
clearing whatever combat they choose to
engage you with. So for now it feels
like TTA is going to have to take a
little bit of a step back and Bing Ram
going to join its friends at Targon's
Peak and do a bit of sightseeing as Sam
Sherman going to untap and take a point
and take a draw.
>> Yeah, let's see what we can do here. We
do have the 10 might stuck in the
Trifarian War camp, but it is kind of 13
right now with Trafarian War camp. Uh
but we need to get into Targon's Peak.
We have six, but we have so many runes
at our at our access as well.
>> Yeah, Sam getting a pretty big resource
advantage with TTI having to use that
power earlier. Not maybe finding as many
seals as you would like. Again, seals
very good at kind of giving you
resources, but the the tail on getting
that investment back is quite a bit
longer. And uh mid-range Draven not
really interested in making this game go
very long because the longer this game
goes, the better it is for Miracle. And
uh Sandy Sherman's here to win. Ferris
41 are now going to get equipped with
the spinning ax. Darius gets bigger and
ready and everyone's charging down
towards the bottom side. And battering
rams are going to get smashed to bits
here in this combat.
>> Ooh, this is going to be so nice. And we
are able to get every one of those
battering rams out of Targon's Peak.
Spinning blades is spinning axis is
still alive as well. And we have three
runes up to do extra things as well as
attach the spinning axes to one of the
other units. So A gets plus three might
but also so we just keep the axes in the
first place.
>> Yeah, interesting decision I suppose to
take out the forerunner there. Uh both
units were potentially targets. They
certainly couldn't get both obviously
that's why Sam won the combat but giving
two extra mechs to base doesn't
necessarily feel great but also kind of
at a point where you kind of have to
just clear it all out at some point cuz
Darius you don't really want to stick
there either. So with only so many
rebukes in TTS deck I believe it is just
one. So without a Fizz to potentially
buy that one back. tricky unit to get
off a battlefield. So, just deciding to
clear it out instead.
>> Yeah, we haven't seen Fizz from TTA just
yet. There are two in his deck, as is
very common with these miracle lists,
but we're going to have to see where
they can come out at one of these
points. Maybe play one of the spells
from TTA's discard pile and hopefully
turn this game around because Sam is
already at six points and he wanted this
lead. He's got it already.
>> Yeah, currently threatening a win and
the top battlefield looks a little tough
to crack. It's 10 uh 10 base might
without the war camp being factored in.
So 13 a bit extra from stacking it up
there in the top side. But Tyon is
swapping it up with the Darius is great
cuz don't really care about giving up a
point at this at this point. You're
already three points ahead here. You're
threatening to win with a double hold.
You're also threatening to win with a
double conquer on the other side of it.
They're even going to retreat the
hopefully. In fact going to retreat
everyone here and just say you know what
my army back home is so much bigger than
anything you can possibly muster. do
something cuz I'm going to win by
conquering if you don't.
>> Yeah, and I think we can also capitalize
on this a good bit, the Trafarian War
camp, because we have so many different
units, which is just each one of them is
going to get plus one from the Trafarian
War camp up top. So, we'll have to see
what they're able to do. But TTA does
look at this. He sees Sam is at six and
that's a really important number for
this deck and that hopefully we could
conquer both sides next turn. Yeah,
Ezreal are just going to have to go pay
tide turner a visit. And yeah, you win
the combat, get a point, and draw a
card. All pretty important things. So TT
has to decide, can I have a big enough
turn here to try and stack up a
battlefield? Cuz I think one of the
things that happens when Miracle falls
behind, and it does do so every now and
then. I think if you're not at this
point in the game where your opponent
can threaten a win quite easily from six
to eight, it feels a little bit better
to play a bit more defensively. But even
if you have a big explosive Rasa
Bushwack combination turn, he kind of
just priced into stacking everything at
one battlefield because the way you
primarily draw cards and take out units
is by fighting them. And if you're not
to the battlefield, well, we've seen
people retreat units all weekend long
against Draven. You don't want to get
into combat and the easiest way to do
that is just to abstain completely.
>> Yeah, I think that's a great point. It
was great by Sam to remove themselves
from the Trafarian War camp. While we
did keep something in Targon's Peak,
which offered a combat for draw, we're
not letting them draw twice with the
with the secondary battlefield up north.
>> GTA calling the shots and that graveyard
is now stacked into a pile after being
fanned out before. And I think it had
about eight cards in it when it was
found out. So, I'm going to say with a
pretty high certainty that it has more
than 10 at this point, which is exactly
where Rasa the Sunderer wants to be. And
I think we are going to have to see some
Ras reinforcing a battlefield here. But
we'll start by tapping through. We'll
make another Ezreal and we'll have to
discard a card to draw a few more. But
scrap heap going to give that bonus draw
every all the miracle players love so
much.
>> Yeah, this is such a great turn for TTA.
We do get that second sill of discord.
The discord uh the seal which we had to
pay a rune for. Get pays for itself by
paying for Ezreal and we discard a scrap
heap. What a great moment here. We'll
have to see if it's enough to turn it
around though.
>> Really digging through the deck is TT.
This is where again the the the deck can
shine by accessing so many cards. He
drew three off Ezreal. I think we played
another ESnote. That was the Ezreal
before. So Ezreal this turn for three
cards thanks to discarding trap. Two
cold shots both repeated I believe. So
that is we've seen seven cards already
and drawn five of those. And now Fizz is
going to do it all over again.
>> But what can you find at the end of the
line? That's the thing. The battering
rams are all gone. We found a falling
star. Back from the bin we go. You do
have to pay its power cost. So, a ton of
runes are about to go underneath the
rune deck.
>> Yeah, that is a great point. I wonder
what we are still looking for here.
Maybe we're still hunting out those
rosas if we haven't found them just yet.
That would be six more might for the
bottom battlefield, which would be
really nice, especially knowing that if
Sam can conquer both, we're in a in a
problem.
>> I feel like you it has to be roster cuz
you don't have battleing rams left. You
find another hopeful, but do you have
anything else? Cuz this isn't that much.
the units you've kind of played to get
yourself through your deck with such
efficiency are just not big units.
They're more utility units
hiding a card here for TTA. And that is
it.
All that digging and couldn't find a
single copy of your asses. You have
three of them. Going to get the peak
conquer trigger and untap two runes. But
there's so much going on in the hand.
It's just all small units. How many
tricks are there? We'll have to find out
in just a moment. But 9 + 4, that's 13
might only. I mean, I'm not even going
to do the math cuz I know Sam Sherman's
units are bigger. That's already more
might waiting at home.
>> Yeah, I think there's so much might that
Sam can threaten here. Obviously, I do
believe it is a fight or flight here in
the bottom battlefield. I think it's the
only hidden in his main deck. Uh, so it
could potentially push away one of Sam's
units, but he's got a lot of them and
he's still got a lot of runes as well
that he could be using. uh certainly
would is likely to be a uh a fight or
flight. It could be the uh the little
bushwack bluff as I like to call it,
which we did see actually from
Prismaticism on stream earlier in the
Swiss rounds. Uh that would really just
get your power back as you make a gold.
The readying your units on your
opponent's turn doesn't do all that
much. So not the card you necessarily
want to see, but kind of making uh Sam
D. Sherman think about it at least cuz
at this point total, it's not like Sam
has to go for the win this turn. So can
just respect the potential fight or
flight. So if it is a bluff from TT, it
might be a prudent one. But I have a
feeling Sam is just going to go rocking
in in some increments here and try and
cut down the battlefield one by one. And
when you do suspect it's fight or fight,
it's often safeish to go alone and just
see what you can chip away at.
>> Yeah. And I think especially with
spinning axes, it is so nice to go one
by one. You are giving more draw to TTA
by doing that. But each time you
reattach the spinning axes, it isn't
like you just gave, you know, Nox's
hopeful two from discipline and your
other guys don't get anything. The
spinning axis hopeful dies and now you
can reattach it to your tide turner.
Trade up to something that has five.
Reattach it to something else. Another
plus three. O
>> that battlefield just completely wipes
away. Draven goes down, but there was a
bushwack.
>> You were right. I think shows off the
rest as well. just conceding I believe.
Yes, it is. It's Sam Sherman taking game
number one yet again. Mid-range Draven
one game away from being crowned our
champion.
>> Yeah, what a fantastic job by both
players. I loved the bluff. We've seen
it a couple times now. Even when you
don't have that fight or flight, you act
like you have that fight or flight, but
it will be able to take us the game. And
TTA, I mean, both players will have the
option to sideboard. TTA has a couple
extra cards here. Obviously, Brin here,
Thunder Thundersong. He's also got three
Ferris 4runners in that side deck that
he could put in and last rights as well.
>> I'm not going to lie, most of this board
looks kind of attractive in this deck
for many reasons. Brin here is not bad
at shutting down your opponent's
potential tricks is obviously better
against maybe a deck like Ezreal or
maybe the mirror where there's a few
more spells being played in Flurries.
But Switcher actually seems okay here
cuz in general TT's units are going to
be smaller than Sam's units. Then rebuke
obviously against 4runner is a really
nice trick to have just having your own
forrunners when you're trying to fight
kind of these mid-range battles does
seem pretty good but Sam Sherman also
prepared hard bargain could be decent
two minds fitter looks great here the
falling star could be okay the last
rights that both players have access to
certainly something I think they're
going to want to bring in but I talked
about it earlier there is a way to undo
all those seals in Sam Cybboard a single
copy of the beam
>> yeah thermmo beam is so nice I feel like
a lot of gear removal that we see is,
you know, remove one gear, but Thermmo
beam is kill all gears, which is
absolutely insane. I do think
mindsplitter is also nice, getting not
only the information of your opponent's
hand, but also to remove something
there. And I mean, falling star, as you
mentioned, I think could be really good
in this matchup. You can kill Ezreal's,
which is really, really nice, and maybe
another unit as well.
>> Can see a deep exhale there from Sam on
camera, kind of understanding the
gravity of the situation. Actually going
to walk away from the table.
So, uh, going to get fight or flighted
off the feature match stage
and, uh, if it wasn't obvious already,
we are live here in this finals. We've
caught up to the event here. And, uh, I
think that Sam is going to take a little
walk, reset, prepare, visualize what
winning this game is going to look like.
Maybe just doing a little bathroom
break.
>> Yeah, it does seem like he's putting a
lot of pressure on himself from the
interview that we saw earlier with what
he was saying from his Magic Pro Tour
runs. it sounded like. So, we'll have to
see what he does here, but you know, a
lot of card games is that mental battle,
so maybe a deep breath will do him good.
>> You can see the deck list as well for
either player now available. Players
going to be looking over them and making
sure they know exactly what their
sideboard strategies want to be. In
general, have to feel like the players
have kind of mapped this out already
considering what their matchups might
have been on top. Although, they didn't
have all that much time as we reset Sam
at the feature match table and the
shuffling begins in our second game. I
mean, we have seen Sam play many game
threes so far this event. Is the final
going to be the time where he finally
doesn't have to do it?
>> That would be really nice to see, but
we'll have to see what both these
players do. It is the finals for both of
them. So, you know, they're bringing
their agame and I wouldn't be surprised
if this is game three again. Both of
these players have probably so many, you
know, rounds into these same decks
expecting Draven not too crazy. We have
played so many games here in Las Vegas
and we only have up to two remaining. As
uh to note, TTA actually has not lost a
game in the round of eight until just
now. Two his quarterfinals. Two his
semi-final and unfortunately dropping
the first game here. But the first one,
you know, sometimes you can give it
away. It's not so bad. Never feels good
to lose the first one. Always feels
great to win it. But it really just
matters that you win two. Doesn't matter
how many losses. Well, it doesn't matter
how many losses you take before it. As
long as you win two at the end of it
all, you'll get grab the best of three.
The crown, the glory, the trophy, the
money, the playmat, the promo, and of
course, the best of metal Draven card,
which I can't believe I'm saying that
cuz that is a ridiculous prize for
winning a final.
>> Yeah. And also, it'll be a great
comeback arc if you do, you know, game
two and three as a win.
>> All right, game two is kicking off. We
saw the battlefields. It is Obelisk of
Power for Sam D. Sherman and Zorn Warren
here for TTA. Will Miracle continue its
reign here as one of the most powerful
decks in Riftbound or is mid-range
Draven enough juice to get over the line
and be the champion of regional
qualifier Las Vegas?
>> Yeah, and we are into that game too. Zan
Warren is the choice by TTA. I think
it's going to be great for what that
deck wants to do for I mean Miracle just
wants to draw, draw and draw. It's got
scrap heap in its deck. It's got
traveling merchant and obviously that
Ezreal discard as well. So, we're going
to be seeing a lot of cards here on that
miracle side. Sam will get to access it,
but TTA is definitely set up to access
it better.
>> Yeah, you can see TT starting off with
the stack deck. Getting a little bit
more selection, maybe trying to find one
of the twos that inhabits the deck and
does find an Nox is hopeful. Not so many
of those. That is one of TTA's best turn
one plays. Yeah, and I do think he
really really wanted to find a turn one
going into that mid-range. We know if
Sam can get ahead early, then that's
going to be a bad spot for TTA. And
actually that obelisk is what allows him
to do it because obelisk gets discounted
by that stack deck that we saw and
suddenly it's not a four cost, it's only
a two cost. I don't want to read too
much into things, but TTA, I think,
starting to feel a little bit of the uh
the gravity of the finals, especially
how late and how long the tournament has
been. It has been a long weekend for
these players to battle all the way up
to this final two spot. He's kind of
plunking the runes on top in a little
pile. He's forgetting to awaken his
units every now and then. It is
important again to remember the little
things to keep everything clinical and
orderly because you want to at least
keep the automatic things automatic
because you have so much to think about
when matches are this high stakes. So,
we're back to Sam already. Dravens are
out, leaping from the chosen champion
zones and back into the base. And now
Sam Sherman starts to ponder, what do I
want to do this turn? There's a Darius,
which would cost all six runes. And
apparently that's good enough. It cost
52 cuz I apparently can't remember
energy cost from cards that were played
commonly in Origins. And is there a
stack deck to reset it? If there is,
Sami Sherman decides I don't want to do
it this turn. I'm going to make you come
to me. I don't want to get into combats.
I don't think I can win. So, I am just
going to wait. Yeah, I think both of
these players are kind of in a little
bit of a stall. You know, we didn't move
forward as TTA and Sam isn't deciding to
try to take either of these
battlefields. They know that, you know,
combat could mean extra card draw, which
could be dangerous for both of them
because you don't want the other to get
ahead in cards here.
>> Yeah. No, the uh you can pretty
accurately uh predict how much you're
winning a game by by how many times your
Draven Legend triggers in any given
matchup, especially in the mirror. But
the game being a bit slower paced is
somewhat concerning when Miracle has
such a great engine once it gets online.
And seal into seal into Ezreal into
discarding scrap peep is exactly what
the doctor ordered for a TTA comeback to
even up our grand finals potentially.
>> Yeah, it is exactly what TTA is going to
need to take this game to. Oh my god,
that is the perfect sequence for him and
he is, I'm sure, so happy for it. And
straight into a called shot here now.
Not only are we getting that extra draw,
we're getting that not having to pay
that power for Ezreal, but we're going
to get to see two cards for the price of
one. Well, four cards for the price of
the power of one.
>> Yep. That's a pretty good rate if you
ask me. And if you're wondering why TTA
might be going digging when you don't
have to do this. You have two seals
already. You could wait and maybe keep
your rune count a little bit higher.
Well, there's a little card called
Battering Ram I'd like to introduce you
to. There's two of them in the base.
Thanks, TT. Right on time. Yeah, and I'm
thinking he's seeing here that he's
playing it for one actually incre like
actually an incredible turn here on
TTA's side. I think that the game
couldn't be going better right now.
>> And again, the mid-range decks do want
it to be just a bit bigger than every
other deck they play against or get
under the decks that are really, really
slow. This is a position where the units
on your opponent's side of the field are
starting to look a little bit bigger
than you'd like. So, Sam Sherman will go
digging once again. stack deck is going
to go fanning through the top three
cards of the deck and we'll put one of
those in our hand and the rest recycled
to the bottom. We'll do a quick might
check while we're here though. It is
only nine right now in Sam's base and is
at least 10 just from the two rams and
we're going to add uh 8 and three which
is 11. So 21 to 9 again a great number
here in Vegas is 21 and TT off to a much
better start this game.
>> Yeah, I think TA is really happy here.
Sam has got had to go a lot slower. We
saw him play Draven and then Darius.
Two, I mean, good size units, but we
didn't even get to get Darius ready and
attacking the same turn that he was
played, which I mean is fine. We have
the M, but in this game plan, I think we
need him moving.
>> Yeah, I mean, the thing was is there's
nowhere for Sam to go cuz the whole
thing with Draven when you ready up
units is you want to go fight stuff. And
again, when you don't go to the
battlefield, when your opponent decides
to play pacifist, uh you can't really
get all the value you'd want out of your
fighting. But uh that is a nice little
trick there from Sam actually readying
after conquering to again keep the units
safe in base cuz I don't know how many
times I can repeat it. I guess not that
many more because we only have so many
games left here in Vegas. But do not
leave your units at the battlefield
playing against Draven unless you are
very sure they're going to win their
subsequent combats.
>> Yeah, they're definitely trying to
starve each other of resources here. Not
leaving anything in these battlefields
to be able to have a combat against. And
so not a lot of draw from these Draven
leaders, but I mean slower game is
exactly where TTA is going to fill at
home with. Another called shot. We're
going to look at more cards. And because
we get to choose which ones go to the
bottom of our deck, this Draven will be
able to know exactly what he's going to
be seeing later in this game cuz this
deck has the ability to cycle through
the entire
>> Yeah, every single time Ezreal lives,
another cold shot is played for an
extremely good rate. That just kind of
seems to be the trend that uh these
Miracle Draven decks do consistently
show. And that hand is unbelievable
as far as number of cards in hand. At a
glance, it's six or seven. That was not
on purpose. And I regret some of my life
choices. Ezreal going to go north
perhaps here. Perhaps with on the back
of a war machine, perhaps like a
battering ram. TTA lining up some
potential conquers and decides the zone
warrants is the first port of call.
Yeah, we're going to have to see if Sam
has anything, but if not, we'll be able
to go on and discard. Ezreal getting
discarded means I think TT is pretty
happy with his hand right now.
>> I'd be terrified if I was Sam and I saw
that happen.
>> A conqueror just throwing away this
Ezreal. Don't need it. Don't need any
more cards. Have more than enough. Going
to keep vomiting might into the base.
And already a question being asked on
the top side, but TTA's got more where
that came from potentially. and
everything for discounted prices, which
is just where this deck thrives. This
Noxis Hopeful, a two not a four here.
We're going to play another card.
Another Noxis Hopeful for two not four.
Discount after discount after discount.
And that's not even the best discount
that this deck can play.
>> And of course using the seal this time
to hide a card. That's the other thing
it does besides pay for cold shot for
free with Ezu's in play. So battering
ram going to represent 10 might on the
top. And there's going to be a hidden
cart as well, which as you mentioned is
really only one of two things. We
already saw the bushwack. This time I
think we're going to see the fight or
flight.
>> Yeah, it definitely could be. And we
also do have switch in the side for TT
is something that could be put in if
only for extra cards to bluff with. You
never know. I
>> mean, it's not so bad here cuz Darius
and Draven are both bigger than the
battering rams. So that is a trick that
would maybe work out here. So TT
presenting a few options here for Sam
Sherman to mull over. I see a ferris
4runner in the hand considering yet
another stacked deck. Three cards in the
right hand side, hand on the table
picked up by the left. Requires a lot of
dexterity sometimes to hold all the
cards that these purple decks do want to
have a look at. But clearly a pretty big
decision to make here cuz TT is finally
committed to a battlefield. And
generally that means they're feeling
pretty confident about winning a combat.
>> Yeah, I definitely definitely agree. And
they have the cards to defend with. Not
even only the cards, they have the runes
to defend with as well. A hidden card
already paid for and three runes up.
That is normally roughly one card for a
Draven because we are looking at
intervals of two, but it could still be
things like stack deck. That could help
us see more cards on TTA's side, which
is not great for Sam.
>> Yeah. Well, Draven going to go bot lane.
Going to go ahead and take that point
and retreat. Same trick we saw in the
previous turn. and Ferris Forrunner also
got played as the second card to proc
that Draven's ready and pop effect. I
did see a rebuke on TT in TTA's hand and
Rasa is one of the other cards in the
hand that I have seen, but these
battering rams going to do their job and
hold on to the battlefield. So, Zone
Warren's going to be scored for yet
another point. This time via holding.
>> Yeah, I mean we've seen a couple players
actually play Rossa for higher costs
than uh completely free minus a power,
but TTA is moving through his deck. I
think he is happy to wait. He's only, it
looks like, at six cards in his discard
pile. So, he's probably going to wait a
couple more turns before we see that
Rosa come down on his on his side.
>> You can see what uh very cheap might can
do for you in a game like this where
you're trying to outmuscle the mid-range
units as TTA shuffling a few more units
around, decides, you know what, looks
pretty good here at the Oblisk power.
Those units absolutely are exhausted. I
feel like TTA might be a bit as well cuz
again, it's just these small things the
game play. doesn't matter on its face,
but it can add up every now and then.
But there's that Russa we saw and that
uses vector was coming in. Not the
biggest discount ever, but not so bad.
>> Yeah, I mean it was four, but we're
threatening 18 down here at the obelisk
of power. That's a lot for Sam to deal
with right now. And I'm not fully sure
he's going to want to commit everything
to take this back.
>> Yeah, 18 down the bottom, 10 hidden card
up the top, rebuking hand that we know
about. And that's Sam D. Sherman very
likely suspects as Sam lays out lays the
units out a little more in a line just
to be able to see those might totals
cleanly and I'm sure that's for him but
I like to think that it's for us also.
>> That would be very kind of him. It looks
like we are looking at roughly 19
might could be upwards though of 23 if
you get all the triggers on Sam's side.
Darius can go to seven, Draven can go to
six. Um, and so we could see him moving
these battles, but he's got a lot to
think about. That hidden you mentioned
four runes up on TTA's side. That could
be two more spells that he plays. And
Sam has a lot to think about here.
>> Yeah, 23 with the triggers, I think, is
about where you were. And that is
correct. I was looking at Sam's board a
few times and blinking quite hard. That
number does not divide all that well
against what? Uh, oh no. Uh, 28, which
is the total might that TT has across
both battlefields here. Again, 10 up top
and 18 down the bottom. And the hidden
card is going to throw a spanner or two
into the works. I do see what looks to
be the edges of two copies of Fight or
Flight in Sam Sherman's hand all the way
on the left. And we are not scooping. I
hope we're going to a battlefield.
>> I think we are going to a battlefield. I
did also see another Darius in hand. I
don't think we've played any cards yet
on Sam's turn. So, we could still get
that Darius readied and up to fight, but
we are just going to go in first that
Obusa power with our currently 19 could
be 23 I think we agreed on versus the
eight.
>> It is 18. 19's big enough, but want to
make it a little bigger here does Sam.
So, Draven is going to get pumped and
Darius isn't ready just yet, but he
could be.
>> He could be. We do have two actions or
reactions we can play here in the
showdown could get even bigger than
that. But uh this rebuke is going to be
troublesome. Ferris 4 on a almost always
draws the eye of that particular bounce
spell.
>> So now it looks like a little more even
of a fight. 6 + 4 that's 10 + 5 is 15.
15 playing 18 is good for TT. Even if
Draven gets pumped, sorry, even if
Darius gets pumped, that's only going to
be 17. But it depends what it gets
pumped by cuz I do see a spinning axe in
Sam's hand as well.
>> We also do see fight or flight which
does mean if we could if we complete two
of them increase the might of this
Darius but also decrease the might on
TTA's side which you know two-fold win
for Sam
>> decides actually to bounce one of the
hopefuls back to base. kind of wants to
tussle with the roster and get it into
the graveyard. Not have to deal with
that very efficient sixite unit any
longer. So, this fight looking a lot
fairer. It's only 14 right now and Sam
says, "Hey, I'm currently winning. Why
don't you do something about this?" And
TA says, "Nope, I'm just going to lose.
Take out some of your units, leave a
hopeful on the battlefield, but let you
win the combat, get a point, and draw a
card."
>> Yeah, I mean, not great to lose all
those units, but I'm sure Sam doesn't
feel too bad with that card draw. He
still does have so many of his runes up.
We know that there is a Darius. We've
played one card thus far this turn,
which does mean this Darius could be
played as card number two. And that
would mean that Darius would trigger his
own ability, readying him, making him a
seven. Not enough just yet for those
battering rams on the north battlefield,
but it could be the first step to it.
>> Yeah, had to commit quite a lot of units
just to clean out that battlefield. did
successfully do so, but there's all this
might up top. There's all this might
left at home. So Sam says, I'm just
going to redeploy my Ferris 4 on here
cuz I know that's a unit that's pretty
annoying for you to deal with. And I'm
just going to pass it back. So three a
piece as far as the point totals go.
Tier is going to hold for a point here
at the Warren. So up to four currently
in the lead as far as points go and is
going to awaken the rest of the things.
I think this is really interesting by
Sam to choose to play the ferris 4runner
there and not play that second fighter
flight that we know he has in hand. That
being said, maybe knowing the fact that
there was only one, I believe one rebuke
in the main deck, but we are in game two
and we know there's a second one in the
side deck that he could have put in.
Also, we can access our own discard pile
in the miracle list because of cards
like Fizz.
>> Yeah, Fizz haven't seen too much of. Saw
it in game one. did a lot of digging
alongside Nezio but wasn't able to come
up with the cards that TTA needed to win
that game instead. It's going to be
quite a bit of might coming on through.
That is 11 as printed but one recycle
here of the rune. It's going to make it
plus two more for Draven. So 13 all told
playing 10 with Sam only having two
runes available and TT having a few more
than that. So fight or flight going to
be used on defense. Didn't want to
recycle a power does want to push the
Draven out of the combat.
>> Yeah, we do push that Draven back. We
could potentially lose this fer ferris
4runner in this battle. But if they
decide to kill the ferris 4runner and
not the nox is hopeful it would mean oh
it looks like we kill both but we could
get two baby mechs again in that in the
base.
>> Yeah those mechs do seem pretty good in
the spotlight here. So it's double axe
here. Couple of tricks here as ax is
being thrown and juggled into the air.
That's going to be plus six all told at
this particular battlefield. So it was a
four and a three. That's seven plus
three is 10 plus three is 13. And as we
pointed out already, only 10 here right
now for Sam DD Sherman. So, we're going
to have a quick fan through the trash.
Maybe just counting how many cards it
is. That certainly looks like more than
10 if there's another Rasa on the mind
for our mid-range Draven player. But the
combat does not work out, but the mechs
do get made in base. So, Ezreal going to
be the one left holding the axe at the
battlefield. TTA likely going to
reattach it to one of his units. The
question becomes which one? As Falling
Star says, I don't think so. I'm going
to take all of the Ferris Forun off the
field. Yeah, and that is a huge swing by
TTA. I mean, Sam was pretty well set up
and he had that Ferris 4Runner. Ferris
4Runner is so nice in saying, "You can
try to remove me, but you won't be able
to do it." But TTA had the one card that
was needed. Falling Star dealing three
to both of those baby mechs. Meaning Sam
is put so far behind here with no units
in even his base. I would not like to
cast a curse our Draven player on the
left, but I can't help but feel like
Miracle Draven has put itself in a
winning position here in game number
two, which is great news for Riftbound
fans across the world cuz that means we
get one more game. And that's all the
games we have room for on this
broadcast. We'll see if Sam Sherman can
mount the comeback. Mindsplitter looks
to be the draw for turn. A pretty
powerful piece to deploy in this kind of
matchup. But is it a little too late?
Seven might looking a little smaller
with things like Rasa on the horizon.
>> Yeah, that is completely true. And TTA
has gotten to look at so many of his
cards as well. This Mindsplitter may
have too many choices really to do too
much, but we will at least get the
information in hand if we decide to play
that seven might unit.
>> Looks like Kaiser, Falling Star, Darius,
Mindsplitter, Spinning Axe, and another
two Tide Turner as the last card in Sam
Sherman's hand. a lot of options to pick
from, but I'm not exactly sure what line
you're supposed to take. It's tough to
get on Battlefield this turn, certainly
in a way that feels meaningful. I guess
Darius is the way you would do that if
you feel like you want to try and win a
combo, but there are still two pesky
runes ready and waiting for TTA. So,
whatever you get up to here, it's not
going to be easy to kick off either
battlefield. And that hidden card still
up the top as well. So, if you're going
to look somewhere for a battlefield, I
think you have to look in the bottom
side on Obeliska Power. Otherwise, I
think Sam Sherman is just going to play
for a setup turn here.
>> Yeah. And I mean, we can set up with
this Darius if we But the problem is we
want to go into a power. Ezreal is
currently a six with the spinning axes,
which is slightly larger than Darius.
That being said, if Darius does get
readied, it will become a seven. It
actually looks like we're potentially
looking at the top battlefield though,
taking out a battering ram currently.
Oh, we do still go into the south
battlefield though.
>> Yeah, I like this play here. using
Falling Star to remove uh one of the
battering rams. Kind of clear that out
cuz you do have to do that at some point
and you might as well use your removal.
It's relatively efficient. Darius though
does win the exchange with Ezreal which
is nice to see. So going to draw a card,
get a point and try and even up the
point total. They may have spoken
slightly too soon cuz TTA didn't really
have anything to speak of there on the
back swing. So Darius does successfully
claim the battlefield, get the point,
hide a card, and create a situation
where Sam is crawling back the points as
TTA going to awaken and score to six. So
these next few turns looking like
they're going to be our final ones of
this game. The question is Ursay for
whom?
>> That is a great question. And Sam was
able to do all of that with still
leaving three runes up. This is a great
position to be in at least for dealing
with this turn. TTA at six points. Going
to need a couple more turns or be able
to take both battlefields
to really maneuver his way even closer
to the win.
>> How many cards does TTA have? Hasn't
really had that much of the draw
happening lately. Saw a couple called
shots earlier. We saw the Ezreal that
was really making that sing, but perhaps
another Ezreal to dig for more cards.
Now it's a Fizz looking to buy back
something here from the bin. Seal gets
have to pay for the power cost and Fizz
is going to retrieve something. Fishing
up a spell from the rubbish bin. It is
going to be called shot once more. This
time though it is going to cost two
power, not one and a half.
>> Yeah, there is no Ezreal Ezreal to be
seen here on the field for TT meaning it
is going to be at full cost. But that
being said, TTA is looking for
something. Obviously, he didn't choose
any of the other spells in his discard
pile. So the most important thing TTA is
prioritizing is finding the cards he
needs.
>> Does have a hard bargain I believe
somewhere in list. Yes, one in the main
deck would be pretty good against the
suspected spell that's hidden under the
battlefield. But just going to pass back
here after the Fizz happens. And off to
six we go for both players. Starting to
feel like a little bit precarious here.
But again, I'm not sure which way the
scales are going to tip.
>> Yeah, they're teetering back and forth
for sure here. I'm not really sure who's
going to take it just yet. We do have a
removal spell in hand. I saw that
falling star. We could potentially kill
the battering ram. And if we're able to
do so, that hidden card is suddenly just
going to have to go to the trash as
well.
>> Yeah, also trying to consider if we do
want to maybe move this Darius back and
then ready it again to go over and
conquer at the Zorn Warren, but of
course that would lose the hidden card
that Sam so lovingly placed there. So,
we'd have to reinforce first if that's
the line he wanted to look at. And
there's just not very many cheap units
to look at here. It's Kai'Sa and
Mindsplitter and Darius. None of those
cost uh costs less than four with Kaiser
being the cheapest one. One extra of
course if you want to accelerate it.
>> Yeah, I think there's like some world
where there's a play where you could go
into both battlefields if you like fire
or fighter yourself back went up and
then you could go back safe. But you
don't want to do that this turn. We're
currently at six points for TTA. So we
need to kind of hold at least one
battlefield so he can't take both next
turn.
>> Does seem to be that way. Want to at
least present some sort of threat and
the hidden card and the Darius do seem
to be just that. So it looks like four
runes are going to be turned sideways
and that to me seems like
>> Kaiser.
>> Kaiser is actually just going to
reinforce. We do want to retreat here.
And now this next card is going to ready
the Darius. And here's the falling star
we thought about. Battering ram going to
be pushed out back into the trash. That
hidden card is going to go by the
wayside along with it. And Darius is
ready to go. You can see Sam already
trying to awaken it. Hidden card goes
away. That fight off flight crumbles to
dust. And Sam now threatening to get to
six himself and set up to win on the
subsequent turn.
>> That is going to be so nice for Sam. TTA
did have to pay power to hide that
fighter flight and it's gone now.
Instead, Sam taking both sides here. It
feels nice for sure and I mean we'll
have to see what TTA can do.
>> Very delicate game.
Kind of hanging in the balance here as
Mindsplitter again. Don't have time for
that. I actually really respect that as
a discard. A great spell in many
matchups when you can be afforded the
time to cast it, but certainly not a
luxury Sam has in this particular
matchup cuz we are basically a turn away
from either player winning from this
point forward.
So far, Sam, if he holds his position,
is going to threaten to hold for the
win. The double conquer is also
available. And it's already 10 might
between the Fizz and the Draven with the
spinning ax. In fact, it's more than
that with Draven being able to recycle
maybe the one remaining fury rune that
TT has right now.
>> Yeah, it's a concern for sure. I mean,
the might that TT already has in base.
Sam is trying to figure out how to make
this a harder puzzle for TTA to figure
out next turn. We have two runes up. Do
we keep it up as almost like a mind
game? I still have cards I could play.
Or does he need to put other cards down
to, you know, reinforce his board? It
looks like we are going to go for that
reinforcement because to be fair, as
long as TT doesn't take both sides or
both battlefields, we still do have
another turn.
>> Yeah, Overzel fan and spinning axe were
kind of the two choices there for Sam to
make and decide that Overz fans
protection on that top battlefield was
more worthwhile. But Rebuke is going to
push Kaiser away and I would be
terrified.
>> I think I would be as well. We could
play the hidden here. Uh and assuming
it's fight or flight save Kai'Sa, but if
TTA can take both sides, it won't
matter. The game will be over.
>> That's why I'd be terrified cuz this
hidden card is going to go away one way
or the other most likely. And Rebuke
kind of Rebuke especially that quickly
kind of sells to me that TTA feels like
he's found a line to win this game and
push us to a final one. But we'll have
to find out cuz if he can't find it, Sam
is going to get awfully close to winning
his second match in a row and being
crowned the champion of Las Vegas.
>> Yeah, let's see.
>> The tide turner is a tide turner
swapping with the Darius. Very opportune
moment now going to make the might even
better at that battlefield. Does kind of
move the power around. doesn't change
the totals too much, but is it going to
present more threat at the Warren? And
Draven, sorry, is going to go straight
in there and try and pick a fight.
>> Yeah, it's going to be six to five right
now. Uh, which is going to be enough to
kill that Darius, but that does divide
the might. Oh no. And yeah, that is
going to be gained from that fight or
flight. Fizz will be able to kill the
tide turner. And that's the two points
TTA needed this turn to be able to win.
We're going to game three.
>> We found the land for game three. I said
TGA felt like he was in a winning
position and I suppose after a few turns
I was proven correct. Thank goodness the
player would never have forgiven me if I
had cast a curse then. But we are going
to get one final game here in Las Vegas.
There are so many matches of Riftbound
played. Hundreds and hundreds round upon
round. Again,
1,700 players or so at this event. very
similar to the numbers at Balonia as far
as players that signed up to win some
best of to get a qualifying slot to a
regional by finishing top 64 and to of
course maybe win it all here in top
eight. We'll go back to the sideboards
once the players are thinking is my deck
in a spot where I want it to be.
>> Yeah, it's a great question. And what
knowledge did I gain last this in this
last match that is going to help me
figure out exactly the pieces I need? I
mean, there's so many different
questions. I mean, obviously, Rebuke did
seem to come in. I think I saw two
different Rebukes uh
>> during last game.
>> I almost assured that we'd want Rebuke
in this match up given how annoying
Ferris 4Runner is. I actually don't
believe I don't think I saw 4Runner,
which is a card I thought maybe TT want
access to. We did see at least one
mindsitter. So, uh Sam clearly bought at
least one of those in. Didn't spot a
thermmo beam. Didn't really see hard
bargain, although not sure how valuable
it is in this matchup. Certainly some
spots where it's really good, but it's
not always overperforming. And the
shovel, um, it's only a one for both
teams, but sorry, both players, but
didn't see that one here either. Have to
think that that's got enough power,
especially as the game kind of pushes on
that you probably want access to the
effect, although it is a little bit
slow. And I think the tempo of this game
is really interesting cuz Sam's deck is
very consistent. constantly applying
very similar numbers, very similar
pressure, really great output, good
might, and of course continually
snowballing an advantage while
triggering Draven's legend ability. On
the other side, again, Miracle more
explosive, but a little more
inconsistent. And TT had a much more
explosive beginning to that game. There
are many battering rams played in this
game, but if that doesn't happen, I
don't think the average might that TA is
going to muster in the section of the
game where Sam is kind of ready to
really be pushing is going to outmuscle
the units that Sam has access to. Yeah,
I think that's a great point. TTA had so
many fantastic turns, you know, getting
that was basically his two cost on his
turn one. Thanks had Obless stacked into
Nox's hopeful. I don't think you can get
a better turn one. And then also, we had
the seal of discord into Ezreal into
scrap heap. Just so many different
things there that led to TTA's win. I'm
really interested to see if we can do it
again. And I know TT is gonna want to
find a two drop, but he just doesn't
have as many as as Sam does.
>> Yeah, also going to be going second here
in this final game. So, uh going to be a
little bit uh behind the eightball, if
you will, to start this one off. And
again, that's okay. Miracle often in
spots where it does feel a little bit
behind, but Sam has saved, I would say,
the best for last here in game three. I
talked about how Rever feels like so
often the opening battlefield for
Draven. Sam saving it for the final
moments of this grand final. And all of
a sudden,
moving into battlefields is going to
feel like a really gross prospect if you
ever have to go to the row.
>> Yeah, I mean that's a great point.
Reaver's row is so strong and tangent
with that Draven ability. But also the
other thing is is Sam can just keep
building might in his base. he can
protect what'sever in the reaver's row
and hopefully convince his opponent to
give him some combat draws as well,
which will be nice. And we'll also have
that obla power with an extra energy for
our turn one that will help us get set
up early and hopefully get, you know,
off to the races.
>> I actually kind of like Obl going
second. Need to find a unit early and at
least you know you have one in your
chosen champion zone. But it is game
three and that is our final game of the
weekend. But we have taken quite the
long road to get here. And now only one
Draven can remain. Will it be TTA on
Miracle Draven or will it be Sam D
Sherman on mid-range?
>> Yeah, we'll have to find out. This is
the last match that will decide it. And
I cannot wait to not only see our winner
of the tournament, but the best Draven
we
>> That's true. You do get to be the best
Draven. That means winning the best of
prize, which is very valuable on top of
it all. So stack deck to kick things
off. We have seen this opener so many
times from Dravens and Ezreals alike.
>> I am. Yeah, I mean it's always nice to
get to pick the cards that'll come to
your hand and you get to look at three
to choose the best one for your hand
here. It does look like we do find a
twoc cost and it is going to be that
treasure hunter. We saw that last round
for Sam. I don't think we saw it any of
the last two games, but generating that
gold early, it's not as nice as a seal,
per se, but we will just get it from
moving, which is pretty economical.
>> It does the thing you wanted to do,
which is get points early on the board.
Get yourself some gold. Again, Sam does
not have seals, so this gold nice is
good. And Falling Star immediately
committed here by Sam. Does not want the
early game to go anywhere other than
his.
>> Yeah, that is a fantastic turn two for
Sam. That falling star does cost us a
bit of power, but I mean to take the
wind out of TTA's cells, I think it's
worth it.
>> I mean, look, mid-range is often a deck
that can kind of be like a little bit
more slow, but in this matchup, Sam
absolutely is the aggressor. Once again
on Battlefield early, wants to play the
earlier drops that they put in his deck
and wants to do something before the
engine can really get online. But bad
news is that seal the discord is going
to kick things off here. So, TT already
finding the pieces. Ezreal, I know, is
going to be the follow up here as well.
starting to already
have the question we're going to have to
ask ourselves.
>> And we discard an Ezreal though. I don't
know if I should read that as a great
hand or a terrible one when it's only
our turn two. I'd want to see a scrap
heap obviously to get extra card draw.
Later in the game, I'd say we must have
a great one. But this early,
>> the one card we only need to be thinking
of is Battering Ram. That is the only
thing you want here early on in the
game. And there's an Oxis hopeful just
barely missing out on the five might but
four ain't bad as Sam Sherman awakens
everything gets a point for holding and
starts to push forward because again
time is not on your side.
>> It is not. Sam's going to want to try to
finish this game early or at least be
able to get an early lead here. It's a
bit difficult obviously because TTA is
already finding its units. It was able
to find at least somewhat of a
discounted unit with that Legion keyword
on Nox's hopeful, but it wasn't the
battering ram that he really wanted.
>> Ezreal and this seal also sets up cold
shot to be played at maximum efficiency.
So, lots of things for Sam to worry
about on subsequent turns. For now, just
trying to puzzle out what we want to do
with this hand cuz this hand
kind of sucks. It's Darius Darius
Mindsplitter and all of those cost more
energy than Sam currently has in play.
And this is the impact of that falling
star. Yeah, that is rough. It looks like
those two power will come back to bite
us. We could play a single Darius for
five for one, but we won't be able to
get to use the the written text on the
card, which is to ready it, get that
seven, potentially take another point.
But if we really wanted to do that, we
could have. Nox is hopeful was ready in
our base. And so, actually, we are
choosing here, making a conscious
decision not to take that third point.
>> Yeah, again, even with Razor giving you
a pretty easy avenue out. You don't want
to lose combat to the Draven. So good on
Earth today for remembering the energy
cost of Dyus, which I think is something
I've forgotten twice already in this
grand finals, but it's been a long
weekend. That's going to be my excuse.
I'm sticking to it as Sam setting up the
units in the middle of the game. It's
almost that's almost like that's
something that a deck that's labeled
mid-range would want to do. But TTA,
what's next? A second seal. Always
delicious in these Miracle lists.
>> Yeah, Miracle wants to get these seals
done as quick as possible. And that seal
is already going to pay for itself to
some ex well no it's a different color.
Uh but we are going to be able to see
that fallen star come down uh and to
start clearing out different things. We
see that Darius that we just paid for
going into the trash already.
>> Yeah. Again not a great hand for Sam. So
just committing a big unit and getting a
falling star pretty efficiently as TT I
think for the most part realizes I just
need to buy time. I love cards. I want
to draw them. But the only way I'm going
to do that is if Sam commits to a
battlefield that I don't think he really
should have. So Sam again being careful,
wanting to get points where he can, but
not wanting to overextend and give card
draws over to the Draven. That really is
the name of the game when you play
against this deck as try as hard as you
can to not let your opponent's Draven
legend trigger.
>> Yeah, I would definitely agree. And Sam
is playing that miniame here between all
of these actions. That conscious
decision to stay back. It does look like
Mindsitter is coming down and only two
cards in TTA's hand is showing us that
Sam is playing it successfully. He's
starving TTA of cards even though maybe
he could access them in different ways.
He's not just yet.
>> I almost wonder if that's a little tiny
mistake again from TTA cuz could have
responded with the spinning ax before
the mind spplitter trigger did go off.
You have to think that might would have
been pretty valuable on one of your
units but just giving your opponent the
ch the choice of what card you want to
take. Twitter is pretty good. Maybe it's
a card you want to hold on to. So offer
up the axe to your opponent here on the
mindslitter, but certainly didn't seem
to consider an option you wanted to
take. So maybe decided that already knew
if mine splitter does come. I have no
interest in playing this axe, but is
going to lose it as a result.
>> Yeah, and TA does only run two spinning
axes. So that's half of them already
gone. That mind spplitter is so strong
being able to discard card discard a
card from your opponent's hand. And I
mean, we also now know it's just a
switcheroo. We don't have to worry too
much.
>> Yeah, I mean, next hidden card is going
to be a little bit more obvious. And
more than anything else, TT is just so
down on resources in terms of cards in
hand. Miracle, a deck that draws so many
cards, usually has their hand full to
the brim, but not in this case. It's one
measly card. My goodness, that is almost
a perfect draw. Cold shot off the
topping. It's either smile on TTA's
face. That is exactly what he needed to
kick himself back into this game.
>> Yeah, he's going to get to look at four
different cards and choose two of them.
Uh, which is going to be really, really
nice here. Going from only two cards in
a hand to three.
>> Part of greed pretty good. I've heard
from some reliable sources. Arasa now
getting spotted as well. Not too
expensive. Discounted by six right now.
Four isn't the the best, but it's
certainly not the worst if TT wants to
add a little bit more might to this
battlefield. And still a seal of discord
up and available to pay that power cost
nice and conveniently. And again, there
is a mind spplitter across the other
side in the base of Sam. So knows that
there's a pretty big unit that you have
to contend with very very soon.
>> Yeah. And there's even a chance, right,
that Sam could have a second one. There
were two minds in his side deck. He
could have potentially put in both of
them into his deck here for this game
three. So TT I mean he's only has to
look out for one but he does have to
look out for that one. I
>> think TT reached for a gold because I
think he assumed it was Draven that was
coming in to win that combat. No, it's
Ezreal with three might versus the one
of Treasure Hunter that does take the
exit offered by Revis. But that does
mean Draven is winning a combat. Drawing
TT card and scoring his first point of
this game. Going to be a little bit of a
climb back here as falling star going to
recycle both of the fury runes and
taking out the hopeful
four val four might value taken out by
six damage. Not exactly the rate the
exchange rate you're looking for. But at
this point you kind of do have to again
buy yourself more time.
>> Mhm. And we take it out and we get our
own Noxis hopeful and a battering ram as
well. We're just adding so much might to
our base. Really developing our board so
that we can hopefully I mean come back
to some extent with Sam is at three but
also just establish oursel in a way that
Sam can't take this game.
>> That was a really good turn from TTA.
Hides a card on on the battlefield with
Ezreal by using the seal. Removes one of
the problem units again. Presumably
hides a fight or flight to challenge the
mind spplitter from coming in down onto
the revis row. And the traveling
merchant with no cards in hand says
discard a card. Draw a card. You just
get to draw a card if you have no cards
to discard. Yeah, that is a fantastic
part of traveling merchant. I think the
saying is like do as much as you can. So
if you can't discard, that's fine, but
you can still draw.
>> And exactly that's music to Draven's
ears. I mean really every player's ear
is everybody loves drawing cards or at
least you should if you're out there
slinging spells wherever you are in the
world watching. Thank you so much for
joining us all by the way. We are almost
70 minutes into our finals and game
three has been a treat so far. But we
can only crown one champion and there is
still some game to be played. We are far
away from the end of this game as it
hangs delicately in the balance between
our two Dravens.
>> Yeah, these Dravens are feeling the
pressure. Every decision they make could
honestly lead to the end here and we'll
have to see what they decide. I mean,
there's a couple cards in Sam's hand. I
do believe I see at least one tide
turner, a Darius, that spinning axe, and
maybe a
what is the last one?
>> Fight or flight.
>> Ah, fight or flight there. So many great
cards that can help us, but we have to
choose what to do this turn.
>> Feel like, you know, I've uh been
casting a lot of rift a weekend where I
can see the little lantern in the guy's
hand in fighter flight and know exactly
what the card art is. But that's a
result of covering many matches of rift
on fuel which has been a wonderful
experience I might add. But before we
get a little too poetic in the booth,
let's have mind spplitter move on in and
force the action. Is it a fight or
flight? It is not. It's switcheroo.
That's just about as good. In fact, I
think Sam would have known what it was
cuz saw the switcheroo off the mind
spplitter and just decides, you know
what? I'm going to win the combo anyway
by popping fight or flight. Now my mind
spplitter is on the reaver zero and I'm
the one drawing a card. Yeah, I mean he
was prepared with that fight or flight.
He had an idea what was there and so he
could deal with it very quickly. And now
I believe we won the combat. So we'll
get to draw a card and get our point.
>> Yeah, Sam a little more astute than to
me actually 100% knew what that card was
after the information from Mindsplitter
because TTA wanted to empty their hand
first before the traveling merchant went
off. And again, that little bit of
maximizing value eking out a little bit
more of an edge did give Sam a slight
bit of additional information. I think
regardless would have been pretty happy
with the exchange and now Darius is
going to come down to cut down the
spinning merchant and that merchant is
goodbye. That's seven might to two.
That's a very easy win for Draven. And
yet another card for Sam D Sherman. And
what did we say Ursa? What's the one
thing you don't want to do in a Draven
mirror?
>> Don't let Draven win the combat.
>> Don't let Draven win the combat cuz
drawing cards just snowballs the game to
a point where Sam Sherman can see the
end in sight.
>> Yeah. And we are already to five points
now. Getting closer and closer to eight,
but also starting to pull away from TTA.
And so I mean, we're looking kind of
nice. Five potentially seven. Well,
let's just say five might in our top
battlefield since we only have one rune
up and it's looking like eight in the
bottom. And that hidden card, it's it's
scary.
>> 16 might at home though. So TD certainly
got some things to fight back with, but
what else is there in the hand? only had
one card to start this turn. Did draw
another one at the beginning of the
turn, but getting out getting out card
advantage honestly in this spot. And so
we're going to start by trying to
challenge the Darius here. Seven might
to five feels like a pretty easy fight
to win. And Sam Sharm going to have a
glance at the hand. Note that the hidden
card only works at the battlefield. It
hides that. And unless it's a tide
turner,
>> which is going to move the titan over
there and save the Darius. So the
combat's still going to be won. In fact,
no units going to go down here as a
result. But Sam deciding that preserving
the bottom battlefield and buffing it
up, making it more of a stronghold for
me to operate from is more important
than having a tide turner.
>> Yeah, we also get to protect this. I
mean five five cost, one power unit that
is Darius. Darius is such a big a big
hefty unit. So it's really nice to be
able to protect it there and only
sacrifice this the tide turner.
>> Yes, tide turner. One of the cards you
can play from the other battlefield. So,
uh, what I said about hidden is not
incorrect. Just didn't apply it fully
considering all the cards that Sam would
have had access to.
>> That is very true. And now we're trying
to figure out what to do with Reaver's
Row. I'm sure TT had a game plan for
both of those battlefields, but I don't
think he was expecting Tide Turner when
he was initially doing his math, which
means he's going to have to recount and
refigure it out. And it looks like
potentially we're going for a hold up in
Obelisk. We're going to play a couple
more cards. Since Ezreal is at risk
there in the top battlefield, we'll play
a second in our base.
>> Also turning the same trick with the
traveling merchant. Same thing. Discard
a card, draw two cards. When you can't
discard, you just get to draw two.
Feeling pretty good as far as the value
goes. But is it in time at six points
now for Sam Sherman and TTA going to
have to have a massive miracle turn to
turn this game around? cuz slowly but
surely mid-range Draven is just plugging
away at the points and I would be very
scared if my opponent fanned out 11
might at the top battlefield and start
to have a peak into what they might get
up to there.
>> Yeah, it is definitely intimidating and
Sam can be patient here. He's at six
points which is a really really nice
number. I mean we only need two more. We
can decide either to try to conquer both
in future turns but TTA at three isn't
even threatening to win. So there is
even a chance we could decide to pull
back, but it doesn't look like that's
going to be the play. Darius comes back.
You'd think he's not ready, but two
spinning axes will be enough.
>> Certainly ready when I play when you
play a second card ready me. And those
spinning axes mean Darius is ready for
combat. That is 7 + 6. That is 13 might
crashing into the obelisk of power.
Three units get deleted off the top
battlefield and straight into the trash
for TTA. It will make Rosa easier to
cast, but there are no roots available,
so TTK can do nothing but watch his
forces fall by the wayside as Sam
Sherman is one hold away from winning
Las Vegas.
>> This is such a great spot to for San and
I am sure he is so happy right now.
>> Slowly but surely considering all the
options. What else do I have access to?
Kaiser Thermo Beam I believe that card
is. Oh no, it's Ferris 4. Excuse me.
either at couple cards across red power.
I couldn't quite make out the single
symbol with Sam's finger just barely
over the spot where this other one would
be. Now looking in the base, counting
the might at home. What do you have to
break my battlefields? Where do I want
to put this forunner? And you're at a
point where you only need to stack a
single side to win. And the mines split
is already looking pretty menacing in
the bottom lane alongside Treasure
Hunter. Yeah, I mean in Ferris 4Runner,
we do have the runes to play him to one
of these battlefields. That would be an
additional six might threatening to hold
and that would be all it takes to win.
That being said, it would completely
wipe Sam of all the runes that he has,
which would mean that TTA would have all
the knowledge that he would need to
start, you know, piecing together a plan
to come back.
>> Well, TTA doesn't know this yet, but Sam
doesn't have anything else to hand but
units to play. So, you might as well
play them. You put them in your deck for
a reason. Ferris 4runner going to be
deployed to the top battlefield and Sam
is going to say go. Can you break both
of these battlefields? If you can't, I
am going to be the champion of RQ Las
Vegas. And TT again, look for Bushwreck,
look for Russell, look for cold shots.
This turn is going to have to be
incredible to overcome the force that
Sam has assembled.
>> Yeah, he's got so much might between
these two battlefields. It's going to be
difficult for TTA to break both of them,
but he's got a lot of runes to try.
>> Bushwack.
>> Bushwack. That is exactly how you want
to start this turn. TTA is not going to
win off this, but he is going to do a
lot of damage. This needs to work for
TTA.
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean, we do also have
a lot of cards in our discard pile.
Haven't seen what TTA has exactly in his
hand. But we do have a number of big
might units. And I think the biggest one
is going to be that Rosa coming down.
Might have been a tin once upon a time,
but it's going to be a zero, but just
for one power and six more might ready
cuz of Bushwack.
>> Like the TT I think picked up the
graveyard to start counting. I was like,
it's good. I'm pretty sure it's have
more than 10. This game has been going
on for a decent amount of time. So, how
big can this Bushwack turn be? We're
going to start off by going over to the
side with a battering ram and hopeful
and try and challenge the smaller of the
two battlefields. And that is easy
cleanup for Sam D. Sherman is going to
retreat. The mindsplitter gives a bit
more might for later. But still, the
combat is won. And the card is drawn as
TTA is slowly but surely accumulating
more and more resources. And again, it
is called miracle for a reason cuz when
it does its thing, miraculous things
happen. Yeah, that being said, even if
TTA can bring back this tournament and
stop Sam from winning, Sam has time. TTA
will only be at five points and Sam is
just standing there at seven points even
if he loses this top battlefield.
>> Yeah, it's not it's not about having a
big turn and winning the game from that
point, although sometimes it is on the
miracle draven list. It's often creating
a situation where you do so much in in
one turn, play so many units to the
battlefields, you create an advantage
that is simply overwhelming. Scrap heap
going to be discarded here for traveling
merchant picking up two cards out of the
deal and TTA is starting to piece
together what's looking like a
completely disgusting Draven turn.
>> Yeah, I think GTA is trying to find a
card here to push or rebuke either this
Draven or Ferris 4Runner. We only really
have nine might here between Rosa and
Ezreal. And I mean we are currently
threatening I believe 17 in that Obelisk
which is a little bit too much for these
two cards to deal with right now. TTA
again needed the bushwack to have the
units enter ready. Needs more units.
Here's traveling merchant number two. We
are getting desperate here. We might be
moving just to draw another card. What
else is coming? Battering ram for two is
not the discount we would have wanted.
>> Short, right?
>> But we are up to
>> 17.
>> 16.
>> Roser is six. Never mind. Math is going
to happen later. Traveling merchants's
going to move. A cold shot gets drawn.
That is a very good one to play. It's
going to play it right now. You can see
Sam German jumping up and down in the
chair.
>> Raser is six. Ram is five. That's 11.
Ezreal is three. That's 14. Fifth. No,
you're right. It is 16. Traveling
Merchant. Two might on that unit in the
top right hand corner. It is not
treasure hunter. It is slightly bigger
than that.
>> It's cold shots going to happen. Be very
careful TTA. Don't get too excited. Put
your cards down one at a time. Draw your
things. Do not resolve your spell
incorrectly.
Tensions are high. Cold shots are being
made. and runes are going to be
recycled, but it's all going to be worth
it in the end as we recycle once more.
Cards quickly going to the hand. Brin
here thundersong to the bottom of the
deck. Not helpful here. What do we see
now? A spinning axe and a rebuke. That
seems like a very good piece to have
found. Rebuke immediately put to hand
>> and probably put to task as well.
>> Yeah, I think that is going to be the
card that TTA was looking for because
Rebuke would be a fantastic solution to
more than likely I'm going to guess
Ferris 4 Hunter. So, oh no, it's going
to be the Draven, meaning Ferris, if it
gets killed here, actually is going to
be able to create two more mech units in
the base and that can swing back next
turn.
>> Is there any more as Rasa goes to the
bin here for TTA? The mechs get made.
The mindslitter is there. The axes are
going to go away, but it's still 13
might at home for Sam Dman. The hold win
is not going to happen this time. Double
conquer probably not going to happen on
the next turn, but again Sam can have a
setup turn, let TTO go to seven and then
try and crash back for the win.
>> Yeah, Sam still has so many options
because of that early lead. And he also
is actually running three spinning axes
unlike TTA. So he does have the option
even when these two spinning axes go to
the trash that he could find another.
>> There's battering ram for one. We are
going to hide a card here as well. It is
ready thanks to the bushwack. That is
correct. Thank you judges for pointing
that out. Little chuckle from the table.
Good to see everyone still having fun
this late and this tense into a
tournament. A hidden card going to be
put on the top battlefield here. It is
10 might up top for the battleing around
the Ezreal and the traveling merchant.
And it is currently 10 + 6 is 16. So 16
versus what did I say 10? 16 versus 10
with a hidden card for TTA. This is a
position that looks good. That turn
wasn't the biggest Miracle Draven could
get, but it may just be big enough.
Yeah, and we do have 13, but we know
Darius is in hand, which is potentially
another seven if we wanted to be running
in with these different units. So, I'm
going to go on and say 20 might at
minimum that could be coming in here. I
mean, maybe not enough to clear up both
battlefields and get that win, but
again, you can hold. We can also just
take a turn to set up. These are all
options and we have so many runes. I am
loving watching these players play. You
can see they're having so much fun with
all the smiles as well. TA kind of
running out of gas at the end of it all.
Had the big turn, drew through so much
of the deck, but not a lot of resources
left and Sam is a bunch of runes and a
fist full of cards to try and answer
back with a big turn of his own. So, as
always, considerate, careful, and
deliberate here. Every decision you make
could influence whether you win or lose
this final game of Riftbound here in
Vegas.
>> This is the game that everything is
coming to. Oh my gosh. And Sam is trying
to figure out the best way to get big
might, but also potentially maybe might
this turn. Obviously, we talked about
that Darius. Uh I
>> Kai'Sa Switcheroo and one other card. I
think it's either a tie turner or a
fight or flight. Could be a treasure
hunt, I suppose. Could be a ride the
wind actually as well. And Sam says,
"You know what? Let me take a minute
here. This finals is untimed. What's in
your bin?"
>> Also, how much is in your bin is another
thing as well. I don't believe we are
far enough into our deck for it to
matter. But one additional way to get
points is to deck out your opponent. And
mir in miracle cases, it is something
that miracle decks have to watch out
for. They go through enough of their
deck that you can actually do it. And if
you have enough units on your own board,
you can run them one by one into your
opponent's battlefield and force them to
draw those cards. Yeah, certainly could,
which could be a fun way to have it all
happen. Darius though going to be the
player recycling a single power here
when you play your second card. Ready me
give me a plus two. And Kaisa going to
be accelerated here as well. So adding
might to the table right now. Not really
going to be used for the draw trigger
for the conquer cuz probably not going
to live the combat, but will at least
help win it here for Sam.
So where are we going? Yeah, it looks
like we're deciding to send only a
couple of them into this top battlefield
potentially. Darius does also get that
plus seven. Note, we are counting it
out. We're currently looking at
21 might that it looks like Sam is
potentially sending into this obelisk of
power. And it does seem that's what he's
going to do. 21
versus 10.
>> Yeah, 21 versus 10. And even minus 7 is
if one of the sevens gets pushed out by
a fight or flight, that's still 14. So
still enough to win the combat pretty
handily here. And TTA no runes
available, only this one hidden card and
it can only be so many things. In fact,
it can only be two things and one of
them does absolutely nothing in this
spot if it's that second bushwreck that
did look so good for TTA's big turn. So
Sam D. Sherman trying to cut down a few
of the units, get a card draw. We'll
actually get two draws here. one for
Draven and one for conquering a
battlefield when it will not win you the
game because you cannot win by
conquering unless you score both
battlefields on the same turn. So, as a
little treat, you get an extra card.
>> Yeah, it's definitely a nice thing to be
able to draw from this. Obviously, you'd
like to be able to win from it, but
getting that card and getting further
and further into your deck is going to
be really nice for Sam. It does look
like we are going to be killing the baby
mech and the Kai'Sa denying Sam the
ability to draw a third card from that
conquer, but it does mean that we're
going to have 14 might still in the
obelisk.
>> Yeah, pushing back the Ezreal, I think,
just for future cord shots to make those
power costs a little bit more tenable
cuz again TT are likely going to have to
dig through the deck and dig deep to
find a way back into this game cuz
already just with a single Battlefield
take and this looks impossible to try
and break through. And there are two
rebukes in Sam D. Sherman's hand. A
hidden card, a ton of might, and not a
lot left in the tank for TTA. Is this
the moment where Sam DH Sherman becomes
the champion of regional qualifier Las
Vegas?
>> Yeah, TTA's got to deal with a lot here.
He does have a number of runes and some
ways obviously to draw if he can find
the cards to do it. First one is going
to be stacked deck. Look at three and
choose one. I'm seeing fighterflight.
There is a bushwack as well, but is it
going to be a card that can help him win
or at least stop Sam from winning here?
>> If a single unit is left on that
battlefield, the game is over. Ezreal
can fight that mech. So you they will
trade. Not a great trade for you, mind
you, but at least Ezreal can deal with
that. But you don't have any other units
to really get in there. And and Draven
is still a deck that cares about combat.
And to fight, you need units to fight
with. You need forces to command. So
fight or flight a single copy is just
not going to do it. And without
Bushwack, I don't know how you ready
some units. It would have to be Bushwack
Rasarasa, but TTA just doesn't have the
resources for that. Like I'm I'm
struggling to find ways for TTA to not
lose here.
>> Yeah, I'm trying to think how many
Rosses have been played. We've seen at
least one this game. Uh but I'm not sure
if we've seen a second. This is going to
be We are checking as well. I feel like
ourselves just double-checking what is
in our discard pile, what has been
played, what we have an option to find
if we continue to dig in. It does look
like we're moving rebuke to the top. So,
there is some question if we could find
Fizz. We wouldn't actually have to find
the spell we want to because it's in our
discard pile already.
>> We are live and the venue is quite
quiet. So, I will lower my voice just a
few decibb for now and try not to talk
too much about the cards in players
hands because again, we don't want any
information going anywhere. it shouldn't
be going and I'm sure the players are
laser focused on the match in front of
them. But uh I am known for being
somewhat of a y boy from time to time
but I will reserve that for the final
moments of this game which I have to say
yesterday it seems like we are rapidly
approaching one way or the other.
>> I will try to do it with you as well
because I like to speak rather loud.
>> There will be time
>> we will get it I'm sure. Uh let's see
here. I mean this is going to be a big
moment. TTA has a lot to think about.
>> Is that TTA's deck?
Did he fan out? He's Is there five cards
left in his deck? Did he Is that Is that
real?
>> I mean, I didn't think that we were
going to see I mean that far in, but I
did mention earlier deck out is a way to
win.
>> Looking at this stack deck still. Okay,
there's going to be two more cards put
under here. I forgot we were resolving
one, so I believe took
>> Okay,
>> a uh spell that sometimes gets hidden
again. Let's reveal two and three. So
only seven. Still plenty left in the
tank. Here's Rebuke pushing away the
mine spplitter. Doesn't feel great on
the way back down, but you do need to
move units off this battlefield.
>> Yeah, but I mean, so we're having to
move things away. I think Sam is doing a
really good job at being patient. A
second fighter flight is coming from
TTA, pushing Darius back. Now it's a
three might mech being threatened as
well by a three might Ezreal. Looks like
we are taking a pause really quick just
to check here. Uh,
>> go ahead.
>> Wonder if players are talking about
>> maybe wanted to rebuke a different unit.
>> Oh no, wants to switcheroo.
>> Ah, that is such a smart thing. They do
have to choose the target for the fight
of flight. Now switcheroo is going to be
able to actually make what was going to
be a three might mech by itself at the
battlefield. A five
>> and that's it.
>> Oh my god. Andy Sherman with the switch
room at the final moment is your
champion of regional qualifier Las
Vegas. It doesn't change which unit gets
pushed, but I talked about it. See,
Ezreal was the card that could fight the
mech and the mech got just big enough to
shut off that play. What an incredible
end to what's been an amazing tournament
here, but they can only be won at the
end of the day. So, our champion, our
winner of our Blade of the Rune King
promo and Plymouth, our winner of the
best of Draven and the best Draven deck
in the room and possibly the country is
Sam D. Sherman and mid-range Draven as
he takes it all in.
>> It is so nice. You can see he is so
happy just taking a moment to really
process that lane. You can tell it was
so important to him. It is fantastic to
see these players
>> razor thin margins. This game was played
on TTA. I thought was down and out in
the latter stages of that game, but sure
showed me that Miracle had more than
enough play. But that switch, that final
hidden card that we had left in the back
of our minds and forgotten until Sam
Sherman flipped it over to win Las Vegas
as the players do the thing gamers love
to do. Chat about the games that just
happened.
>> I mean, we all love this game and
talking about it is just one way to show
it. That is for sure so cool to see
these two passionate players
fight it out at the end. Well, it has
been a long day, a long finals, and an
awfully long weekend earr. But I can't
think of anything else better than
commentating Riftbound for many, many
hours in a row because it has been a
treat to see all these different decks,
all these different legends. And even
though it was all Draven's all the way,
I think it's fair to say that Draven,
maybe some people have it draw some eye
because it is such a good deck, a
represented deck, a a deck that is
commonly a fixture of the recent metag
games in Spirit Forge. But I don't think
you can call the Draven games boring.
They are fascinating puzzles to solve in
Riftbound.
>> Yeah, it was so awesome to watch and
honestly coming down to a switcheroo was
crazy. A lot of times you think of it
almost more as a bluff, but instead it
was the deciding card. So cool to see
and we got to see all the different
types of Draven decks as well.
>> Quickly going through the deck list in
just a second as we are going to look at
our bracket one more time. Eight players
entered here in our final throws
original qualifier Las Vegas and there
can only be one at the end of the day.
Took two g took three games, excuse me,
to get over the finish line. But Sam D.
Sherman is our champion, our best of
Draven Glorious execution. And I was
trying to see just how many switcheroos
are here as there is the final best of
winner crowned right at the finish line.
>> I love this picture. He was ready to
fight it out and he did. What a great
game by both of these players. So cool
to see. Oh my gosh.
>> And I have a deck list here in my hands
today. And I've hidden it away from you
in view for one very specific reason. So
I'm going to ask you a question. How
many copies of Switcheroo does Sam D.
Sherman have?
>> Oh, jokes's on you. Pastry. I was
looking at that earlier and it is a one
only in the sideboard.
>> There is only one copy and that is all
it took for Sam D. determined to be
crowned the champion of Las Vegas Earth
today. It has been an incredible weekend
here with you. I cannot tell you as
someone that commented League of Legends
for more than a decade of my life, how
much I feel home here at Riftbound. So,
thank you very much for having me.
Please invite me back. I can't wait to
see what Riftbound has in store because
already in the early stages of this
game, it has been incredible to behold.
Yeah, watching all these players not
only get to see each other and interact
in person, have so much fun, but also
have these master classes on screen and
show us how much they love their decks
and also how great they can play. This
game has been so much fun. Can
>> Can you believe we're only two sets in?
>> Yeah, that's kind of insane. There's so
many different I mean options, so many
awesome leaders that we got to watch
today. I mean, there was a Jackson top
eight. I think we had four different
leaders. So many cool great games.
>> Well, we've had all the games. cuz we
only have a few things left to do. So
now we're going to throw it down to the
stage for our awards ceremony.
I am here with the winner of the Las
Vegas Riftbound regional qualifier, Sam
D. Sherman. I know the emotions have to
be washing over you right now. How are
you feeling after the big win?
>> I am speechless. I can't believe it. I'm
so excited. Can you tell?
>> I Yeah, I can absolutely tell it's
radiating off of you. I mean, what does
this mean to you to to be the winner
here at the end of all of it?
>> Um, I mean, I've been playing these big
tournaments in Magic for many years, and
every single time the
uh takeaway is, man, I really wish I
could win one of these things and get a
trophy. So,
um, yeah. I mean, I I can't believe it
took me one Riftbound tournament to do
what I couldn't do in
many tens of Magic tournaments.
Well, I won't hold you back from your
trophy any longer. Here is Justin with
it. Let's present you as the winner of
the Las Vegas Riftbound regional
qualifier, Sam D. Sherman.
with a whole has emptied out as
thousands of players filled this hall to
witness Rift in its peak form. There are
so many matches, so many legends, so
many stories to be told. But the end of
it all as everyone was forced to leave
the expo hall, not because they wanted
to, but because it was closing near
almost midnight here in Las Vegas, we
finally crown our champion, our best of
players, our riftbound legends. There
are so many narratives that we have
written and so many stories to still be
told. A top eight full of fearsome
competitors that came through Bolognia,
flew over to America and almost made it
happen. But at the end of the day, it is
a single man in his first major
riftbound tournament that is crowned
king of the strip. At the end of the
day, Draven may be the deck that reigns
supreme, but there is only one champion
and Sam D. Sherman can lift that trophy
high and proud as we've had one
incredible weekend. To everyone out
there watching, thank you so much for
what we have to witness here. And no
matter what you're happening, treat
yourself nicely and you have a wonderful
night.
Heat. Heat.
Heat up